Nicht schlecht. Weißt du noch, was man machen muss für Gold?
Da wunderst du dich jetzt schon. Du denkst jetzt, Gold, kann das wirklich sein?
Also das heißt, er hat Seepferdchen, Freischwimmer, Bronze, Silber und Gold.
Und ja, das habe ich alles gemacht. Man muss dann, glaube ich, relativ lange tauchen.
Ich glaube, das war die größte Herausforderung. Man muss sehr lange schwimmen,
45 Minuten oder sowas oder 60 Minuten und muss vom Dreier springen und so ein paar Sachen.
Also es ist machbar und ich bin ein guter Schwimmer.
Sehr gut.
Also es ist jetzt auch eine Weile her, dass ich das gemacht habe.
Ich kann mir dich auch.
Ich glaube mit 15 oder 16 habe ich dieses Abzeichnen gemacht.
Mit 20er Jahre, die Badehose geht über die Schulter im See, der Kopf ist niemals unter Wasser vorstand.
Nein, der Kopf ist natürlich niemals unter Wasser.
Gut, ich habe auf Instagram Seepferdchen gepostet. Leute haben mir dazu gratuliert,
dass ich jetzt mein Seepferdchen habe.
Nein, ich war der Prüfer dieser Seepferdchen.
Drei meiner Kids haben jetzt ihr Seepferdchen gemacht und ich dachte mir, ich mache ein Foto.
Natürlich nur von den Seepferdchen, nicht von den Kids. Ist doch klar,
ist doch Instagram. Verkauft doch nicht die Seelen der Kinder,
indem ich ihre Gesichter fotografiere.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Gut, apropos Techniksprünge. Ich weiß noch, dass wir im Januar 2020 ganz viel
über die CES geredet haben.
Ja. Ja.
2024 ist alles ein Turbulenzen, deswegen werden wir nicht so viel über die CES reden.
Man müsste aber eigentlich, denn zum einen gibt es jetzt eine Apple Vision Pro.
Apple natürlich naturgemäß nicht so oft der CES vertreten.
Die machen ja ihr eigenes Ding. Aber Samsung hat auf der Konferenz dort in Las
Vegas transparente Mikro-LED vorgestellt.
Und jetzt denke ich natürlich, 1 plus 1 ist 100.
Sowas wie die Vision Pro, aber nicht mehr mit Kameras repräsentieren,
was man in echt sieht, sondern man sieht einfach in echt durch ein Glas und
dann wird aber trotzdem entsprechend vor dem Auge abgebildet und so weiter,
was man augmentet, erweitert, wie auch immer. Ja.
So und in der Hinsicht ist glaube ich dieser Januar 2024, um das ganz kurz abzuhandeln,
ein wirklich tiefgreifender Monat, denn das ist ein echter Paradigmenwechsel
in der Mensch-Computer.
Wir wollen nicht darüber reden, dass Elon Musk jetzt auch seinen ersten Neuralink-Chip
verpflanzt hat, wobei es schon häufiger Chips, die verpflanzt wurden, gab.
Also er stellt sich wie das Pionier da ist, aber nicht.
In der Hinsicht so viel zur Technik.
Ja, wir werden heute noch viel über Technik reden in Bezug auf TikTok.
Ich werde da ganz Erstaunliches mitbringen,
politischer Natur, wie dann auch in der Form, dass TikTok sich da sehr umgestaltet,
um die Shopping-App schlechthin zu werden.
Wir werden darüber auch sprechen. Ja, wir sollten aber auch über die Demonstrationen
und Proteste sprechen, die stattgefunden haben.
Warst du betroffen?
Ich war nicht betroffen, nein.
Ja, ich war schwer betroffen. Also dieser Bahnstreik, um da mal anzufangen,
hat mich extrem genervt, denn ich war genau dieses Wochenende in Hamburg.
Mein zweites Kind wollte König
der Löwen sehen, ich auch. Und dann hieß es 500 Kilometer mit dem Auto.
Zum Glück ein cooles Auto, aber trotzdem irgendwie nicht so wie Bahnfahren.
Schon allein, weil es zwei, drei Stunden länger dauert.
Aber wir sind ja dafür, dass gestreikt wird.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher bei der Bahn.
Warum? Ich.
Finde, es sollte andere Möglichkeiten geben. Du kennst bestimmt aus den Diskussionen
des Monats einige Versuche, wie wenn wir gegen das Management streiken,
lassen wir die Kunden einfach kostenlos mitfahren oder sowas.
Es streikt die Ticketkontrolle. Es streikt nicht der Weichensteller,
nicht der Lokführer, sondern die Ticketkontrolle. Ja.
Sowas wäre natürlich eine sehr subversive Möglichkeit. Ich weiß nicht,
ob das durchführbar ist, weil wir die Ticketkontrolleure mitspielen müssen,
die nicht, glaube ich, dann alle von der GDL vertreten werden.
Also da wird es schon kompliziert, das zu machen.
Insofern kann ich jeden verstehen, der sagt, das kommt mir aber gerade blöd.
Und ich war auch froh, selbstredend, dass ich dann in dem Zeitraum ausgerechnet
keinen Vortrag hatte, mussten nirgends hin.
Aber ich habe trotzdem sehr großes Verständnis dafür, denn es ist ja die einzige
Möglichkeit, Beziehungsweise man kann ja sagen, sie müssten ja nicht streiken,
wenn die Bahn einlenken würde, was sie ja dann nicht tut oder sie lässt ja sehr
lange das dann eskalieren.
Also dieser Streik wurde ja dann ein bisschen vorzeitig beendet,
aber man hat ja dann doch erstmal für einige Tage Ausfälle produziert.
Ja, aber die Streikgeschichte lebt doch eigentlich davon, dass der Streik das
Ziel hat, die Kapitaleigner zu schädigen.
Also Streik bedeutet keine Arbeit, kein Umsatz, kein Gewinnen und so weiter.
Das ist bei der Bahn nicht so. Das Management hängt nicht davon ab,
ob die Bahn fährt. Das ist ja das große Drama, was wir auch mitbekommen haben.
Dass die Boni einfach ausgezahlt werden, weil der Zug war pünktlich,
weil er geht nicht in die Unpünktlichkeitsstatistik, weil er ist vor Hannover
einfach umgekehrt und als pünktlicher Zug wieder zurückgefahren nach Passau oder so.
Also das geht ja eh alles drunter drüber und Mois Höfgen hat ja auch nochmal
schlüssig vorgerechnet, ein Bahnstreiktag kostet die Bahn 25 Millionen,
sechs Tage bedeutet so und so viel Geld man hätte.
Hätte also aus allein des Schadens, der jetzt entstanden ist,
diesen sozusagen Opportunitätskosten, dass das Management da einfach stramm
bleibt, hätte man alle Forderungen begleichen können. Weil so viele Lokführer sind es ja nicht.
Und da sehe ich, okay, dann ist irgendwas viel spezifiziert.
Also dafür ein Land lahmzulegen,
dass man das Geld ohnehin verbrennt, um dass man da streitet,
nur um am Ende so Punktsiege auf Fatznet Seite 1 zu machen, ist irgendwie nicht
die richtige Konstellation.
Nur dafür können ja die DGDL-Leute nichts. die Konstellation so ist.
Also die können diese Konstellation ja nicht ändern. Das ist ja die Frage,
wie würde man das dann eigentlich aufbauen, dass man in anderer Weise auf sowas
reagiert, als wenn es höhere Lohnforderungen gibt.
Ja, und da muss ich mich jetzt leider unbeliebt machen, denn Weselsky,
er wird von allen gefeiert, von mir nicht.
Denn ja, er ist ein Draufgänger, ein Über-den-Zaun-Springer.
Jemanden, der ein bisschen weiter rauslangt, als wir das üblicherweise kennen.
Aber ich finde, wenn man intern solche solche Moves macht, wie eine Fairtrade-Leiharbeitsfirma zu gründen,
um nicht mehr eine Gewerkschaft für Lokführer zu sein, sondern der Arbeitgeber
der Lokführer, sodass die Bahn nur noch frisst oder stirbt.
Hier hast du 1000 Lokführer, nimm sie oder lass es.
Also den Streik sozusagen institutionalisieren, was ich eine super Idee finde.
Dann sollte man die Aufmerksamkeit, die man im Streik hat, nutzen,
um diese neuen Modelle zu propagieren.
Und mit propagieren meine ich,
Die Gewerkschaft darf nicht ins Management eingreifen. Sie darf auch nicht solche
Leiharbeitsfirmen gründen.
Jetzt sagen alle, das muss ja vor Gericht diskutiert werden und so weiter und
so fort. Sie macht es trotzdem.
Und mir hat gefehlt, dass Weselsky vor der Kamera steht und einfach mal die
Gelegenheit, die er hat, nutzt, um uns das zu erklären, egal wie kompliziert das ist.
Also du willst keine tollen Sprüche hören?
Wirklich jede Empathie für die Leute, die von diesen Streiks betroffen sind.
Ich wollte jetzt nur zu dritt in den Musical fahren.
Aber Leute haben an Wochenenden riesige Konferenzen organisiert,
Leute aus der ganzen Welt für ihre wissenschaftlichen Tagungen organisiert und
dann kommen die auf dem letzten Kilometer irgendwie nicht nach Kassel.
Naja, es zeigt aber, dass wir es hier mit wirklich gesellschaftlich notwendiger
Arbeit zu tun haben und dann ist ja die Frage,
warum ist sie so schlecht honoriert und es wäre natürlich auch zu fragen,
Ist es mit so einem Streik allein getan oder müsste eigentlich vielmehr der
Streik verlagert werden zum Verkehrsministerium,
dass sie da in ganz anderer Weise nochmal gehen?
Mein Wunsch wäre gewesen, dass Wieselski auf der Bühne steht und sagt,
nicht sich drüber lustig macht, dass die Bahn auch sonst kein Service liefert,
dass man ja eigentlich den Streit gar nicht merken sollte oder so.
Sondern seine Botschaft hätte sein müssen, meiner Meinung nach,
liebe Menschen, die ihr hier betroffen seid, wir verhandeln hier gegen euch.
Ihr seid der Eigner der Bahn, der Staat ist der Eigner.
Wenn ihr das nicht akzeptiert, wie die Bahn gerade funktioniert,
nämlich gar nicht, dann rührt euch.
Und dann wäre das auch ein Auftrag an jeden, wie auch an mich gewesen,
dieser typische Schreibenbrief an den Bundestagsabgeordneten,
dass du gerne möchtest, dass die Leute ordentlich bezahlt werden.
Weil am Ende entscheidet darüber der Bundestag.
Die Bahn ist zu 100% gehört in dem Staat.
Sie ist ein eigenes Unternehmen, es ist jetzt nicht für die Haushaltsdebatte
so Thema, aber für den Bundestag doch schon. Und in der Hinsicht fehlt mir da
irgendwie der konstruktive Ansatz.
Ja, aber ich sehe jetzt auch nicht von gesellschaftlicher Seite aus,
dass man daran großes Interesse hat. Also nicht mal Fridays for Future oder so greift das große auf.
Also für die wäre das ja eigentlich dann die große Angelegenheit.
Das ist die große Drama des Bahnstreiks, weswegen ich das alles gar nicht leiden kann.
Ich bin wegen nichts und wieder nichts mit dem Auto nach Hamburg gefahren.
Ich hätte gerne mit dem Zug mehr gefahren.
Ja, aber das ist ja, guck, was in Frankreich mit Streiks ist,
da sind ja ganz andere...
Alltäglichen Dinge dann nicht möglich.
Jetzt fang nicht an mit dieser Romantik und so weiter. Ich will hier bewusst
einen Kontrapunkt auch gegen viele unserer Hörer setzen.
Die die ganze Zeit abfeiern, was da passiert. Ich bin nicht romantisch,
aber ich finde es schon großartig, wenn überhaupt jemand noch diese Reibung sich erlaubt.
Wenn man sich sonst viele in anderen Gewerkschaften ansieht,
zum Beispiel die, wie heißt die Vorsitzende, Fahimi oder so.
Das sind ja einfach nur Leute, die sich da wohlig eingerichtet haben in ihrer
Gewerkschafts- Funktionärsposition und hin und wieder irgendwie sozialpartnerschaftlich
ein bisschen was ausbaldowern, aber das führt nie dazu.
Dass man wirklich mal radikale Schritte geht und dass da jemand wie Wieselski
auftritt und dann mitunter das auch mit Schmackes vorträgt, das finde ich erst einmal gut.
Ja, das könnte alles sehr viel weiter gehen und ich weiß auch nicht,
wie sehr da Wieselski Kapazität noch nochmal hat in seinen eigenen Reihen,
um das nochmal anders zu organisieren.
Aber grundsätzlich muss man ja sagen, ist das ja offenbar der einzige Weg und
man sieht ja, jetzt wissen wir noch nicht, wie genau die Ergebnisse ausgefallen
sind, aber man sieht ja, es bewirkt ja etwas,
während wir das bei vielen anderen Dingen, die immer mal so getwittert werden,
nicht sehen, weil sich dort nicht etwas entsprechend mobilisiert.
Und insofern würde ich eher sagen, könnte man sich da für viele Anliegen auch
ein Vorbild dran nehmen, wenngleich ich gestehe, ja es ist natürlich sehr einfach,
wenn man die Bahn lahmlegt, dass man dann sehr viel lahmgelegt hat,
dass also der Handlungsbedarf wesentlich größer ist, als wenn irgendwo anders
ein Streik stattfindet, das ist schon so.
Kommen wir also zu diesen Traktoren, mit denen auch die Leute,
aber eins will ich noch sagen.
Auch ein Kontrapunkt. Wir haben viele tolle Operntermine dieses Jahr,
aber jetzt war ich im Musical und habe auch wieder diese Qualität zu schätzen gelernt.
Nein. hin.
Ich will noch mal als Empfehlung, es gibt für diejenigen, die Musicals mögen,
es gibt Menschen, die mögen Musicals so sehr, die,
sind so in Vereinen organisiert und stehen einfach dann auf der Bühne,
proben das ganze Jahr, fast wie so ein Tanzverein, der dann nur zum Karneval
dreimal auftritt oder so.
Da kann man sich mal umschauen. In seiner Region hier im Raum Frankfurt ist
das zum Beispiel das Musical Tomorrow und dieses Jahr gibt's Cats.
Und da sollte man nicht glauben, dass es da irgendwelche Abstriche gibt.
Die.
Die es mögen, kriegen dann auch das ganze Programm. Alle Kostüme,
alle Schminken, diese Vereine, in denen alle honorarfrei arbeiten.
Die Tickets kosten dann trotzdem 40 Euro oder so, weil man muss Lizenzen zahlen.
Webber möchte seine Kohle haben dafür, dass man Cats spielt.
Aber dafür kriegt man dann auch Cats und muss nicht bis sonst wo hinfahren.
Gegen diese Vereine habe ich gar nichts, aber gegen die Musicals an sich,
vor allem die von Andrew Lloyd Webber.
Yes, yes, yes, yes. Gut, die Traktoren.
Das hat dich auch sehr gefreut, kann ich mir denken. Was? Die Traktoren auf der Straße.
Sie haben mich zum Glück nicht betroffen, aber ich habe mir auch gedacht, was für eine Idiotie.
Irgendwer hat, ich glaube Frank Rieger oder so, hat auf Mastodon so geschrieben,
im Sinne von, naja, wenn man sich die Traktoren wegdenkt und den Bauer einzeln
auf die Straße stellt, ist so eine Bauerndemo eine von 19 Demos,
die jeden Tag in Berlin stattfindet.
Ja.
Also der Traktor macht einen Unterschied.
Die haben die Produktionsmittel in der Hand, um solche riesigen Demonstrationen zu machen.
Nur in dem Fall ihre eigenen.
Ja.
Sie sind dann mit ihren eigenen Traktoren dahin gefahren. Es gab dann auch wieder schöne Kalkulationen.
Agrardiesel 21 Cent pro Liter, die man irgendwie zurückerstattet bekommt.
Nun fährt man aber von irgendwo nach Berlin, ist also 400 Kilometer unterwegs,
ist es nicht eigentlich aufgewogen dadurch.
Und die Antwort war so, ja, irgendwie schon. Wir haben schon im Oktober 2020
sehr ausführlich über die Agrarpolitik gesprochen, denn damals wurde die jetzt
gerade gültige gemeinsame Agrarpolitik, die GAP der EU, verabschiedet.
Wir haben damals diesen Weg nachgezeichnet, wie in Brüssel entschieden wird,
aber eigentlich der Deutsche Bundestag, insbesondere der Agrarausschuss,
eine Organisation ist, in der nicht die Lobbyisten irgendwie in der Tür stehen
und nochmal einen Zuruf machen, Sondern die Lobbyisten haben selbst das Bundestagsmandat,
um dort einfach über ihre milliardenschwere Molkerei zu befinden.
Da spielt den Bauern überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Da geht es um die Molkerei,
um die Schlachterei und um die Müllerei.
Wir haben es mit Mühlen zu tun, die 10.000 Tonnen Getreide am Tag und so weiter. Ja.
Wir haben diese ganzen Agrarholdings, die haben zwischen 200.000 und 300.000
Hektar. Da geht es nicht um kleine Bauern und diese Holdings sind in den Händen
von irgendwelchen Konzernen, zum Beispiel Immobilienkonzernen.
Zum Beispiel, genau. Das ist ein breit gestreutes Anlegervermögen.
Und die Bauern, die wir auf der Straße gesehen haben, sind ganz arme Tröpfe.
Das sind Zulieferer, die die Systeme selber nicht verstehen,
in denen sie da, also schon verstehen,
aber nicht so richtig durchschauen wollen oder sich nicht trauen.
Wir hören gleich Clips dazu vom Deutschlandfunk, aber auch in der Tagesschau. Genau.
Es klingt auf den ersten Blick, also hier ein geschriebener Text,
Eva Huber, AD Berlin, es klingt auf den ersten Blick wie ein Widerspruch.
Viele Landwirte fühlen sich seit Jahren nicht ausreichend gehört.
Gleichzeitig sagen viele Experten, wie der Agrarpolitologe Peter H.
Feind, der Bauernverband und die Bauernschaft insgesamt haben einen großen Einfluss
auf die Politik. Wie ist das eigentlich zu erklären?
Genau, das ist ja genau dieses Ding. Also wir haben einen Bauernverband,
der im Bundestag selbst sitzt und gleichzeitig die Bauern auf der Straße.
Ist das gar nicht eine Einheit? Auch das wurde gar nicht richtig aufgeklärt,
wie die Bauern und dann die Produzenten von den Rohstoffen, die die Bauern erzeugen,
dass das nicht eine Einheit ist.
Ja, es wird alles rubriziert unter dem Begriff Bauern, aber das wäre in etwa
so, wenn wir sagen würden, ja wir sind Unternehmer und der Unternehmerverband
in Deutschland, der repräsentiert auch Unternehmer, also repräsentiert er uns.
Also das ist völliger Unsinn. Die Sache ist, die einen machen einen kleinen
Podcast und die anderen haben zwei, drei Großkonzerne. Genau.
Also wir, der 920er Podcast, würden niemals zusammen mit der Wetten-Das-Mannschaft
auf die Straße gehen, weil wir sagen, die Medien sind in Gefahr.
So ungefähr ist dieses Verhältnis. Die einen bespielen...
18 Millionen Menschen an dem Samstagabend einmal im Jahr und machen damit ungefähr
50.000 Mal mehr Umsatz als wir mit einem Dauerbetrieb jeden Monat einmal und so weiter.
Also das sieht zwar von außen so aus, ich dachte dann wieder,
ah ja, das ist diese, also wir sind falschen Folklorebildern auferlegen mal wieder.
Wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre lang über den Krieg der Panzer geredet und jetzt
reden wir über unser Essen der Bauer.
Und es passt aber einfach nicht zusammen, es gehört überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Sie schreibt hier noch, die Bauern fühlen sich zerrieben zwischen einerseits
starken Dünger- und Pflanzenschutzfirmen, dann werden ihre Preiseprodukte in
den Preisen diktiert, also sie fahren mit 100 Kilo Kartoffeln irgendwo hin und
er sagt, 3,80 Euro, hier hast du.
Das ist der Preis. Wir haben ja mal über die Supermärkte gesprochen in Frankreich
und da wissen wir, was da für einen Druck ausgeübt wird.
Genau, da kommen dann noch die Handelsverbände. Also es sind die Dünger- und
Pflanzenschutzfirmen, ich würde jetzt sagen auch noch das Saatgut ist ja auch noch da drin.
Die Produkte werden dann, die man hat, im Preis diktiert, weil es gibt unendlich
viele Bauern, die unendlich viel produzieren.
Dann kommen die Handelsverbände noch dazu, Lebensmittelpreise werden gedrückt.
Und die Rolle der Politik, also ob die dann noch 21 Cent irgendwie auf den Benzin
drauflegt, das ist ja dann,
wenn die Hälfte des Einkommens irgendwie sowieso schon nicht aus direkten marktwirtschaftlichen,
also wir haben es hier wie auf dem Wohnungsmarkt auch nicht mit marktwirtschaftlichen
Prinzipien zu tun. Das ist einfach durchsetzt unnötig.
Wir kommen nachher auf MeLay, wir behalten das mal im Hinterkopf,
wie das hier einzuschätzen ist.
Gut, im Deutschlandfunk hat man das so ein bisschen thematisiert.
Wir hören den Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcast vom 12.01.
Dort wird beispielsweise so diskutiert.
Es bildet sich am Markt nur, die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher sind nicht
bereit, das zu bezahlen.
Darf ich eine Sache einschieben? Ich war ja auch mal Korrespondent in Brüssel.
Und man muss natürlich im großen Kontext auch mal sehen, dass diese EU-Landwirtschaftspolitik
natürlich erst mal daher rührt, dass sie so ausgeprägt ist. Das hat eben viel
mit Versorgungssicherheit zu tun.
Die war damals in den 50er- und 60er-Jahren eine ganz andere als heute.
Heute haben wir Weltmarkt. Insofern hat sich da auch viel geändert.
Und was man auch sehen muss, dass sich natürlich auch so wenig tut im Bereich
Agrarsubventionen, liegt natürlich an großen Agrarländern,
wie zum Beispiel Frankreich, die ja den größten Teil der Subventionen auch einkassieren,
die natürlich auch einfach verhindern, dass da Reformen durchgezogen werden,
weil sie einfach politisch eben nicht machbar sind.
Und wenn wir das weiterdenken, auch mit den Flächenprämien etc.
Und über einen EU-Beitritt der Ukraine nachdenken, dann reden wir nochmal in
einer ganz anderen Form über notwendige Reformen, weil die Ukraine so groß ist,
dass ein enormer Teil der EU-Agrargelder sofort in die Ukraine fließen würde.
Aber das können wir an anderer Stelle nochmal ausführlicher besprechen.
Warum eigentlich an anderer Stelle?
Es wären über 40 Prozent, glaube ich.
Die dann an die Ukraine... Ja, aber warum eigentlich an anderer Stelle?
Das haben wir in diesem Podcast hier schon seit Jahren, seit Kriegsbeginn diskutiert.
Von allein macht ihr mal diese großen Versprechen, wir nehmen die in der EU
auf. Ihr habt ja mal die französischen und deutschen Bauern gefragt, wie die das so finden.
Wenn 40 Prozent der Agrarsubventionen an die Ukraine dann gehen.
Weil hier sind ja 40 Prozent gleich 40 Milliarden so ungefähr.
Aber gut, das wollen wir an anderer Stelle besprechen. Warum eigentlich lieber
Deutschlandfunk? Ist nicht spätestens jetzt.
Und ich meine schon fast zwei Jahre zu spät. Kann man es nicht mal thematisieren?
Und so durchzieht es sich das ganze Gespräch.
Die Gastronomie hatte Ruckwied eben auch angesprochen. Auch die solle sich solidarisieren.
Die Handwerker waren auch dabei.
Genau, in Sachsen beispielsweise sind mir auch viele Handwerker bekannt,
die auf solchen Demonstrationen waren.
Interessant fand ich da einen Fliesenleger, der im ZDF zu Wort kam,
der sich beschwerte, dass er für seine Branche gar keine Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter mehr finden würde, weil die jetzt alle lieber in die gut bezahlte
Industrie wechseln würden beziehungsweise als Nachwuchs dorthin gehen würden.
Das hat mit Agrarpolitik jetzt wenig zu tun, ist eher so ein genereller Schmerz,
glaube ich, über die Veränderung der Welt.
Die Veränderung der Welt.
Aber diese Bündungen haben wir ja überall erlebt von Argumentationen,
die eigentlich gar nicht richtig zusammenpassen.
Also wir hatten ja jetzt auch nochmal bei dieser Sendung, ich habe das nur in
Clips bei Twitter gesehen, dass irgendeine Friseurmeisterin,
die schon 57 Mal im Fernsehen aufgetreten ist, immer in Variationen mit ihren
Geschichten, nun jetzt bei Louis Klamrott war.
Weil der auch jetzt ein Arbeiteleut sein will, die dann nochmal sagt,
ja wie schlimm das ist mit dem hohen Bürgergeld.
Ich kann mir so niemanden mehr leisten, der Mindestlohn ist so hoch etc.
Wo man dann da denken muss, naja was ist denn das für ein komischer Friseursalon,
wo das alles nicht mehr finanzierbar geht.
Also ich finde das so erstaunlich, dass man und dass man dann aber nochmal daraus
schließt aus irgendeinem Geschäft, das nicht mehr so gut läuft,
das muss allein die Politik sein.
Also möglicherweise könnte man ja mal festhalten, wenn man ein Friseursalon
betreibt und ist nicht in der Lage den Mindestlohn zu zahlen,
dann macht man fundamental in der eigenen Kalkulation etwas falsch.
Also dann muss man eigentlich das Gewerbe besser abgeben, weil man nicht in der Lage ist ….
Zu rechnen. Also das ist für mich überhaupt nicht vorstellbar.
Und ich weiß ja auch, was bei Friseuren für Preise gezahlt werden.
Also ob das jetzt im dörflichen Raum ist oder im städtischen Raum, völlig egal.
Man hat ja da Spielräume und kann mehr Geld auch nehmen, wenn man es dann von
den Kunden verlangen muss. Also das ist eine völlig irre Kalkulation,
die stattfindet. Aber das haben wir ja schon gesagt.
Also ich habe es ja auch beobachtet bei Friseursalons, aber auch bei Restaurants.
Ehe man ein Euro mehr Lohn zahlt, schließt man lieber einen Tag und sagt,
wir verkaufen gar nichts mehr, weil wir uns das sonst nicht leisten können.
Und dann wundert man sich, wenn man immer weniger auf hat, dass dann die Sachen
immer mehr den Bach runter gehen.
Ich will hier nochmal deutlich sagen, ja es stimmt, wer in Deutschland selbstständig
ist, ist sehr häufig der Gelackmeiter.
Gerade die kleinen Selbstständigen ersticken in einem Wust von Bürokratie und
vergleichsweise hoch sind auch die Steuern, die Selbstständige zu zahlen haben.
Wir sind ja selber selbstständig.
Wir können das ja aus eigener Anschauung sehen. Aber wir haben jetzt nicht eine
große Buchführung zu machen, wie das jetzt bei Geschäften der Fall ist,
dass da wirklich viel Administratives stattfindet und dass diese Leute sehr
frustriert sind, das ist definitiv so.
Und natürlich hängt das auch mit einem demografischen Wandel zusammen,
dass da der Fliesenleger keine Mitarbeiter mehr bekommt, aber wenn er den Schluss
daraus zieht, ja das ist aber dumm, dass die jetzt in die Industrie gehen,
wo die mehr Geld verdienen können.
Ja, aber das ist doch wieder, was möchtest du, dann möchtest du,
also eigentlich Marktwirtschaft nur in dem Bereich, dann bitte keine Marktwirtschaft,
denn ja, Menschen gehen oft…,
Aufgrund von Preisentscheidungen irgendwo hin, sowohl als Käufer als auch als
Verkäufer ihrer Arbeitskraft und was sollen wir jetzt machen,
die Industrie auffordern, dass dort weniger Lohn gezahlt wird,
damit die Fliesenleger auch wieder Leute haben,
die dort arbeiten oder müsste es generell ein Lohnniveau anheben.
Also das ist eine solche Debattenverblödung, die wir jetzt seit Wochen erleben,
dass man es kaum noch aushalten kann.
Wir sehen das ja an dieser Diskussion hier.
Ich will das nochmal gerade sagen, weil mich das wirklich wütend macht.
Du hast jetzt gerade schon gesagt, bei den Bauern ist es keine Marktwirtschaft.
Und hier ist es auch, dass eigentlich die ganze Zeit Leute kommen und sich darüber
aufregen, dass marktwirtschaftliche Prinzipien gelten.
Sobald nämlich der Staat irgendeine Subvention oder irgendetwas zurückzieht,
schreien alle laut auf und sagen, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein.
Also wo Marktwirtschaft zugelassen wird, da sagt man, nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Aber man ist zugleich total auf dem Marktwirtschaftstrip und glaubt,
dass der Markt alles regeln kann.
Nur bitte unter der Prämisse, dass man selbst nochmal vom Staat eine Extramarkt dazu bekommt.
Wir haben es, und deswegen ist so ein Podcast hier ganz interessant,
weil du kennst ja bestimmt auch das Genre, worüber wir heute nicht reden.
Also Podcasts beginnen darüber, worüber sie nicht reden und reden dann darüber.
In diesem Podcast des Deutschlandfunk reden die ja über Sachen und dann aber
doch nicht, wie wir festgestellt haben, wir jetzt schon zweimal.
Also die Agrarsubvention und die EU-Erweiterung mit der Ukraine,
never. So, also diese Kämpfe kann man sich nicht vorstellen,
aber da müssen wir ja nicht jetzt drüber reden, sagt sie.
Dann Schmerzen in der Welt, ah ja, es sind nicht nur Bauern auf der Straße,
das Einzige, was die Leute interessiert, ist irgendwie, ja sind denn Nazis mitgelaufen?
Ja, keine Ahnung, wird das halt ewig diskutiert und so.
Ja, aber sind Handwerker mitgelaufen? Warum eigentlich? Achso,
ist das Problem doch irgendwie größer?
Das, was du jetzt ansprichst, ich würde ja mal sagen, in Deutschland einfach
mal das Wohngeld streichen.
Und dann mal gucken, wie die Vermieter reagieren.
Achso, ja.
Weil das ist ja der Sozialstaat für die Vermieter.
Ja.
Während wir im Fernsehen in der Diskussion, ja der Sozialstaat ist zu groß, sagt die CDU.
Und dann, und das ist nämlich interessant, in Klamrots Sendung sitzt die Friseurin
ja neben Carsten Linnemann.
Ich habe es nur gehört, ich weiß nicht, ob die direkt nebeneinander,
man sitzt ja auch gegenüber oder so. Ja.
Das ist ein ganz neues Konzept.
Und dann fragt ja Klamrots oder sie selber, Linnemann, was können sie denn jetzt
für mich tun? Und Lindemann sagt dann, ja das Bürgergeld streichen,
also das Bürgergeld abschaffen, sagt er.
Warum? Ja damit Leute, die sich in dieser Hängematte ausruhen,
bei ihr für den kleinen Lohn arbeiten gehen. Ja.
Das ist der Wunsch.
Nochmal ganz deutlich sagen, kein Ökonom, Ökonomie-Professor in Deutschland
oder in Europa im Amt hat zu seinen Lebzeiten eine so geringe Arbeitslosigkeit
erlebt in Deutschland wie jetzt.
Wenn man also als Carsten Linnemann auf die Idee kommt, ja, wir müssen die Leute
nur raus motivieren mit Verarmungsandrohungen in den Job,
dann sollte er sich die Leute, über die er da redet, nochmal genau angucken,
ob die sich wirklich bei der Friseurin bewerben sollten, um Erna die Haare zu schneiden.
Weil dann muss man nicht mehr davon abraten. Dann hat man einfach das Elend gesehen.
Und mit Elend meine ich, wir haben es hier sehr viel mit Leuten zu tun,
die aus Gründen bedürftig sind.
Wir können nicht verlangen, dass 100% der Menschen funktionieren.
Es sind nur mal 3,5% arbeitslos. Und 3,5% ist aber echt kein Drama.
Und wenn die alle nicht arbeitslos wären und man die sofort in Beschäftigung
bringen würde, dann hätte man erstmal da ein sehr großes Drama.
Zugleich würde man bemerken, ach, das reicht ja trotzdem nicht.
Das auch, genau. Diese Konstellation dass wir in einer Rezession sind,
Wirtschaftswachstum brauchen für unser Lebens- und Wirtschaftsmodell,
aber niemand es treiben kann, weil der Mehrwert menschlicher Arbeit einfach ausgeschöpft ist.
Das ist eine Konstellation, die ist jetzt neu und da sind wir,
ich schreibe ja ein ganzes Buch darüber, da sind wir die Pioniere von dieser
Art Neuschrumpfungsversuchung, die wir einfach machen müssen,
weil einfach die demografische Lage ist, wie sie ist.
Thema Schuldenbremse, auch darüber wird in diesem Podcast einfach gar nicht geredet.
Also sie müssen sparen, beziehungsweise eher ist ja eigentlich die Aussage, sie wollen sparen.
Das ist auch schon ein bisschen selbst auferlegtes Leid, oder?
Gut, dann sind wir jetzt natürlich bei dem Großthema Schuldenbremse.
Das wollen wir jetzt nicht vertiefen.
Es ist aber ganz interessant, es gab neulich eine Meldung von den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von dpa, da hieß es, es sei noch ein einstelliger Betrag übrig im Haushalt. Er.
Sagt einfach so einen einstelligen Betrag, meint Milliarden.
Schuldenbremse.
Ja, darüber wollen wir jetzt nicht, das wollen wir nicht vertiefen.
Also wir haben jetzt dreimal wirklich weltbewegende Themen in diesem Podcast
gehabt, über die einfach nicht gesprochen wird.
Sie werden so angedeutet, nee, nee, nee, das ist jetzt nicht das Thema.
Und ich denke, doch, genau das.
Es hängt doch nun alles miteinander. Ich würde ja sogar noch weiter gehen und
sagen, die Bauern auf der Straße ist zu Recht ein Thema über unsere Ernährung.
Wie kriegen wir jetzt, wo wir auch von künstlicher Intelligenz schachmatt gesetzt
werden, unsere kleinen Gehirne, die das machen, was die großen Computer machen,
aber mit 40 Watt und so weiter oder wie auch immer, Kalorienzufuhr und so weiter.
Das sollte doch jetzt ganz explizit mathematisiert werden.
Stattdessen gar nichts mehr thematisiert. Es wird einfach gar nichts mehr thematisiert.
Und dann passieren solche...
Mich erinnert das an diesen Witz. Ein Mann kommt von der Arbeit nach Hause und
erwischt seine Frau mit einem anderen Mann im Bett.
Die Frau blickt ihn an und sagt, du hattest doch gesagt, du kommst erst spät heute Abend nach Hause.
Und der Mann sagt, ja, aber was macht der Mann hier? Und sagt,
nee, nee, jetzt lass uns erstmal darüber reden, dass du eigentlich dachtest,
du wolltest heute Abend spät kommen. Also das andere ist jetzt nicht das Thema.
Und wir sind hier an so einem Punkt, wo man sagen kann, und ich glaube Marc
Schieritz hatte es in so einem Tweet nochmal auf den Punkt gebracht,
das alles wäre jetzt nicht passiert, wenn man nicht an dieser Schuldenbremse kleben würde.
Und deswegen kann man nur über das Thema reden, wenn man die Schuldenbremse
einbezieht. Sonst ist es völlig sinnlos.
Wir machen mal einen ganz kleinen Mini-Exkurs. Schuldenbremse Japan.
Maurice Höfgen hat dazu geschrieben, dass die japanische Notenbank die Zinsen
einfach gelassen hat, wo sie sind, bei 0 Null oder Minus, keine Ahnung.
Wir brauchen jetzt mal 4,5% Zinsen. Ach, die Bauwirtschaft geht deswegen zugrunde? Naja, kein Problem.
Genau vor einem Jahr hat die Bauwirtschaft geredet, ich sagte dann,
die sind da im Adler und auf der Bühne und sagen, wir haben noch ein Jahr,
danach ist der Bauüberhang weg, das Jahr ist jetzt rum.
Die fahren jetzt gerade voll gegen die Wand.
Es wird jetzt immer gesagt, ja der Benko ist halt so ein Idiot.
Ich habe ja diesen Hamburg Tower da jetzt auch stehen, den sollte man genau so stehen lassen.
Das ist deutsche Politik, das ist Olaf Scholz. Dieses Ding, wo unten zwei Reihen
Fassade und bei dem Rest sieht man auch, ah ja, ihr habt so eine verschwungene
Architektur gehabt, aber es passt nichts.
Hier in Frankfurt wurde das alte Polizeipräsidium verkauft für 200 Millionen Euro.
Der Investor aus Düsseldorf wollte hier Milliarden investieren. Pleite gegangen.
Das ist ein flächendeckendes Phänomen. Das kann alles pleite gehen.
Aber nur diese Geschichte.
Dieser Hallo-Tribenko.
Das mag ja sein.
Dass der da so ein bisschen… Genau.
Also da muss man sehr aufpassen. Und wie ist das, wie konnte das passieren?
Vielleicht war es tatsächlich einfach eine katastrophale falsche Politik von
Christine Lagarde in der EZB und muss man nicht auf sie zuschreiben,
das ist das ganze Gremium, Bundesbank sitzt ja da auch drin.
Jedenfalls in diesem Text ist ein ganz interessantes Zitat vom Zentralbankchef Kazuo Ueda,
der sagt, der erste bemerkenswerte Punkt ist, dass die jährliche Veränderungsrate
der Importpreise, die für den jüngsten Preisanstieg verantwortlich waren,
seit etwa dem Frühjahr dieses Jahres negativ ist.
Während bei uns immer Stress mit die Inflation und so.
Und dass sich der Anstieg der Erzeugerpreise in letzter Zeit auf etwa 0% verlangsamt
hat. Während wir, die Inflation.
Betrachtet man den Verbraucherpreisindex, also da wo ich sagen würde,
das ist wirklich ein Inflationspreis, das ist so der Warenkorb und so,
so hat sich der Preisanstieg bei Gütern, den es also auch in Japan gab,
wie Nahrungsmitteln und Waren des täglichen Bedarfs verlangsamt.
In Anbetracht dieser Entwicklung dürfte die Auswirkungen des früheren Anstiegs
der Importpreise, der die Gesamtpreise in die Höhe getrieben hat,
allmählich nachlassen, auch wenn es noch einige Zeit dauern wird.
Was ja bedeutet, während wir hier zum Supermarkt gingen, festgestellt haben,
oh krass, Inflation, ja da müssen wir jetzt mal alles torpedieren,
Hauptsache die Inflation geht runter, haben die Japaner einfach gesehen,
naja bei diesen Energiepreisen und so weiter ist es ein Preisschock.
Und wir haben ja auch jetzt schon wieder seit einem Jahr Preise unterhalb,
also beim Gas unterhalb des Niveaus vom Ukraine-Krieg und so weiter.
Hat man gesehen, ah ja, also diese Energie, diese grundlegenden Preisentwicklungen,
das war ein Preisschock. Das ist lange wieder vorbei.
Wir können also abwarten, dass sich auch die Endkundenpreise wieder da anpassen.
Erzeugerpreise in der Produktion 0%. Wir können also abwarten,
bis sich das auch im Supermarkt zeigt.
Man hat einfach abgewartet und gesagt, sagt, wir lassen es mal bei 0%,
den Preisschock, also nicht die Inflation, sondern den Preisschock halten wir
aus und das etwas höhere Niveau danach akzeptieren wir.
Wir hatten hier genau dieselbe Entwicklung, nur alle sind durchgedreht und haben
diese Zinsen da hochgejagt oder so.
Und die Japaner sagen sich einfach, wozu der Stress?
Wir verschulden uns jetzt einfach zum dritten Jahr hintereinander mit einem Staatsdefizit von 6%.
Und damit ist alles ruhig. Damit hat man die Gesellschaft einfach ruhig gehalten.
Man ist von diesen 260 auf 270 Prozent Verschuldung oder so weiter da irgendwie,
also das hat man natürlich gesehen, aber es ist jetzt kein Drama.
Während in Deutschland gestern Jubelstürme, weil der Wirtschaftsweisenrat da
sagt, naja, wenn wir unter 50 Prozent Staatsverschuldung sind,
dann gönnen wir uns mal ein Prozent und zwischen 60 und 90 gönnen wir uns einen halben Prozent.
Damit ist keine Zukunft zu bezahlen. Also es ist einfach völlig irre.
Wir wissen doch jetzt, dass wir...
Wir kapitulieren uns immer tiefer rein.
Wir haben jetzt Probleme, die wir nicht aus einem Jahr deutschem Wirtschaftswachstum
heraus bezahlen können.
Wir müssen jetzt wie jeder normale Mensch, der sich ein Haus kauft und sagt,
ich spare jetzt nicht 30 Jahre und ziehe dann erst ein, sondern ich ziehe jetzt
schon mal ein und bezahle 30 Jahre.
Dieses einfache Prinzip, was die Japaner genau richtig machen und ich empfehle
wieder, schaut euch diese aktuellen Dokus aus Tokio an.
Ihr denkt, es ist ein Science-Fiction-Film, Aber es ist einfach die Realität.
Und wir in Deutschland, ja Bahnsteig. Und es ist auch kein Unterschied zu,
die Bahn fährt sowieso nicht.
Und es ist doch erstaunlich eigentlich, dass die Inflation so niedrig ist.
Und zwar nicht wegen Zinsen oder sonst irgendwas, sondern weil wir doch gerade
sehen, dass lauter Preisanstiege stattgefunden haben aufgrund von politischen Entscheidungen.
Also beispielsweise wird die Mehrwertsteuer dann erhöht in der Gastronomie,
das heißt damit steigen die Preise, nur ist das ja nicht mit höheren Zinsen
zu bekämpfen, das ist ja völliger Unsinn, wenn man das jetzt damit bekämpfen
wollte, sondern das sind ja politische Entscheidungen.
Also obwohl die Politik laufend Preissteigerungen entscheidet,
ist die Inflation relativ niedrig und man muss ja auch noch hinzufügen,
wenn Kredite teuer sind,
dann bedeutet das ja nicht nur ein Abwürgen der Wirtschaft, sondern auch das
ist ja eine Preissteigerung wieder.
Also auch das produziert Inflation, auch das produziert ja zum Beispiel,
dass Vermieter sehr viel höhere Mieten jetzt nehmen.
Also die neue Devise ist ja jetzt im Immobilienmarkt nicht mehr,
wir haben billiges Geld, wir bauen, sondern…,
Es ist gerade zu teuer Kredite zu nehmen, wir bauen nicht, erheben aber höhere
Mieten, da wir ja sowieso schon drei Prozent bekommen würden,
wenn wir unser Geld einfach fest anlegen.
Also müssen diese drei Prozent, die man ohnehin bekäme, nochmal draufgeschlagen
werden auf die Mieten und deswegen steigen die Mieten ja in allen großen Städten so eklatant. Es.
Ist einfach alles absurd und weil wir darüber so wenig aufgeklärt sind,
weil einfach keiner eine Ahnung hat von irgendwas, passiert es dann, dass in diesem Podcast,
nee, das war der Tag vom 12., also vom selben Tage, an dem die diesen Podcast
aufgenommen haben, darf dann,
Markus Söder einfach diesen O-Ton abliefern, den die nicht weiter besprechen
und wir auch nicht, weil jeder, der uns zuhört, so ungefähr eine Ahnung hat,
wie dämlich das ist und wie doof er uns verkauft.
Aber es ist trotzdem auch, finde ich, eine kleine Kunst für sich,
wie er das immer wieder schafft, das in so runden Sätzen zu formulieren.
Ja, wichtig wäre die völlige Rücknahme dieser Beschlüsse, denn die waren einseitig
zulasten der Landwirtschaft und auch auch unangemessen, denn die Landwirtschaft
erbringt für unser Land einen enormen Beitrag.
Wir spüren auch, dass es ein Problem ist, wenn wir uns nicht mehr selbst versorgen können.
Beispielsweise bei Medikamenten. Wir haben keine Hustensäfte,
keine Antibiotika. Wir sind abhängig von Lieferketten aus dem Ausland.
Bei der Landwirtschaft, der Ernährung ist es noch anderswo.
Und deswegen wäre es auch wichtig, dass das erhalten bleibt.
Und dieser einseitige, dauerhafte Angriff auf die Landwirtschaft,
der muss zurückgenommen werden.
Und deswegen wäre das Beste, die Ampel gesteht den Fehler ein und nimmt es einfach zurück.
In meiner Welt würde jeder, der sich das anhört, lautlos lachen.
So eine Riege Journalisten, die vor ihm stehen und sagen, sorry Herr Söder,
aber da haben wir nochmal 50 Fragen.
Der.
Einseitige Angriff auf die Landwirtschaft, während man die Hälfte deren Gewinne
staatlich organisiert, egal was der Markt macht.
Eine Versorgungssicherheit, wo wir nur für den Weltmarkt produzieren.
Es ist alles absurd. Es ist wirklich schlimm. Stimmt. Gut, wir wollen noch in eine Sache reinhören.
Man hat in einem seltenen, es ist gelungen, den Stefan Gent,
das ist ein Vertreter des Handelsverbandes, also der auf der anderen Seite der
Bauern sozusagen steht und die Misere dort betrachtet.
Er ist im Deutschlandfunk Interview zu Gast und ich würde sagen,
das steht irgendwie alles für sich, wenn man da so zuhört.
Darüber kann ich sprechen mit Stefan Gent, er ist Hauptgeschäftsführer des Handelsverbands
Deutschland. Schönen guten Morgen, Herr Gent.
Ja, einen schönen guten Morgen. Sie haben ja gerade Herrn Backhaus mitgehört.
Also müssten die Bauern eigentlich eher vor der Rewe oder Aldi.
Herr Backhaus ist der Dingsminister aus Schleswig-Holstein, der am längsten
amtierende und so weiter.
Wenn einer wirklich Mitschuld ist für die Misere, dann ist das jemand wie er.
Also nicht, dass hier jemand denkt, ja gut, die Ampel ist ja neu und so,
sondern wir haben es ja wirklich tiefschürfend mit den Leuten,
die verantwortlich sind für Jahrzehnte verfehlte Politik.
Zentrale demonstrieren als gegen die Ampel. Nein, das müssen sie nicht und das
tun die Bauern auch nicht, weil sie natürlich genau die Marktverhältnisse kennen
und auch wissen, wie Preise für Milch, Butter und dergleichen zustande kommen.
Jetzt überlegen wir kurz, wenn der Herr Handelsvertreter sagt,
nein, die demonstrieren zu Recht nicht vor Rewe, denn Rewe ist gar nicht schuld.
Die Bauern wissen, wie die Preise zustande kommen.
An den Weltmärkten und selbst das Bundeskartellamt hat gerade jetzt gestern
nochmal gesagt, dass es keine unverhältnismäßige Marktmacht der Supermärkte
sieht und die Preismechanismen als solche.
Du hast dieses Höfe sterben, wo dann immer gerechnet wird, 20.000 Betriebe und
so weiter und vier Handelsketten, ne?
Da liegt keine Asymmetrie in der Macht oder so.
Es ist wirklich unglaublich.
... natürlich andere Gründe haben. Hier ist der Export, gerade bei Milch,
bei Fleisch und Produkten beispielsweise sehr hoch.
Über 50 Prozent werden hier exportiert. Und die Weltmarktpreise,
gerade bei diesen Agrarrohstoffen, bestimmen natürlich auch die Preise für die
Landwirte in Deutschland.
Und deshalb stehen sie nicht momentan, und das ist absolut auch richtig so beim
Lebensmitteleinzelhandel, diese vermeintliche Marktmacht, man spricht immer
von vier großen, dahinter stehen aber 10.000 selbstständige Kaufleute in Deutschland,
die selber entscheiden, was sie einkaufen.
Ja, das ist so bescheuert. Das ist ein Franchise-System, das ist aber trotzdem die eigene Marktmacht.
Edeka, was heißt Edeka nochmal ausgesprochen, wir haben es letztens erst nachgeguckt,
privat, das ist die Zunft der und so weiter, also dass die sich zusammenschließen ist deren Prinzip.
Kaufen. Und es ist auch die falsche Betrachtungsseite. Es geht ja hier nicht
darum, dass die vier Marken, die über dem Endverbraucher uns gegenüber mit den
Supermärkten auftreten, sondern es geht ja um Einkauf. Das heißt,
wo wären die Waren beschafft?
Und da sieht die Situation völlig anders aus. Also ich habe da vom Kartellamt
in der Vergangenheit auch schon anderes gelesen.
Das wollte ja auch schon Übernahmen in dem Bereich verhindern.
Die großen vier, die Sie jetzt auch schon angesprochen haben,
die sollen 85 Prozent des Marktes abdecken.
Und dem stehen ganz viele Erzeuger gegenüber.
Das ist doch dann eigentlich logisch, dass die Die großen Discounter am längeren
Hebel sitzen und die Macht haben, die Preise zu diktieren, weil außer ihnen
kann das ja niemand kaufen.
Oder was habe ich da falsch verstanden? Ja, das ist genau die falsche Marktbetrachtung.
Wenn man 85 Prozent meint, dann meint man damit den Verbrauchermarkt.
Das heißt, wir kennen natürlich die großen Marken, ob es Edeka,
Rewe, Aldi oder Lidl oder andere sind, natürlich Dinge über einen Endverbraucher.
Also das E in Edeka steht für Einkaufsgenossenschaft.
Die machen also genau das.
Was die Bauern nicht machen, nämlich alle gemeinsam auf den Markt aufzutreten
und zu sagen, das ist der Preis.
Wenn die Bauern das jetzt machen würden, okay. Also wenn 10.000 Bauern einfach
sagen würden, also Kartoffelpreis ist 5,80 Euro, nicht 3,80 Euro.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie nicht verstanden haben, ich nehme die wieder mit.
Dann hätten wir eine Gleichstellung.
Aber hier geht es ja um den Beschaffungsmarkt, das heißt, wo die Produkte eingekauft werden.
Und bei der Frischmilch ist es beispielsweise in Deutschland so,
dass nur 20 Prozent der in Deutschland erzeugten Frischmilch überhaupt in die
Supermarktregale gehen.
Das heißt, 80 Prozent gehen in andere Märkte, nämlich 50 Prozent in den Export
und diese 30 Prozent an die Industrie, an Großverbraucher und andere.
Sodass der Handel überhaupt keinen Einfluss alleine auf die Preise hierbei hat.
Und das wissen die Bauern sehr genau.
Das wissen die Bauern alles sehr genau.
Die Bauern wissen, es ist ein Weltmarkt, man kauft halt ab für den Weltmarkt,
der Weltmarkt ist der große Goliath, da hat man gar nichts zu sagen und so weiter.
Gent reitet ganz viel auf dem Weltmarkt rum und kommt dann mal auf den Preiskrieg
zwischen Händler und Produzenten zu sprechen?
Es geht hier nicht um Druckpotenziale der Discounter, sondern wie Sie es eben
auch schon gesagt haben, haben wir in den Zwischenstufen große Molkereibetriebe
oder wenn Sie den Fleischbereich nehmen, da sind drei große deutsche Unternehmen,
die über 50 Prozent des Marktanteils haben,
die natürlich sehr konzentriert auftreten gegenüber den Bauern,
die die Produkte anliefern.
Auf der anderen Seite haben sie eine große Ernährungsindustrie,
die häufig eben auch international aufgestellt ist.
Es sind vier, fünf große multinationale, internationale Industrieunternehmen
aus dem Ernährungsbereich,
die jetzt gerade in der Corona-Zeit und danach versucht haben,
Preiserhöhungen durchzusetzen, die der deutsche Handel nicht akzeptiert hat,
weil wir wissen, dass der Verbraucher weder bereit noch in der Lage ist,
diese höheren Preise zu zahlen.
Und dann gab es Auslistungen. In der Tat, es gab leere Supermärkte.
Also Frau Braucher ist nicht bereit, der Weltmarkt ist schuld,
du als Käufer. Das hat alles gar nichts mit dem Handelsmantel anzutun.
Stattfinden. Das hat aber nichts mit der Situation der Landwirte zu tun.
Ja, weil die gar nicht gefragt werden mehr dazu, die müssen sich dem fügen,
was da ausgekummelt wird.
Und es ist ja so interessant, dass hier nochmal so auf den Weltmarkt gezielt
wird im Sinne von, wir wollen nicht, dass da höhere Preise verlangt werden.
Wenn da aber höhere Preise verlangt würden, würden ja auch die Bauern davon
hier profitieren, denn sie müssen ja dann auch an diesem Weltmarkt ja wie immer betont teilnehmen.
Und hier tut man aber so, als sei man eigentlich der große Anwalt der Verbraucher,
weil man sich gegen diese Industriekonzerne durchsetzt, wo man aber sagen muss,
naja, was ist selbstredend auch dann der Effekt, dass die Bauern auch ganz,
ganz günstig weiterhin ihre Milch produzieren müssen.
So und jetzt macht der Gent hier mal ein ganz interessantes Eingeständnis.
Aber wäre das dann nicht Stichwort Wettbewerb eigentlich auch für die Discounter
gut oder besser, wenn der Staat das vorgeben würde, dass der Preis,
den die Bauern am Ende kriegen, mindestens kostendeckend sein muss?
Das wären ja dann gleiche Ausgangsbedingungen für alle in Deutschland.
Gut, wir haben es hier nicht mit staatlich festgelegten Preisen zu tun.
Aber in Spanien zum Beispiel gibt es das ja, so ein Gesetz, dass man sagt,
mindestens Kostendeckung.
In Spanien nicht eins zu eins, weil auch in Spanien der Weltmarktpreis für Agrarrohstoffe
natürlich maßgeblich ist.
Das heißt, die Politik kann hier gar nicht den Weltmarktpreis bestimmen.
Denn wenn Sie in Deutschland sehen, dass wir unglaubliche Mengen produzieren,
ob das Milch ist oder Fleischprodukte, wenn der Exportanteil 50 Prozent beträgt,
dann merken Sie sofort, dass im Grunde hier andere Preisabhängigkeiten da sind
und dass die Politik ja gar nicht in der Lage ist, Weltmarktpreise zu kontrollieren
und Preiskorridore vorzugeben.
Bei Milch sind es wie gesagt 20% der deutschen Milchmenge, die überhaupt nur
in die Supermarktregade fließt.
Und selbst wenn sie dort staatlich vor Ort den Preis verdoppeln würden,
würden sie die Situation auf den Höfen kaum verändern können,
weil 80% der Menge eben gar nicht im Lebensmitteleinzelhandel landen,
sondern Export und Weiterverarbeitung.
Also, die deutschen Bauern produzieren viel zu viel.
Wenn da einfach die LKWs Schlange stehen und Kartoffeln in Tonnenweise,
dann ist einfach klar, dass man sich die aussucht und dann den Preis diktiert.
Und da geht es nicht um Versorgungssicherheit, dass wir alle noch genügend Kartoffeln
haben, sondern die exportieren für den Weltmarkt.
Also man muss sich noch auf der Straße anschauen, wie das Übergewicht so verteilt
ist. Es mangelt den Deutschen nicht an Biomasse.
Wir haben Wir haben zu wenig Menschen für den Arbeitsmarkt, aber in Kilo umgerechnet sind wir zu viel.
Um es mal ganz despektierlich zu sagen. All das kann im Deutschlandfunk Politik
Podcast natürlich nicht diskutiert werden, weil man sich, letzter Clip dazu,
grundlegende Fragen stellt.
Diesen Kontext verstehen zu können, dafür bildet Journalismus die Landwirtschaft nicht adäquat ab.
Ich fand jetzt gerade interessant, dass du gesagt hast, es ist ein Bereich der
Wirtschaft. Ist dann eigentlich die Landwirtschaft richtig aufgehoben in Wirtschaftssendungen? Na klar.
Das.
Wäre eine schöne Idee.
Die Erkenntnisse tropfen vor sich hin.
Zu langsam. Hast du denn auch die Demonstrationen gegen rechts ein bisschen
verfolgt, die stattgefunden haben in den großen Städten?
Ja, kommen wir doch zu dem guten Thema. Denn während ich an den Bahnstreiks
und den Bahnprotesten kein gutes Haar lasse, da schon. Schon.
Aber nur, weil mich Matthias Quent noch mal überzeugt hat, denn man muss es
aus Sicht der AfD sehen. Wir nähern uns denen aber mal langsam.
Also Korrektiv hat diese Veröffentlichung gemacht.
Wenn man den Text liest und dann dieses Berliner Theaterstück dazu sieht.
Ich habe da nur reingeguckt, das fand ich so furchtbar.
Es ist Klamauk. Also es ist Klamauk.
Schlimmster Klamauk.
Ich verstehe das inhaltlich nicht.
Ja, das ist so dieser verzweifelte Versuch des Berliner Ensembles,
gesellschaftliche Relevanz zu erzeugen.
Und da grüße ich ganz herzlich nach Berlin. So geht das nicht.
Nee, so geht das wirklich nicht.
Es ist wahnsinnig peinlich. Löscht es lieber. Ja.
Und auch bei den, um was für ein Thema geht es hier eigentlich? Ja.
Aber das ist ja für, also wenn ich das nochmal gerade ein bisschen polemisch
zuspitzen kann, das Berliner Ensemble hat ein bürgerliches Publikum,
das sich so ein bisschen gruseln möchte und deshalb führt man dem das nochmal so auf,
das Publikum glaubt an einem wichtigen politischen Prozess mitgewirkt zu haben.
Das Berliner Ensemble kann damit ausweisen vor der Politik,
wir machen hier gesellschaftlich relevantes Theater und nicht nur Kunst und
damit ist dann allen geholfen,
die Fördergelder fließen und die Leute in Dramaturgie und Regie müssen nicht
allzu viel denken, das ist ja auch für viele ein Vorteil.
Ja, aber ich finde auch, wenn man auf eine Bühne geht…,
Wir wissen, dass das dann ein Bühnenstück ist. Man muss nicht in der 50.
Minute immer noch dazu sagen, dass man, wenn man eine Person dort anspricht,
ja die Bühnenfigur meint und nicht den Schauspieler.
Also diese Art von, ich differenziere, ich distanziere mich jetzt mal von meinem
Gegenstand, nämlich Menschenvertreibung oder sowas, ist doch gar nicht nötig. Ja.
Aber das ist ja, wenn man eigentlich die Kunst verabschiedet und nur noch ein
bisschen Tagespolitik machen will,
dann kann man eben diese eigentliche Verabredung, die es zwischen den Akteuren
auf der Bühne und den Zuschauern im Saal gibt,
nicht mehr einhalten und dann muss man die ganze Zeit markieren und sagen,
hallo, das ist natürlich so und so eine Rolle.
Also das ist etwas, wenn man das eigene Publikum so weit verblödet hat,
dann muss man irgendwann mit ihm auch wie mit kleinen Kindern umgehen. Genau.
Also es ist durchaus interessant. Wer spielt denn da im Sinne von,
das hat mir aber gut gefallen, ich will noch andere Stücke von ihm sehen,
aber ich brauche nicht den Schauspieler,
der sich von seiner Rolle distanziert. Das ist völlig daneben.
Und das zweite ist, wenn man kein Original-Wortlaut hat, den man da wiedergeben
möchte, dann muss man sich Mühe geben in seiner Textgestaltung und kann das
nicht die ganze Zeit einfach behaupten, dass man sich ja hier gerade was ausdenkt
aus der Bühne, auf der Bühne, weil ja, es ist auf der Bühne.
Ja.
Es ist nochmal, da stecken nochmal Herausforderungen für Theatermacher drin,
also ich fand das einfach gar nicht gut, zu diesem Korrektivtext selbst,
der hat ja nun einige Debatten losgeschlagen, wie zum Beispiel,
was war die Wannsee-Konferenz, Patrick Banas hat dann im Podcast mit Reinhard Müller,
im Einspruch-Podcast der FAZ, minutenlang, deswegen kann man den Clip leider
jetzt so nicht spielen, aber wir kennen die Argumente,
Also die Wannsee-Konferenz, das waren ranghohe Behördenleiter,
die während eines Krieges die Endlösung diskutiert haben.
Während jetzt ein privater, keine Ahnung, es wird ja dann auf der Bühne nochmal
thematisiert, wie der Einladende sich nicht sehr erfreut darüber zeigt,
dass doch viele vorher noch abgesagt haben und so weiter. da ist halt mehr so ein Party-Charakter.
Ach, Egon kann auch nicht kommen, schade, hoffentlich kriegen wir es noch gut
über die Bühne heute Abend und so.
Naja, und dann diskutiert man halt so in privater Runde, ohne jetzt großen politischen
Folgenreichtum, sondern mehr so einen gesellschaftlichen, was ist denn das für
eine Stimmungsmache und so weiter.
Ein Thema, das schon bei der Wannsee-Konferenz.
Ja, also wie soll man sagen, bei der Wannsee-Konferenz hat man 11 Millionen
Juden in Europa ausgemacht, die man in dem Fall gerne ermorden möchte.
Es kam dann zu 6 Millionen, das wissen wir. Und dass die Leute,
die das da verabredet haben, direkte Befehlsgewalt über ihre Verwaltung hatten
und so weiter, wissen wir auch. Doch, 1933 lebten ungefähr 500.000 Juden in Deutschland.
Wir wissen also, so wie bei dieser Remigrationsprivaten Veranstaltung ging es
also auch nicht nur um Juden und es wird ja dann im Text auch dargestellt,
wie Martin Sellner direkt sagt,
es geht hier um Ausländer, also keinen deutschen Pass, aber auch Deutsche mit
Pass, die nicht richtig assimiliert wurden.
Also Menschen, die nicht mit deutschem Pass geboren wurden, sondern ihn später erhielten.
Und er sagt, das ist sogar die wichtigste Gruppe, um die es uns geht,
inklusive der Diskussion dann vor Ort.
Aber wie soll man das dann machen? Das sind doch große juristische und politische
Hürden. Und dann sagt er, ja, ja, ja, das ist schon klar, deswegen ist das ja
auch ein Jahrzehnteprojekt und wir wollen sie eigentlich so vergrämen.
Also wir wollen die Stimmung für die so schlecht machen, so ein gesellschaftliches
Klima erzeugen, wo ich mich wieder frage, na, aber was ist denn das bitte für
ein Klima, dass so und so viele Menschen dann ausgewiesen werden,
also freiwillig gehen, das nimmt ja wohl die anderen dann auch mit in Beschlag.
Also da muss man ja grundsätzlich die Laune einfach wirklich dimmen.
Also darum geht das schon.
Um da die Leute zu vertreiben.
Also ich meine, dieser Prozess findet ja dann schon statt, wenn man solche Veröffentlichungen
sieht und sich dann im Freundes- und Bekanntenkreis unterhält mit Leuten,
die in irgendeiner Weise einen Migrationshintergrund haben, den man nie eigentlich
thematisiert, weil der gar keine Rolle spielt.
Und jetzt aber dann im Zuge eines solchen Diskurses, der von rechts diktiert wird.
Findet etwas sehr interessantes statt, nämlich eine Selbstethnisierung.
Das heißt also, die Leute, die einen Migrationshintergrund haben,
für die aber gar keine Rolle spielt und die hier in Deutschland irgendwie leben, wie sie wollen,
spielt plötzlich aber dieser Migrationshintergrund eine Rolle,
weil ihnen gesagt wird, naja, ihr seid vielleicht doch nicht richtige Deutsche
oder wir werden mal sehen, was wir mit euch anstellen in ein paar Jahren.
Und dadurch findet plötzlich eine Selbstethnisierung statt, die dazu führt,
dass man sich plötzlich auch selbst als anders erlebt und nicht der Gesellschaft zugehörig.
Und das ist sehr interessant, dass damit eine Stimmung tatsächlich geschaffen
wird, bei der man sich nur noch so halb geduldet hier empfindet.
Und das ist ja der Wunsch, den diese Leute haben und das ist ihnen ja auch im
Osten zum Teil schon geglückt.
Also da sind ja viele Landstriche, wo jetzt Freunde, die ich kenne,
die einen Migrationshintergrund haben, die sagen, da würde ich ja in 100 Jahren niemals hinziehen.
Niemals, niemals, da würde ich niemals Urlaub machen, da fahre ich mit dem Auto
durch, mache das Knöpfchen runter und bin froh, wenn ich dann irgendwo in Berlin
rauskomme. Und das ist etwas, was hier produziert wird.
Was mich erstaunt hat bei diesem Artikel von Korrektiv ist, dass eine solche
Welle auslösen konnte, weil das bedeutet ja, dass man vorher offenbar so viel
gar nicht rezipiert hat.
Also wir hatten ja im August schon über Schnellroder und Krah gesprochen und
da ging es ja um den Begriff der Remigration.
Da wurde ja Maximilian Krahl gefragt, ob er denn auch an diesem Konzept etwas
finden kann von Martin Sellner, der Remigration und dann wird ja darüber geredet
und ja und das ist ja auch ein tolles Projekt.
Also das heißt, das ist doch die ganze Zeit im Diskurs mittendrin.
Also ich kann sagen, ja, dieser Artikel hat jetzt vieles losgetreten,
deswegen ist auch nichts in dem Sinne dagegen zu sagen.
Ich finde, dass man aber den Journalisten, die jetzt da zum ersten Mal jetzt
so tun, als hätten sie da was erfahren, also wenn das wirklich so ist,
dann muss ich sagen, muss schon auch die Aufgabe sein, dass man mal ein bisschen schaut.
Und ich glaube das ganz große Problem ist bei Journalisten, dass sie sieben
Wochen irgendwelche internen Recherchen und sonst was machen,
statt einfach mal den Schnellroder-Podcast zu hören, wo die das einfach alles genau so sagen.
Die sagen da, wir wollen Remigration und da wird über diese Konzepte ganz klar
gesprochen und man muss auch nicht dann nochmal mit dem Mikro hinter anderen
AfD-Abgeordneten herrennen und fragen,
ja entschuldigen Sie, also wollen Sie auch eine Remigration?
Da werden die gerade das sagen, was ihnen opportun erscheint oder was jetzt
gerade Parteilinie ist, aber natürlich wollen die das.
Also das ist der Austausch zwischen AfD und Identitärer Bewegung,
der ist jetzt seit fast zehn Jahren bekannt.
Ich wundere mich, dass sich noch Leute wundern. Das.
Stimmt und deswegen und ich will, bevor ich das jetzt sage, sagen,
ja das ist jetzt heikel, aber wir trauen uns ja hierzu, ein paar Punkte anzusprechen,
die ansonsten bewusst umgangen werden. Dieser Vergleich mit der Wannsee-Konferenz.
Dramaturgie, die ich jetzt nicht denen bewusst unterstelle, aber wir haben es
nicht mit Behördenleitern zu tun, die auch nicht Massenmord oder Deportation geplant haben.
Und dieses Wort Deportation ist wohl auch im Korrektivtext jetzt nachträglich verschwunden.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das eine ist schlimmer als das andere,
aber ich halte es für sehr wichtig, dass man 2024 jetzt darüber diskutiert,
wie wir es ja auch anhand der KRA-Sachen schon gemacht haben.
Was bedeutet es denn, wenn die AfD sich zwar vielleicht insgeheim,
irgendwo gibt es Leute, die wünschen sich einen Holocaust oder so,
sie wissen aber, das ist nicht der Weg, sondern wir wollen die Stimmung im Land so verändern,
dass 25 Millionen Menschen freiwillig sagen, sie gehen.
Das halte ich für ein Problem, das es an sich wert genug ist zu besprechen und das hätte man auch,
sage ich jetzt etwas mutig, steckt ja nicht drin, ich respektiere und finde
es auch gut, wie die Projektivarbeit vonstatten ging und zu welchem Resultat
im Sinne von wie der Text aussieht, den sie da gemacht haben, ist.
Aber ich wünschte mir in solchen Momenten wieder jemanden wie Frank Schirrmacher,
der einfach noch etwas feinfühliger auf die Zeitläufte blickt und sagt,
nee, jetzt keine falschen, verqueren Vergleiche wecken mit der Wannsee-Konferenz,
sondern lieber auf das Thema zu sprechen kommen.
Wir haben hier keine Zukunftsperspektive und die AfD braucht das als Protestunternehmerin.
Sie braucht so eine Stimmung, die erzeugt wird durch zum Beispiel solche komischen
privaten Treffen, bei denen man ja fast auch vermuten kann, naja,
dass man solche Treffen macht, gehört ja schon dazu, eine Stimmung zu erzeugen,
bei denen Menschen Angst haben und sagen, komm, wir gehen lieber.
Ich habe das ja selber gemerkt, ich war jetzt im Januar in Jena,
habe dort einen Vortrag gehalten und kriege danach E-Mails, ja meine Freundin sagt jetzt, wir gehen.
Und zwar nur, weil ich auf der Bühne über die demografischen Grundlagen von
Thüringen gesprochen habe.
So, also man kann durchaus Leute dazu kriegen, große Lebensentscheidungen zu
treffen, wenn sie sich einfach nur anschauen, was gerade Zustand in ihrer Lebenswelt
ist und dazu gehört ja, okay, wir haben jetzt eine AfD, die sowas direkt plant,
dass die AfD noch ein bisschen fester da verwickelt war,
als einfach nur, ja, es war so diese rechte Hand von Weidel,
den sie auch aus einem Budget bezahlt, das die Partei gar nicht kennt,
sondern ihr zugestanden hat, also die kann einfach selbst drüber entscheiden
und wie auch immer, solche Sachen und ich will jetzt mal dieses,
okay, wir haben es nicht mit 1933 zu tun, sondern mit einer Ausgangslage,
die demografisch anders ist und auch eine andere Zielsetzung,
hier soll also kein Holocaust organisiert werden, sondern es soll einfach und
es betrifft uns dann alle eine Stimmung erzeugt werden, in der ein Viertel der Leute sagt, ich gehe.
Ja und das reicht doch als Aussage.
Das ist ja alles Stimmen genug.
Ich muss jetzt nicht nochmal gucken, wie nah ist das am Dritten Reich oder nicht,
sondern das ist doch so eine Horrorvision, die da ausgebreitet wird.
Die Strategie in die Zukunft gerichtet, nicht in die Vergangenheit.
Ich will gerade mit diesem Blick in die Zukunft das auch nochmal unterstreichen,
was man in den Vorträgen von Sellner sehen kann und zwar seit Jahren und ähnlich
auch bei Krah und Kubitschek ist,
dass immer wieder betont wird, wir haben 10 bis 20 Jahre Zeit und ich habe das
nie so richtig wahrgenommen, dachte immer so, ja 10 bis 20 Jahre sagen die immer
so, ist ja irgendein Zeitraum, den man mal angibt.
Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich und du hast jetzt gerade die Demografie schon angesprochen.
Schauen wir doch mal, dass wir ja sehr viel Zuwanderung in den 60er,
70er Jahren bekommen haben aus Italien, aus der Türkei, aus ein paar anderen Ländern noch.
Und was passiert dann? Zunächst einmal große Abwehr aus der Mehrheitsbevölkerung,
also je nachdem, aber ja, Warnungen an die Töchter, lasst euch nicht mit Italienern ein etc.
Kann man sich alles noch von Leuten, die in den 70er Jahren schon erwachsen
waren, erzählen, wie die Stimmung da mitunter war? Und dann erlebt man aber
jetzt, dass das keine Debatte wäre.
Also würde jetzt niemand sagen, ja ich muss jetzt mal meinen Eltern beichten,
dass ich mit einer Italienerin zusammen bin oder so.
Das wäre einfach gar kein Thema mehr. Und das erleben wir natürlich auch bei
sehr vielen anderen Menschen, die zu uns kommen, wo immer mehr Durchmischung stattfindet.
Also Leute heiraten, es gibt Freundschaften im Kollegium, es gibt also irgendwann
solche Verflechtungen,
dass man dann tatsächlich ein Einwanderungsland, ein gelebtes Einwanderungsland
ist, wo es diese Differenzierung nicht mehr gibt.
Jetzt wird von der AfD zwar eine Stimmung geschaffen, wo ich gerade sagte,
da löst man selbst Ethnisierungen aus, aber was wir hier sehen können an dieser
Perspektive 10 bis 20 Jahre bedeutet.
Natürlich sind die Leute, die 2015 zu uns gekommen sind und dann auch in den nachfolgenden Jahren,
jetzt oft noch welche, die sich selbst sehr stark ethnisieren und die auch ethnisiert
oder auch dann rassifiziert werden, die mit Rassismus belegt werden.
Wenn wir aber jetzt weitergehen und eine offene Gesellschaft bleiben oder wieder mehr werden,
dann würde natürlich in 10, 20 Jahren eine so starke Durchmischung in allen
Bereichen, also von Ehe und Kindern bis hin zu Kollegium etc.
Stattfinden, dass diese Idee einer Remigration….
So verrückt erscheint, also sie ist sowieso verrückt, aber dass sie dann so
unwirklich erscheint, wie wenn man jetzt sagen würde, ja wir müssen mal wieder sehen, dass wir,
an den Schulen die Evangelischen von den Katholischen trennen.
Da würde man sagen, viel Spaß, probier's mal.
Und hier müssen wir eigentlich jetzt sagen, also wenn die AfD sagt,
wir haben so 10 bis 20 Jahre, dann können wir, solange können wir das machen,
dieses Projekt, also können wir das versuchen.
Da müssen wir jetzt von gleicher Zukunftsperspektive drauf blicken und sagen,
also wir haben jetzt 10 bis 20 Jahre Zeit, um die Gesellschaft so zu durchmischen
in jeder Hinsicht, dass das nicht mehr möglich ist, schon deshalb, weil wir,
alle anders sind, beziehungsweise alle dann eine neue Gleichheit erleben.
Und wir nähern uns ja Aussagen von Matthias Quent zum Thema,
der ganz explizit sagen wird, ja man muss sich schon mal mit der AfD die Politik
beschäftigen und sie auch stellen.
Wenn jetzt ein Viertel der Leute, die wählen wollen, oder jeder Fünfter und
im Osten dann jeder Dritte, warum sollte man das nicht mal aufgreifen?
Ich finde ja nicht, ich habe ja schon gestern Angst bekommen,
als ich einen FAZ-Podcast gehört habe und Simon Strauß dort den Vogt,
den CDU-Chef in Thüringen fragt, ja, würden Sie in einem Reduduell mit Höcke
antreten? Vielleicht hier im Podcast oder so? Und er sagt so, ja klar.
Und da habe ich schon Angst, dass irgendwie jetzt Höcke gegen Vogt im FAZ-Podcast
zu diesem Duell antreten.
Meine Angst ist dann vor allem, dass es das Ende der Zeitung ist,
weil so ein Shitstorm würde man nicht überleben und zwar zu Recht nicht.
Aber man kann sich ja trotzdem mit der AfD-Politik mal beschäftigen,
statt sie immer nur zu moralisieren.
Und ich sage ausdrücklich, das Moralisieren ist natürlich richtig,
aber es gibt ja auch noch Argumente daneben.
Und wir lesen nachher Fratscher und Matthias Gwent, wo das sehr deutlich wird.
Würdest du denn sagen, um da gleich die Frage zu stellen, würdest du denn sagen,
dass man jetzt bei den Protesten,
Also sagen wir so, ich muss es anders machen.
Also das Argument, also nur zu moralisieren, das kann man machen,
das kann mitunter auch hilfreich sein, aber es ist vielleicht auch ganz gut,
mal wieder ein ordentliches Argument zu machen.
Aber du würdest ja wahrscheinlich dem zustimmen, wenn ich sage,
es gibt einen Teil von Leuten, die jetzt angeben in Telefonumfragen die AfD
zu wählen, die zu retten sind in irgendeiner Weise.
Also die sagen, die man vom Gegenteil überzeugen könnte, egal wie auch immer,
emotional oder mit Argumenten.
Aber wir können doch schon davon ausgehen, dass wir wahrscheinlich so 10,
12 Prozent von Leuten haben, die die AfD wählen wollen, weil sie die AfD wählen
wollen, weil sie sie gut finden und weil sie das auch gut finden,
dass die Remigration wollen,
dass die, oder ich will es nochmal überspitzen, die die AfD wählen,
weil die NSDAP gerade nicht zur Verfügung steht.
Ja, das hat man ja gesehen in diesen Straßenumfragen in Sonneberg,
kurz vor der Landratswahl dort, dass es solche Leute gibt.
Ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, die Dramaturgie, dass in dieser Mitte-Studie
oder in welcher auch immer, immer wieder festgestellt wird, 10% sind wirklich
nicht zu überzeugen und so, das hält man durchaus aus, weil 10% ist ja eine
Minderheit, die kriegt man auch gut isoliert.
Wir greifen deine Frage gleich nochmal auf, wenn wir Matthias Quent dazu hören.
Also was mit so Wechselwählern, die aber jetzt gerade AfD wählen würden, was mit denen ist.
Zum Thema Re-Migration ist hier noch zu sagen, weil du es jetzt so angesprochen
hast, das wurde ja auch im Korrektivtext deutlich, da Martin Sellner steht auf
der Bühne oder auch die anderen Typen und sagen, Ja.
Wir rechten oder rechtsradikalen Parteien streiten uns über jeden Scheiß,
aber Remigration vereinigt uns.
Also da sind wir uns alle einig. Für die ist das also ein Chiffre-Thema,
um Einigkeit herzustellen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die eine Marktforschung machen, um das rauszufinden oder
was da los ist, aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass da jemand ein bisschen genauer Bescheid weiß und deswegen dieses Thema
bewusst vorangestellt wird, weil das so den, Wir wollen einen handelnden Staat,
ja und wozu, was soll er denn handeln?
Na ja, Remigration organisieren. So irgendwie. Also dass das so die Einflugschneise
für diese Mobilisierung ist.
Nun gut, dieser demografische Vergleich, also damals Wannsee-Konferenz,
es wird also wirklich ein Massenmord auf dieser ethnischen Differenzierungsbasis organisiert.
Bei der Volkszählung 1933, bereits nach der Machtergreifung der Neonationalsozialisten,
wurden 66,2 Millionen Einwohner in Deutschland gezählt.
Da sind ungefähr 15, 16 weniger als heute. Also heute haben wir gerade jetzt 84,6.
Äh, 18 Millionen sind es. Ausländeranteil damals, das kann jeder kurz überlegen,
Ausländeranteil 1933, 1%.
Arbeitslosigkeit, kurz überlegen, 30%.
So.
Das ist eine ganz andere Ausgangslage als heute. Ausländeranteil 13%,
von denen 13% übrigens 54,2% beschäftigt. Das ist eine ganz normale Quote,
der Rest sind Alte und Kinder und so weiter.
24,3% der Bevölkerung hatten 2022 eine Einwanderungsgeschichte.
Das sind 20 Millionen Menschen.
Das sind alles Zahlen vom Statistischen Bundesamt. Die Arbeitslosigkeit heute,
damals 30 Prozent, dass das Mobilisierungspotenzial ist, gerade über so eine
ökonomische im Sinne von, naja die AfD-Wähler sind ja irgendwie so abgehängt
und so weiter, die haben Angst um die Zukunft,
naja damals war jeder Dritte war arbeitslos.
Also die hatten erst recht Grund mal so zu sagen, okay ich werfe jetzt einen
Molotow-Cocktail ins Ding, die Demokratie ist so jung und hat mir irgendwie nicht so viel gebracht.
Wir haben ja heute die Erfahrung oder die historische Geschichte,
dass die Marktwirtschaft mit der Demokratie einen Zug erhielt in Deutschland
und dann war für alle erstmal 30 Jahre Sonnenschein und die Boomer profitieren
ihr ganzes Leben davon, andere Generationen danach dann nicht.
Arbeitslosigkeit heute in Deutschland nicht 30%, sondern 3,1%. Das ist November 23.
Der 15- bis 74-Jährigen. Im EU-Vergleich war die Erwerbslosenquote nur in Polen
mit 2,8 und in Malta mit 2,5 und Tschechien 2,4 noch niedriger.
Also Deutschland, ja, wir haben ökonomische Probleme und große Transformationen
und Rezessionen und wir sind das Schlusslicht im großen OECD-Vergleich oder
was auch immer, aber Arbeitskräfte haben wir deswegen trotzdem nicht.
Also wir leiden nicht an Massenarbeitslosigkeit.
Es ist also genau nicht diese Art der Mobilisierung, die damals zur Verfügung
stand, auch wenn wir heute sagen, naja, viele Leute arbeiten und sind dann Aufstocker,
sind also abhängig vom Staat, können sich dann wie die Friseurin da bei Klamroth
doch nichts leisten und so weiter und so fort.
So, unter diesen demografischen Ausgangslagen jetzt eine Demografie über öffentliche
Stimmung zu organisieren, also eine Remigrationsdebatte anzustoßen über,
ja wir sorgen mal für so viel Disbalance,
Uneinigkeit, Streit zwischen den Ethnien, dass die Ur- und Arischdeutschen irgendwie
die Passdeutschen rausdrängen oder so. Das kann man sich ja mal anschauen.
Nehmen wir mal Thüringen. Thüringen ist ja für uns besonders interessant, weil ich daherkomme.
Hans-Georg Maaßen, der seinen Bundestagswahlkreis hatte in Suhl.
Uwe Trum, der jetzt für die AfD
im Saale-Orla-Kreis am Wochenende knapp verloren hat mit 4% Unterschied.
Robert Sesselmann, aber Landrat wurde. Björn Höcke und so weiter.
Also Thüringen ist jetzt für uns besonders interessant, aber es wäre auch insgesamt
ganz Ostdeutschland. Hier Sachsen.
Ich erkunde ja dann in Meiningen, ich gehe da ins Theater.
Erkunde Dortmund im Osten. Ja, kannst du bei der Stimmung erkunden und auch
wie so die demografische Physiognomie aussieht, wenn du im Theaterseil dich
mal umdrehst, wer im Publikum sitzt.
Gut, aber das ist ja fast ein Theater, leider so.
Aber die Zahlen sind grundsätzlich so, also hier mal sächsische.de.
So schlimm sahen die Zahlen in Görlitz schon lange nicht mehr aus.
338 neue Einwohner wurden im vorigen Jahr geboren, 669 Görlitzer starben.
Also das ist einfach ein Verhältnis von 1 zu 3.
Für Thüringen, Ostdeutschland allgemein, das Statistische Bundesamt hat hier mal so einen Text.
Damals zu Wendezeiten gab es mehr junge Menschen in Ostdeutschland,
ist ja klar, es gab ja einen Geburtenboom vor der Wende, also mehr als 2,1 Kinder pro Frau.
Damals im Osten unter 20-Jährige 25%.
Ähm, damit sehr viel mehr als im Westen.
Dann diese demografische Abwanderung. Im Zeitverlauf hat sich das Verhältnis umgekehrt.
Heute sehr viel weniger Junge im Osten, nur 18 Prozent, aber 27 Prozent Ältere, über 65-Jährige.
Im Westen nur 21 Prozent. Also da liegt einfach mal ein Viertel obendrauf an älteren Leuten.
Wir haben es also im Osten schon mit eigentlich einer demografischen Ausgangslage
zu tun, von der wir einfach sagen, hier ist Abwanderung in den letzten 30 Jahren
das größte Problem gewesen.
Die Remigration hat schon stattgefunden, willst du damit sagen?
Die Migration.
Ja.
Also wenn man eine Remigrationsdebatte anstoßen wollte, dann vielleicht die
deutsche Wende, also die deutsche Einheit irgendwie so zurückbauen,
dass diejenigen, die in den Osten gingen, wieder zurückgingen.
Nur das Problem ist, die sind ja jetzt im Rentenalter. Leute,
die vor 30 Jahren als 30-Jährige nach Westerstand gingen, um da ihr Glück zu
suchen, die sind ja heute kurz vor der Rente und will man die dann im Osten
zurück haben? Also wir haben es hier mit grundsätzlichem Problem zu tun.
Ich widerspreche dir nicht, aber du baust natürlich deine Argumentation,
wie sollte es anders sein, auf die Rationalität der Menschen auf.
Ganz genau und darauf kommen wir gleich, deswegen ja Fratscher und wir legen
hier nur den Grundstein.
Denn rational ist das ja nicht, was wir erleben.
Nee, gar nicht.
Wir hatten eben schon diesen Söder-O-Ton und wir könnten natürlich jetzt ganz
viele O-Töne von CDU-Leuten einspielen, die sich auch zum Thema AfD-Rechtsruck
äußern und dann sehen wir sehr häufig,
dass die CDU Teil des Problems ist und nicht darauf ausgelegt ist,
den Diskurs rationaler zu gestalten.
Also das heißt, was ich als große Gefahr sehe,
ist eine Gegenaufklärung oder eine Irrationalität, die sich so bahnbricht,
dass man mit den besten Zahlen kommen kann und sie sagen trotzdem,
naja, aber das geht ja nicht. Mir geht es ja um eins.
Also Remigration und Deportation mal außen vor. Das, was im Vorfeld der AfD
hier diskutiert wird, ist eine Abwanderungsbemühung.
Man möchte Leute motivieren, abzuwandern.
Wir haben Erfahrung mit Abwanderung in Ostdeutschland.
Also man kann sich das jetzt schon anschauen, was sich die AfD dort wünscht.
Bevölkerungsentwicklung in Thüringen 1990 2,8
Millionen Menschen Perspektive 2060 1,8 Millionen
Also da sind so mehr als 25% einfach
mal abgewandert Also weit mehr mit einer
ganz kleinen Ausnahme 2022 und 2015 Die beiden einzigen Jahre in denen es mal
eine positive Bevölkerungsentwicklung in Osterstein gab Das heißt für 2022 Es
sind trotzdem minus minus 20.000 Deutsche zu verbuchen, aber plus 38.000 Ausländer,
die nach Thüringen zum Beispiel gekommen sind.
Genau, also 2022 ist das Jahr des Ukraine-Kriegs.
Und 2015 war es dann auch Syrien.
Waren es die syrischen Flüchtlinge, genau. Diese Leute sind,
wie wir ja oben, also ungefähr, also 52% der Ausländer in Deutschland arbeiten.
Wenn sie gerade neu angekommen sind, dauert es natürlich ein bisschen länger,
Anlaufschwierigkeiten, erstmal Sprache lernen und so weiter.
Also perspektivisch, wenn man diese Leute ansiedelt, hat man auch wieder eine
Infrastruktur, auf die man sich sich beziehen kann, mit der man leben kann und
so weiter und so fort, dann hat man es nicht nur mit diesen Ausdehnungsprozessen zu tun.
Und für Thüringen sieht es ja nun, da hat ja Bodo Ramelow diesen Tweet,
den ich schon ein paar Mal erwähnt habe, am 26. September letzten Jahres gemacht.
Diese Karte, ich zeige sie dir nur
mal kurz, das sind die Erwerbspersonen-Potenzial-Prognosen für Thüringen.
Wir haben also einen kleinen grünen Fleck, das ist Jena.
Dieses Grün bedeutet aber nur 0,0%. Weimar schrumpft, minus 10.
Erfurt schrumpft, minus 5%. Es gibt Landkreise, und dann natürlich wieder Suhl, minus 42,5%.
Das sind Abwanderungswellen, die sind so immens. Damit hat noch niemals ein
Politiker irgendetwas anfangen können. Es ist da auch egal, wer regiert.
Keine Ahnung, man kann das Land dann auch der AfD überlassen.
Es ist ein derartiger Mangel und Abwanderung zu bewältigen, dass es einfach
keinen Unterschied macht.
Es wird keine Haushaltsbudgets geben, es gibt nichts Materielles zu entscheiden
in diesen Ländereien, wenn die Landräte da flächendeckend an die AfD gehen,
ja, macht halt die AfD dort die Unterschriften unter die Schließungsanträge.
Das IFO-Institut hat letztes Jahr entdeckt.
Es sind ja dann auch immer noch viele Leute da, die nicht die AfD gewählt haben,
auch viele dann in den Augen der AfD-Biodeutsche, die die AfD nicht gewählt
haben, für die das Leben ja da ziemlich unerträglich wird oder man sieht ja
auch gerade dabei so Verwaltung, wo es einfach darum geht,
bekommt jetzt das Café so und so, das Kulturcafé in Zuschuss oder nicht oder helfen wir damit.
Diese ganzen Dinge werden ja mit einer AfD-Regierung oder mit einem AfD-Landrat
all das nicht mehr sein. Also ich verstehe deine Argumentation,
aber ich würde sagen, dass.
Nie war der Faschismus rational und er hat auch nie auf eine rationale Argumentation
aufgebaut, um Leute zu bekommen und je irrationaler er war,
dann gibt es so Pseudorationalisierung, aber je irrationaler er war,
desto erfolgreicher war er auch.
Und wenn ich mir die Irrationalität unserer Führungsköpfe ansehe,
dann muss ich sagen, vielleicht hat die AfD da doch einen guten Riecher.
Also es gibt ja diese Umfrage, die immer wieder veröffentlicht wird dann in
der FAZ, wo 485 Führungsspitzen aus Wirtschaft,
Politik und Verwaltung befragt werden zu den Themen unserer Zeit beziehungsweise
zur Arbeit der jeweiligen Regierung.
Ist man zufrieden, da sind dann 89 Vorstände von Unternehmen darunter.
Also wirklich die Entscheider, ja. Also nicht die, die man in der ersten Kasse
im ICE trifft, sondern eher schon die, die hin und her fliegen oder gar geflogen werden.
Und die werden dann hier gefragt, welche Probleme hat die deutsche Wirtschaft
und klar, dann kommen hohe Energiepreise und so, aber schon auf Platz 3 mit
58% Mangel an Fachkräften.
Aha, also das Problem ist ausgemacht. So, jetzt kommt es aber.
Es gibt dann die Frage, halten sie die derzeitige Flüchtlingspolitik der Bundesregierung für richtig?
Und das ist jetzt hier nicht spezifiziert, aber ich würde mal sagen,
diese Frage zieht also darauf ab, müssen wir härter gegen Flüchtlinge vorgehen oder nicht?
Also darauf läuft das ja hinaus.
Sonst hätte man die Frage vermutlich auch anders formuliert.
Und dann sagen 65 Prozent derselben Leute…,
Ist nicht richtig.
Und.
Nur 31 Prozent sind zufrieden mit dem Kurs.
Und wir erleben ja jetzt schon bei der Bundesregierung einen Ruck nach rechts
in der Migrationsfrage.
Also unter diesen Führungskräften, unter diesen 485, sind wahrscheinlich nur
5, 6 Prozent, die sagen würden, wir brauchen viel mehr Migration,
wir müssen viel mehr offene Grenzen machen.
Das heißt, was hier eigentlich eingefordert ist, ist, dass man zum einen sich
ein paar Fachkräfte herauspicken möchte,
die man dann aber gerade, also nur die, die man wahrscheinlich für sein eigenes
Unternehmen gerade braucht und sonst bitte soll niemand kommen.
Und generell ist man für eine große Abschottungspolitik.
Und so zeigt sich natürlich auch, dass die Führungskräfte in der Wirtschaft
zu 54 Prozent sagen, dass Merz der bessere Kanzler wäre als Scholz.
Und da sehen wir, also noch haben wir eine ganz klare Differenzierung.
Also kein CEO und auch kein sonstiger Entscheider würde jetzt sagen, ich wähle die AfD.
Dann wäre man natürlich raus aus dem Spiel. Aber was wir jetzt,
glaube ich, erleben, und das ist die große Gefahr, von der ja auch Florian Schröder gewarnt hat.
Dass wir eine Angleichung bekommen der CDU an ein AfD-Programm,
das dann nicht so weit geht, noch Remigration zu sagen.
Man hat eigentlich jetzt von der AfD, der CDU, ein tolles Angebot gemacht.
Man kann jetzt eigentlich ganz aggressiv gegen Flüchtlinge auftreten.
Nur man unterscheidet sich noch darin, also Remigration, das geht nun wirklich zu weit.
Also dadurch, dass die AfD so sehr eskaliert ins Rechtsextreme hinein,
ist man natürlich selbst, selbst wenn man sagt, und nie mehr soll hier jemand
einen Asylantrag stellen können, ist man immer noch linker als die AfD.
Und ich sehe die ganz große Gefahr, dass wir also durch diesen Diskurs,
der durch die AfD da reinkommt, durch dieses Extrem da mit Remigration,
alle anderen, die eine Abschottungspolitik fahren, sich immer noch sagen können,
ja, aber wir sind nicht die AfD. Und so sind ja auch die Demonstrationen.
Guck mal, ich habe dir hier ein Bild mitgebracht aus Aachen.
Da wurde nicht wieder nur der Orden wieder den tierischen Ernst verliehen,
sondern hier auf der Bühne stehen dann auch noch, man nimmt ja alles mit,
so eine Demo gegen rechts, auf der Christian Lindner und Julia Klöckner zusammen da sind.
Julia Klöckner, die noch bei Twitter jetzt nochmal sagte, ja,
das ist aber auch schlimm, dass so viele Linksextreme bei den Demos mitgehen.
Also ich will es nur sagen, ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass die deutschen
Eliten das so viel anders sehen.
Ich bin ja noch in der Herleitung einer wirklichen Pointe, bei der ich meine,
die muss man ganz deutlich machen.
Das nützt nichts, das so nebenbei oder so, oder so wie du jetzt sagst,
das ist ja irrational. Ja klar, es ist irrational.
Es ist so irrational und ich bleibe jetzt noch bei meiner Vorbereitung der Pointe.
Das ist noch nicht die Pointe, das ist noch die Vorbereitung, Grundlagenarbeit.
Das IFO-Institut hat letztes Jahr, vergangenes Jahr, das letzte Jahr ist vergangen, einen Text gemacht.
Ich will nochmal die Überschrift losen. Und wir lesen es jetzt unter dieser Maxime.
Die AfD möchte Remigration. Dieser Begriff ist für uns untauglich.
Er sollte bitte ein Grundbegriff der Soziologie bleiben oder der Sozialwissenschaften.
Die AfD möchte Abwanderung und Abschottung. Ja.
So, Abschottung und Abwanderung. Das ist das Programm der AfD.
Also wenn ihr mit irgendwem darüber diskutiert, habt ihr das Remigration,
Korrektiv und so weiter.
Sofort auf Abwanderung und Abschottung.
Ja.
Soll die Lösung sein, laut AfD. Das IFO-Institut hat vergangenes Jahr geschrieben,
in so einem Text, der natürlich nur als PDF veröffentlicht wird,
deswegen von niemandem gelesen und so weiter und so fort, die Überschrift schon.
Das Thüringen-Paradox.
Thüringen droht tatsächlich eine zweite Wende, aber anders als von manchem erhofft.
Der Vorspann. In den kommenden Jahren gehen in Thüringen wie in den anderen
ostdeutschen Ländern auch große Teile jener Generation in den Ruhestand,
die maßgeblich zur positiven Wirtschaftsentwicklung seit seit der Wiedervereinigung beigetragen haben.
Angesichts des starken Rückgangs des Erwerbspersonenpotenzials ist Thüringen
weit mehr als viele andere Regionen in Deutschland auf einen Zuzug von Arbeitskräften
aus dem Ausland angewiesen. Der erste Satz dieses Textes.
Thüringen hat ein Problem, ein sehr großes sogar.
All das, worüber ich jetzt sprach, bedeutet, Abwanderung und Abschottung ist der Todesstoß.
Und an Thüringen kann man es schon sehen.
Überlegt mal, wie Deutschland 2030 aussieht, wenn wir jetzt 25 Millionen Leute vergrämen.
Schaut euch jetzt Thüringen an. Fahrt einfach mal mit dem Auto durch,
haltet in irgendwelchen Dörfern an.
Das ist das Ziel von so einer Abwanderungs- und Abschottungspolitik,
wie es von der AfD gewollt wird. 40 Prozent des Erwerbspersonenpotenzials sind älter als 50 Jahre.
Die Hälfte der Zuwanderer nach Deutschland sind minderjährig,
können also einfach in die Schule gehen, drei Jahre später, perfekt Deutsch,
perfekt Mathe, alles läuft. Und das verstehen ja diese Entscheider nicht.
Die wollen 25-Jährige ausgebildete Fachkräfte, die am besten als Singles kommen.
Das ist deren Idee. Die denken nicht daran, dass 14-Jährige in vier Jahren fertig
sind mit der Schule und dann sehr schnell zu Fachkräften ausgebildet werden können.
Aber da verweise ich jetzt auf, glaube ich, alle unsere Podcasts bisher.
Wenn die FDP sagt, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen der Zuwanderung und der,
sagen wir, nein, es gibt nur Zuwanderung oder keine Zuwanderung.
Man kann nicht handverlesen, irgendwie Rosin pickend und so weiter.
So und jetzt kommt, wir nähern uns jetzt, jetzt kommt die Pointe.
Matthias Quent hat der Tagesschau ein Interview gegeben, ich habe es nur als
Text gefunden, es ist wirklich sehr gut.
Die AfD zeigt sich, sagte er, hoch verunsichert durch diese Demonstrationen.
Die extreme Rechte ist regelrecht in Panik. Es wird versucht,
diese Demonstration als Fälschungen und als Inszenierungen in Frage zu stellen.
Hier kriegt man also mit, da läuft irgendwie ein Gegenprogramm.
Und zwar nicht von irgendwelchen Eliten, sondern von der Masse.
Plötzlich stehen die, was heißt denn das jetzt? Wir sind doch die Mehrheit.
Wir sind doch die schweigende Mehrheit, die das Gegenprogramm aufmacht.
Wieso haben die jetzt auch ein Gegenprogramm?
Weshalb ich auch sagen würde, es ist keine kluge Idee, wenn die Organisatoren
solcher Proteste zu sehr auf Regierungspolitiker und sowas setzen.
Die braucht man doch nicht.
Das sagt er gleich ganz explizit.
Die Regierungspolitiker, die überhaupt, Politiker, haben die Aufgabe,
Politik gegen Rechts zu machen.
Und da kommen wir auch am Ende bei so Themen wie Mindestlohnerhöhung.
Lass uns dem aber langsam lernen.
Aber ich will das noch gerade sagen, weil das ist etwas, was,
glaube ich, sehr viel Dynamik nehmen kann, wenn man jetzt nur sich als staatstragend dort versteht.
Weil dann wird man vielleicht als Organisator im Herbst nach Bellevue eingeladen
und bekommt einen Orden, aber man hat dann doch eigentlich der Sache wenig geholfen. Die.
Frage ist jetzt, hinter welcher Idee versammelt man sich eigentlich?
Lässt man sich in München davon verunsichern, dass irgendwer sagt,
naja, da haben wir auch welche gegen März und so.
Ich würde sagen, ich gehe überhaupt auf gar keine Demo, auf der nicht gegen
März auch deprediert wird.
Oder, und deswegen mein langer Anlauf, wendet man sich gegen Abschottungs- und
Abwanderungsideologien.
Ja.
Diese Demo-Bilder nehmen der AfD den Nimbus der Volkspartei.
Die AfD und ihre Wählerschaft hat sich auf Twitter und auf Facebook und so weiter,
wir wissen ja, solche Leute sind dann 10 Stunden am Tag in solchen Netzwerken,
und mit Netzwerken meine ich nicht Facebook, Twitter, sondern dann spezifisch
in ihrer Peergroup, die haben sich da eingeredet, dass sie die schweigende Mehrheit
sind, die sich traut, das zu explizieren, und jetzt stellen sie plötzlich fest,
nee, da sind ja noch viel mehr, wir hätten niemals 300.000 in München auf die
Straße gekriegt, die aber schon, wer sind die denn?
Wir haben uns viele aktuelle Zitate, das ist jetzt eine Fragestellung der Tagesschau-Redaktion,
wir haben uns viele aktuelle Zitate von AfD-Politikern in deren Kanälen und
auf Neurechten-Plattformen angeschaut. Dort hört man, die Proteste seien von
der Regierung organisiert.
Die Kritiker der AfD hätten nicht Angst um die Demokratie, sondern vor der Demokratie. Ein Quent dazu.
Die AfD will einerseits diese Demonstrationen delegitimieren für die allgemeine
Öffentlichkeit, in dem man suggeriert, sie seien nicht legitim,
sie seien im Auftrag der Regierung oder sie sogar gleichzusetzen mit den Aufmärschen
von den Nationalsozialisten oder auch aus der DDR sozusagen als Paraden von
verpflichteten Staatsbürgern,
die hier gegen die Opposition demonstrieren. Also das kennen wir ja, 1.
Mai, Tag der Arbeit, heute gehen wir auf die Straße und demonstrieren gegen
wen eigentlich, egal, wir demonstrieren im Grunde für unsere Regierung.
Also dass man da sozusagen verpflichtet, ihr habt alle arbeitsfrei,
aber ihr müsst dann auch auf die Straße gehen.
Also das wird suggeriert, dass das hier stattfindet. Quent, es gibt einen ideologisch
verhärteten Teil der AfD-Wählerschaft, die glauben alles, was ihnen von der AfD gesagt wird.
Also auch solche komischen Ideen. Die polarisieren sich an diesen Demonstrationen
im Zweifelsfall auch weiter in die Irrationalität hinein.
Also da wird die Kraft, die solche Demonstrationen an mehreren hundert Orten
von mehreren tausend Menschen und so weiter aufgenommen und gesagt,
okay, dann radikalisiere ich mich noch mehr. Das sind dann einfach Leute,
die dieser AfD-Strategien der affektiven Polarisierung auf den Leim gehen.
Also wir haben es hier mit Gefühlsmanagement und dieser Wir-Die-Unterscheidung
zu tun und so weiter und so fort. Und dann Quint.
Du musst dich jetzt dafür rechtfertigen. Du kannst ja nicht einfach einen Joke
machen und glauben, wir sind deine Facebook-Bubble, im Sinne von,
du bist ja in deinem Netzwerk. Nee, wir sind hier die anderen.
Also wir sind hier die 300.000 auf der Straße gewesen, ich gehöre zu denen.
Rechtfertige dich mal. Ich denke sowieso.
Dass über das persönliche Gespräch wahnsinnig viel zu bewegen ist.
Absolut, das persönliche Gespräch. Und dann sagt er hier.
Und natürlich ist es gut, wenn diese Proteste vor allem zivilgesellschaftlich
getragen werden, wenn andere politische Parteien dort nicht allzu präsent sind.
Ich halte es für eine große Pflicht, dass sich die CDU, die Linken,
die Grünen, die SPD, die FDP dort nicht zeigen.
Wenn sie sich dort zeigen, stärken sie die AfD. Wenn sie sich raushalten und
sagen, nee, das sind die Bürger selbst, dann nützt es gegen die AfD.
Vor allen Dingen ist es ja höchst widersprüchlich, wenn Klingbeil und Co.
Und Scholz bei diesen Demos auftreten und dann eine Stunde später ein Interview geben,
ja wir müssen jetzt Abschiebungen konsequenter verfolgen, also das kann ja nicht
sein, man kann nicht gegen Abschiebungen und Abschottungen auf die Straße gehen
und dann aber selber sie vollziehen.
Und dann aber sagen, weil wir nicht die AfD sind, ist jede Abschiebung,
die wir machen, natürlich immer goldrichtig.
Und deswegen würde ich auch sagen, Politiker haben dort nichts verloren. Nein.
Sie dürfen da nicht hin. Sonst funktionieren die Demos nicht.
Die Demos funktionieren nur, weil die etablierten Parteien dort nicht sind.
Wenn sie dort sind, rotten die sich in diesen AfD-Kreisen zusammen,
in denen wir alle keinen Einblick haben, außer Matthias Quente und so weiter.
Dann schaukeln die sich über Wochen und Monate hoch. Wisst ihr noch,
als die CDU und die SPD im Schulterschluss die Leute aufgewiegelt haben gegen uns? Ja.
Und das muss man einfach beachten. Wenn man auf eine Demonstration geht,
dort keine Parteivertreter.
Sie dürfen dort nicht sein. Und dann Quent hier zum Schluss.
Man ist frustriert und erschüttert darüber, dass die eigene Vorstellung über
die Gesellschaft durch diese Demonstration erschüttert wird.
Genau das soll ja erreicht werden. Und das passiert ganz stark auf einer emotionalen Ebene.
Also kein rationaler Diskurs, sondern die AfD-Leute auf der emotionalen Ebene abholen.
Beziehungsweise ihnen da begegnen. Und gar nicht auf einer rationalen Ebene.
Sagt er ausdrücklich. Ich lese den Satz nochmal, wie er ihn gesagt hat, vor.
Und das passiert ganz stark auf einer emotionalen Ebene und gar nicht nur auf einer rationalen.
Auch darum sind diese Demonstrationen so wichtig. Vielleicht wichtiger als das
eine oder andere wissenschaftliche Erklärstück.
Also die Demonstrationen finden statt, wenn in München 300.000 Leute auf der Straße sind.
Gegen die AfD, gegen Abwanderungs- und Abschottungsideologien,
wie sie die bei Korrektiv gelesen haben. Das war nun mal...
Es braucht niemanden zu bezweifeln, der Ausgangs, also der Triggerpunkt,
der die Leute auf die Straße gebracht hat.
Dann sind 300.000 Leute auf der Straße.
Ab dann ist egal, was irgendein Deutschlandfunkredakteur dazu nochmal kommentiert.
Es ist auch egal, was ein Politiker dazu sagt. Er darf sich dort nicht zeigen.
Vereinnahmungsversuche, die irgendwie im Fernsehstudio stattfinden,
schön und gut. Keine Ahnung, das muss man dann entsprechend kritisieren.
Aber diese Demos scheinen hier eine sehr wichtige Funktion zu haben,
Um die Leute, die sich ansonsten da so zusammenrotten, einfach aufzurütteln und ihnen zu zeigen,
du bist nicht Teil einer Volkspartei, sondern du bist eine Minderheit und die
Leute wollen nicht, was du möchtest. Und.
Ich glaube, dass es auch über die AfD-Demonstration hinaus zu beurteilen ist,
denn wenn man dort auftritt und sagt, wir sind gegen Abschiebung,
wir sind gegen Abschottung, wir sind gegen Auswanderung, Abwanderung,
dann sagt man damit auch einer Ampelregierung,
für uns müsst ihr den Kram nicht machen mit der Abschottungspolitik.
Dann sagt man der CDU auch, hier ist die Mehrheit, ihr wollt doch eine Volkspartei
sein, die könnt ihr nicht werden, indem ihr die ganze Zeit nur die Talking Points der AfD übernehmt.
Also deshalb muss auch die Politik dem fernbleiben, beziehungsweise man muss
dafür sorgen, dass die Politik dem fernbleibt. Und.
Das wäre sozusagen meine Pointe, was die Demonstrationen angeht.
Diese Demonstrationen ermöglichen zu sagen, ich will keine Abschottungs- und
Abwanderungspolitik, egal von wem.
Und wenn dich dann die SPD erwischt fühlt mit, ach die demonstriert noch gegen
uns, dann ist das so, weil die SPD macht gerade diese Politik. Tick.
Und dann kriegt man endlich dieses die SPD sitzt irgendwie in irgendwelchen
Gremien da und überlegt, müssen wir der AfD jetzt so und so weit entgegenkommen,
um irgendwie deren Triggerpunkte zu nehmen oder sowas. Nein, gar nicht.
Dann sitzen einfach AfD, dann ist die AfD eine Altpartei geworden,
die die SPD vor sich her treibt und alle machen gemeinsame Sache.
Und zwar gegen die deutschen Interessen. Und das will ich jetzt auch nochmal,
Marcel Fratscher, mein letzter Punkt dazu.
Aber Marcel Fratscher hat so einen herausragenden Text dazu geschrieben.
Also in seiner Zeitkolumne, die er da immer schreibt, weil sie wirklich da ansetzt,
wo wir über die Triggerpunkte-Argumentation so viel gelernt haben.
Also ich erinnere nochmal an Triggerpunkte, verschiedene Arenen, in denen man spielt.
Die ökonomische und die identitätspolitische Arena sind zwei verschiedene.
Und da gibt es auch kein Crossing dazwischen oder irgendwas,
sondern es sind zwei verschiedene Arenen, auf denen gespielt wird.
Und hier schreibt er über das, und er bezieht sich gar nicht auf Triggerpunkte
explizit, aber wir können es daraus lesen, er bezieht sich auf das AfD-Paradox.
Die Wählerinnen und Wähler der AfD würden wirtschaftlich und finanziell zu den
größten Verlierern der AfD-Politik zählen.
Die Partei sieht in ihren Wahlprogrammen Steuerentlastung für Spitzenverdiener
und eine stärkere steuerliche Belastung für Menschen mit geringem und mittlerem Einkommen vor.
Die AfD möchte mehr Protektionismus, Abschottung und einen Austritt aus der Europäischen Union.
Also gerade durch Weidel, da muss jetzt niemand kommen und sagen,
will sie aber nicht, doch, doch, will sie doch.
Wird auch so auf den Parteitagen diskutiert. Sie pocht auf geschlossene Grenzen,
nicht nur für Menschen, sondern auch für Teile der Wirtschaft.
Eine solche Politik wäre das Ende des deutschen Wirtschaftsmodells und würde
Deutschland viele Millionen gute Arbeitsplätze kosten.
Gerade AfD-Wählerinnen und Wähler, die häufig regional weniger mobil sind,
wären davon besonders hart getroffen.
So, und dann geht er auf das AfD-Programm explizit ein und nennt dann auch die Bauernproteste.
Im Wahlprogramm steht, wir wollen alle Agrarsubventionen abbauen.
Ökonomische Arena. Dann gehen sie aber auf die Straße und sagen,
wir unterstützen euch Bauern, Identitätspolitik.
Diese beiden sind unvereinbar. Das ist dieses AfD-Paradox.
Und daran muss man ansetzen. Das muss jeder Politiker, der gegen die AfD kämpft, dann explizieren.
Wir machen hier nicht nur Spaß, sondern wir sitzen in Parlamenten und entscheiden.
Mehrheitlich. Und wenn wir mehrheitlich die AfD zu Wort kommen lassen,
sind die Bauern, also dann ist es vorbei mit den deutschen Bauern.
Dann fehlt denen einfach 50% des Einkommens und dann ist alles vorbei.
Er schreibt hier, es ist wichtig, dass die Verantwortlichen in Wirtschaftspolitik
und Gesellschaft die AfD inhaltlich stellen und dem Populismus die Inkompetenz
und die Widersprüche der Partei offenlegen.
Nur so wird deutlich, dass die
Wählerinnen und Wähler selbst die größten Verlierer der AfD-Politik wären.
Was jetzt für mich bedeutet insgesamt, die Proteste sind ganz wichtig,
frei zu halten von Parteipolitik.
Die Aufgabe der Parteipolitik ist nicht, sich auf eine Demonstration zu zeigen
und sich als Speerspitze von einer Bewegung, die man gerne vereinnahmen möchte
und so weiter, vorzugaukeln, uns irgendwas vorzumachen.
Ja, Julia Köckner weiß ja, wenn sie auf einem Marktplatz stünde,
würde kein Schwein stehen bleiben, aber sie stellt sich jetzt einfach auf die
Bühne und sagt, schön, dass ihr alle da seid.
Genau, also die Aufgabe der Politik ist nicht zu diesen Protesten zu gehen und sie zu vereinnahmen.
Die Aufgabe der Politik ist jetzt, um die Demonstranten zu unterstützen,
die AfD inhaltlich zu stellen.
Also Textexegese zu machen, was steht in deren Wahlprogramm,
auch sich die Frage zu stellen, können wir mit denen koalieren und dann muss
die SPD ohne moralischen Überbau einfach sagen,
wir können nicht mit der AfD koalieren, weil wir gerne den Bauernstand in Deutschland
erhalten wollen und die AfD möchte ihn abschieben. Solche Sachen.
Steuerpolitik, einfach mal
durchgehen, was das für eine Familie bedeutet und so weiter und so fort.
Was ich jetzt wieder sehe ist, dass schon diskutiert wird, ob die CDU dann mit
den Linken koaliert, um in Thüringen die AfD zu verhindern.
Nee, es sollte natürlich nicht als Rederduell im Deutschlandfunk-Podcast FAZ
stattfinden, aber die CDU sollte auf Parteitagen einfach darüber diskutieren,
inhaltlich, ob man mit der AfD koalieren kann und wie das aussähe.
Weil ich habe keine Angst vor diesem Resultat.
Einfach mal durchdiskutieren, was es bedeutet, mit der AfD zu koalieren.
Deutschland wäre am Ende.
Also es wäre einfach, die hat sich auf eine Art und Weise zwischen Identitätspolitik
und ökonomischer Arena verstrickt, dass sie es nicht aufgelöst bekommt.
Die stehen ja jetzt schon schlotternd da, wenn sie feststellen,
oh in Sachsen könnten wir vielleicht, wenn nur drei Parteien reinkommen,
50 Prozent erreichen, dann müssten wir alle Ministerien besetzen.
Wer von uns hat Ahnung, wie ein Ministerium funktioniert?
Niemand. Die lesen gerade diese Handbücher, Staatsverwaltung für Dummies,
um so ein bisschen sprechfähig zu werden, was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Also diese Partei kann jetzt inhaltlich bankrott gemacht werden,
wenn die Politik diese Aufgabe annimmt, statt die Zeit zu verschwenden,
auf so eine Demo zu gehen, wo schon 300.000 Leute sind. Da muss ich nicht,
Frau Lange jetzt noch sich hinstellen als 300.000 Erste.
Ja, und ich möchte noch einen Kommentar dazu loslassen.
Man sollte, auch wenn wir jetzt eben die Bauernproteste kritisiert haben,
dann aber auch nicht jetzt von linksliberaler Seite sagen, okay,
da geht die AfD auf die Straße.
Also dem ist auch nicht so. Also das ist dann wieder diese Debatte,
die wir bei Corona hatten, die wir beim Krieg hatten und die jetzt bei den Bauernprotesten
da ist, dass man dann nur sagt, wenn einem da irgendwas nicht behakt,
dann hat das wohl mit der AfD zu tun. Das ist wohl AfD.
Also man kann jetzt auch nicht immer nur, weil man zu faul ist zu denken, sagen AfD. AfD, ja.
Also ich würde eher sagen, ja, wenn man für radikale Abschottungspolitik ist,
dann kommt man in die Predoje, dass man sich rechtfertigen muss und wie weit
man sich dann klopft, von der AfD zu unterscheiden.
Und das ist ja gerade das, was wir bei diesen ganzen Politikern erleben können,
die nicht in der AfD sind.
Und deren einziges Ding ist ja zu sagen, weil wir nicht AfD sind,
können wir AfD-Gesetze beschließen, ohne AfD zu sein. Und das geht natürlich nicht.
Das geht natürlich nicht. Was ich aber wirklich, wo ich vorwarnen will,
dass man so eine Meinungskorridorverengung dann macht,
dass man alles versucht immer mit so AfD zu vergleichen.
Das ist immer alles gleiche AfDs.
Und ich will daran anführend noch einen Tweet vorlesen, der sehr erstaunlich war.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du diese neue Sendung, die ihr schon angesehen, Karin Miosga?
Gehört.
Ich habe gehört, dass es sie gibt. Sie hatte dann jetzt Thema Ukraine und man
kann sich vorstellen, was der Fall war.
Sie hat Selenskyj interviewt, Vasily Golod war noch da zu Gast und was klingt.
Das heißt, es ging wieder um die Fragen Waffenlieferungen. und es ist so...
Lass mich raten, was du liest, Dirk Kubio war...
Nein, nein, nein, es ist alles wie immer...
Die Fragen, die gestellt werden, sind, ja, sind sie für Waffen,
die natürlich sagen alle ja, ja, jein, ja, ja, jein, ja, ja.
Also wir haben, es hat sich nichts verändert, auch mit Karin Miosga natürlich nicht.
Und Paul Ronsheimer, der ja kein Blöder ist, man kann ja von dem halten,
was man will, aber ist ja kein Blöder, der schreibt bei Twitter nach dieser
Miosga-Sendung folgendes.
Egal, was ich selbst denke, in Klammern, und das ist in Sachen Ukraine sehr klar.
Aber in dieser Debatte fehlt völlig die Stimme, Schrägstrich Stimmung,
von einer großen Zahl von Deutschen, die gegen Waffenlieferungen sind.
Wer in Thüringen oder Sachsen, wo sogar die Mehrheit dagegen ist,
fühlt sich da gerade vertreten.
Oder gibt es einfach niemanden außer Wagenknecht, den man einladen kann?
Hashtag Miosga. Das hat er geschrieben und das ist sehr, sehr richtig.
Und ich will das jetzt nochmal damit unterstreichen, indem ich auf private Gespräche
eingehe aus Familie, aber vor allem die ich bei Veranstaltungen führe so danach.
Ich habe da auf Leute getroffen, die für Waffenlieferungen sind,
für mehr Waffenlieferungen, aber sehr viele Leute sind dafür,
dass man versucht zu verhandeln, mehr Diplomatie weiten lässt,
nicht schwere Waffen liefert.
So, mit all denen, mit denen ich da gesprochen habe und das waren deutsche Menschen
mit ohne Migrationshintergrund, Leute aus der LGBT-Community,
das waren Familienmenschen, das war also ein bunter Haufen.
Wenige von denen finden jetzt Wagenknecht, glaube ich, gut. Nicht alle verteufeln sie.
Aber was ich doch festhalten will, ist, dass ich keinen einzigen getroffen habe,
der sagte ja und deshalb wähle ich die AfD.
Und ich habe keinen einzigen in all diesen Gesprächen getroffen,
der sagte, na der Putin hat schon recht, dass der das jetzt so macht mit der Ukraine.
Das heißt also dieser permanente Vorwurf, jeder der Waffenlieferungen in Frage
stellt, ist ein Putin-Troll.
Deckt sich nicht mit der Realität. Man kann dann sagen, ja vielleicht ist es
dann inkonsequent in der Weise, wie sie denken oder manches ist vielleicht zu
naiv in der Forderung nach Diplomatie.
Über all das kann man ja sehr gut streiten, diskutieren. Aber was stattfindet
im Diskurs ist, dass man sagt, ja das sind wohl Putin-Trolle oder du bist ein
Putin-Freund. Wie gesagt, ich will es nochmal unterstreichen.
In zwei Jahren habe ich noch keinen einzigen Menschen getroffen.
Ich will nicht leugnen, dass es sie gibt und klar ist da bei Telegram und sonst wo was los,
aber ich habe ganz viele Leute getroffen, die die Kriegspolitik,
die Aufrüstung sehr skeptisch sehen, aber ich habe niemanden getroffen,
der Putin rechtfertigt und ich habe auch schon gar niemanden getroffen, der sagt,
ja also ich würde ja am liebsten so in Putins Reich leben.
Nein, da würde jeder immer die Bundesrepublik vorziehen.
Die Stimmung ändert sich. Im aktuellen Spiegel, jedenfalls wurde der Text dann am 28.
Januar publiziert, hat Dirk Kubiowait und zwar als Eröffnung des Spiegels,
also im editorischen Brief an die Leser geschrieben, es ist Zeit für einen neuen Realismus.
Es bleibt richtig, der Ukraine mit Waffen und Munition zu helfen.
Es bleibt richtig, Russland politisch und wirtschaftlich weitgehend zu isolieren.
Aber man sollte auch über ein Kriegsende nachdenken, in dem die Ukraine nicht
der Sieger ist und ihr verlorenes Territorium komplett zurückbekommt.
Es sollte jetzt nach Kompromissen gesucht werden, auch wenn das weh tut.
Aha.
Weil dadurch, dass man im Krieg
ist, durch Militärregierung einfach militärisch in Kiew regiert wird.
Oder sollte man die Demokratie gewähren lassen, also sein Bürgermeisteramt.
Und er sagt, nein, das ist nicht okay. Und es sind autokratische und zentralistische
Bemühungen von Zelensky, diesen Zustand jetzt durch den Krieg zu manifestieren.
Und er hat seit zwei Jahren, seit Kriegsbeginn, nicht mit Zelensky gesprochen.
Die beiden sitzen nur einen Kilometer entfernt voneinander in Kiew.
Und er haut Selenskyj in die Pfanne. Er ist nicht der richtige Präsident für
die Ukraine und so weiter und so fort.
Also es geht jetzt wirklich zur Sache, Schlag auf Schlag.
Wir werden es beobachten.
Wir wollen nur kurz darauf hinweisen, dass man nicht nur diesen Podcast hören
kann, sondern es gibt ja noch Zusatzinhalte, nämlich es gibt den Salon,
in dem wir jeden Monat zwei,
eher drei Stunden, manchmal auch fast vier Stunden über die wichtigsten Lektüren des Monats sprechen.
Wir lesen immer ein Buch gemeinsam und dann liest jeder von uns nochmal fünf
Artikel oder Bücher und dann werden die auch noch angesprochen.
Jedenfalls diskutieren wir immer über ein Buch sehr ausführlich und diesmal
ist es gar kein brandaktuelles, aber eines, das in den 29er Jahren jetzt erschienen
ist, das aber schon sehr viel gelesen wurde und das uns auch immer wieder empfohlen wurde.
Mir wurde es von einem Hörer geschickt, du musst es dir selbst kaufen. So wie immer.
Denn Hörer verschicken immer Papierbücher, damit kann ich nichts anfangen.
Okay, also ich freue mich auch über Papierbücher natürlich, weil ich nur Papierbücher
lese, was ein komisches Wort.
Und wir lesen von Rutger Bregmann im Grunde gut.
Wir haben jetzt so viel Schlimmes von schlimmen Leuten gehört und wir wollen
jetzt schauen, ob der Mensch doch an sich gut ist.
Er leitet ja von diesen Überlegungen, die er da hat, auch ab,
wie anders Politik und Aktivismus zu gestalten wären.
Und wir sind gespannt. Ich glaube, es ist als Debattengrundlage jedenfalls ein wichtiges Buch,
weil es so breit von auch wichtigen Leuten rezipiert wurde aus dem Silicon Valley, aus der Politik,
aus der Wirtschaft, dass man eigentlich nicht an ihm vorbeikommt. Und.
Seit wir gesagt haben, dass wir das Buch lesen, erreichen mich ganz schön viele
Nachrichten von Leuten, die nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass auch Felix Lobrecht
und so weiter das Buch alle gut finden.
Und es könnte sein, dass es wirklich, ich habe noch nicht reingeguckt,
dass es auch an den Grundfesten unserer Diskussion hier immer rüttelt,
denn die Leute fragen sich ja immer, Stefan Wolfgang ist nicht meiner Meinung,
aber nee, du kommst ja immer aus der, sagen wir mal so der Wiener romantischen Richtung,
Einflugsneise. Was ist denn das für eine Richtung?
Ja.
So ein bisschen Marx, ein bisschen Freud und immer gute Argumente.
Frankfurter Schule würde ich jetzt auch sagen.
Frankfurter Schule, während ich ja hier in Frankfurt die Bielefelder Schule,
also ich will ja nochmal das funktionale Argument und so.
Und gerade zum Thema, was passiert gerade auf der Straße? Die Leute sind doch
im Grunde gut, weil wie kann denn sowas bei rumkommen? Es gibt diese sehr interessanten
Bücher, zum einen ganz normale Männer, Christopher A.
Browning, der also über deutsche Polizisten, die trotzdem Massenmorde in Polen
verüben und ganz normale Männer weist schon auf, naja im Grunde sind die gut,
ganz normale Männer, so Männer sind gut.
Und Stefan Kühl hat ja nochmal drüber gelegt, ganz normale Organisation.
Also das unabhängig davon, ob der Mensch im Grunde gut oder schlecht ist,
wenn er sich so und so organisiert, kommt das und das bei raus.
Und in dieser Maßgabe verstehe ich, warum so viele Leute dieses Buch empfehlen,
im Sinne von, das sollst du lesen, denn im Kern ist doch das,
was in der Welt passiert, ausgelöst durch menschliche Intentionen und wenn die
im Grunde gut sind, muss das Resultat auch gut sein.
Und die soziologische Aufklärung widerspricht dem fundamental.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt, wie ich dann dieses Buch lesen werde und wie wir
es dann besprechen, weil im Grunde gut.
Es ist zwar ein sehr programmatischer Titel, aber das muss gar nichts bedeuten,
dass man herausfindet, dass es im Grunde nochmal irgendwie gut ist. Resultate zählen. Ja.
Zizek sagt ja mal, das Schlimme ist ja bei einigen Diktatoren,
die es tatsächlich gut gemeint haben, wo es dann besonders bestialisch wurde. Genau.
Übrigens wurde mir auch ein Clip geschickt von Robert Habeck bei der Republika
und dort empfiehlt er auch dieses Buch und bezieht sich darauf.
Also wir reden jetzt über ein Buch, das offenbar schon alle wichtigen Leute
gelesen haben und da wollen wir doch auch nicht.
Genau, können wir es nochmal in den Kontexten auch besprechen,
in denen dies bisher aufgemacht hat.
Genau, ich denke auch, dass es ja solche Bücher sind, die dann auch vieles prägen
und insofern ist es interessant.
Den Salon könnt ihr abonnieren, wenn ihr zu Steady geht.
Das ist sehr simpel und dann kann man ab 2,50 Euro im Monat diesen Salon buchen.
Wer uns mehr unterstützen will, kann auch die höheren Pakete buchen.
Man kann, wenn man bei Apple ist und es gerne ganz praktisch haben möchte,
auch dort den Salon buchen.
Das ist dann ganz einfach mit einem Klick, kostet aber dann ein bisschen mehr,
weil Apple ja immer mehr für sich selbst einbehält. Wir kennen das ja.
Problem oder wie man es nennen möchte.
Es ist eine der größten Kontroversen in dieser Gesellschaft gerade,
wo Apple Sachen abzweigt.
Ja, und das gilt natürlich auch für Podcasts. Und wer bei Patreon ist,
kann uns also auch bei Patreon abonnieren, aber wir würden Steady empfehlen.
Wer uns über Spotify hört, kann auch von dort direkt zu Steady kommen.
Und nochmal ganz wichtig zu erwähnen, das ist dir ja immer ganz,
ganz wichtig, dass man diesen Podcast dann,
also diesen Zusatzpodcast nicht irgendwo am Browser hören muss,
sondern man kann den auf seinem präferierten Podcatcher hören.
Man kann pausieren, später weiterhören, ohne die Stelle wiederfinden zu müssen im Browser und so.
Ja, man kann das als ganz normalen Podcast auf seinem beliebsten Podcast-Wege hören.
Gut, dann diskutieren wir im Februar über diese vielen Bücher,
die wir noch zum Teil auswählen.
Jetzt geht's nach Davos, dort war Rutger Bregmann übrigens auch schon zu Gast,
hat damals für ein bisschen Furore gesorgt, als er sagte, ja worüber reden wir
eigentlich hier, ihr habt doch alle dafür gesorgt, dass die Steuern immer weiter
runter gehen, dass die Reichen immer reicher werden.
Wir sprechen jetzt über einen, der das anders sieht, sage ich mal.
Wir sprechen über Argentiniens neuen Präsidenten Javier Milley.
Der war jetzt zum ersten Mal außerhalb Argentiniens überhaupt zu Gast,
ist nach Davos gereist und wird von Klaus Schwab vorgestellt.
Ja, the rule of law.
Es ist schon erstaunlich, dass jemand wie Milley so viel Vorschusslorbeeren ernten kann.
Und es ist nicht so, dass er jetzt besonders diplomatisch auftritt,
sondern er tritt dort auf und sagt, so jetzt sage ich mal, was mein Weltbild
ist und dass das auch für alle so sein soll.
Sein Symbol ist die Kettensäge.
Ja, denn was viele nicht wissen, wir leben eigentlich bereits tief im Sozialismus
und das ist unser großes Dilemma.
Und das rollt er jetzt für uns aus. Wir hören mal rein.
Heute bin ich hier, um Ihnen zu sagen, dass der westliche Welt in Gefahr ist.
Und er ist in Gefahr, weil diejenigen, die die Werte des Westen verteidigen
müssen, von einer Vision des Weltes, die inaktiv zu Sozialismus und dadurch
zu Poverty führt, kooperieren.
Sozialismus, Armut, Zukunft.
Er spricht jetzt aus einem Land, in dem 44% der Menschen unterhalb der Armutsgrenze leben.
44%. Also ein sehr sehr armer Land.
Aber sozialistisch runtergerockt.
Das würde man jetzt sagen und tatsächlich ist es ja nicht so ganz falsch zu
sagen, dass es aufgrund der großen gewerkschaftlichen Macht und da sehr viel
falschen Entscheidungen, aber wir sprechen hier über die 50er Jahre,
man dafür gesorgt hat, dass eigentlich ein Land, das sehr gut wirtschaftlich
dastand, dann immer weiter kaputt gemacht wurde.
Das kann man, wenn man sich jetzt für die Details interessiert,
alles sehr gut hören bei Mick Klöcker in seinem Podcast Neben der Spur.
Dort hat er zwei Stunden über Argentinien gesprochen und erklärt auch die Geschichte
Argentiniens, auch die Geschichte dieses Verfalls.
Aber er, Millais, bezieht das jetzt auf die gesamte Welt und weiter sagt er.
That afflict the citizens of the world. Rather, they are the root cause.
Und jetzt tut er das, was alle eigentlich da immer so machen,
die ein bisschen Steven Pinkerton oder so gelesen haben.
Er schaut sich mal an, wie waren das eigentlich mit dem Wirtschaftswachstum so ganz früher.
First be important for us to take a look at the data that demonstrate why free
enterprise capitalism is not just the only possible system to end world poverty,
but also that it's the only morally desirable system to achieve this.
If we look at the history of economic progress, we can see how between the year
0 and the year 1800 approximately, world per capita GDP practically remained
constant throughout the whole reference period.
Ja, von 0 bis 1800 gab es so gut wie kein Wirtschaftswachstum, das wissen wir.
Es gab auch keine Bevölkerung, sagst du.
Aber jetzt kommt der Kapitalismus.
Wenn man sich das Per-Capita-GDP aus dem Jahr 1800 anschaut,
und bis heute, wird man sehen,
dass nach der Industrie-Revolution das globale Per-Capita-GDP über 15-mal multipliziert
wurde, was einen Boom im Wachstum betrug, der 90% der globale Bevölkerung aus der Poverty auslöste.
Das stimmt natürlich, dass der Kapitalismus diese Dynamiken freigesetzt hat
und genau deshalb sagt ja auch Marx, geht der Weg zum Sozialismus über den Kapitalismus.
Er ist ja nicht jemand, der sagt, wir müssen zurück zu irgendeiner feudalen
Wirtschaft und dann können wir uns gegenseitig ein bisschen Brot backen und das genügt.
Und was auch stimmt ist, dass sehr viele Menschen durch die kapitalistischen
Dynamiken oder im Zuge der kapitalistischen Dynamiken aus der Armut herausgehoben wurden,
aus der absoluten Armut, aber die Armut selbst als ganz ganz großes Problem
ist präsent zum Beispiel nicht nur in Argentinien, sondern wenn wir uns die
Entwicklungsländer ansehen, wenn wir uns auch Indien ansehen.
Ich hatte da in einem Sinne auch mal Zahlen gebracht, dann kann man sagen,
ja die sind vielleicht aus dieser absoluten Armut leicht rausgehoben worden,
aber dann geschieht nach oben nichts mehr und das heißt einfach,
wir haben Milliarden Menschen.
So viele sind es ja inzwischen, die am Existenzminimum herumknapsen und die
nicht einen Aufstieg durch den Kapitalismus erleben.
Für ihn ist das aber jetzt klar, die Wirtschaftsentwicklung war entsprechend,
also hat das auch allen geholfen, was ja nicht der Fall ist,
was ja gerade in seinem Land so gut zu beobachten ist, dass da durchaus auch
eine extreme Ungleichheit ist,
das heißt einige sind durch kapitalistische Dynamiken sehr reich geworden,
andere nicht und dort ist ja auch das Land sehr ungleich verteilt.
Also diese ganzen Rinderbarone, die haben da ja irgendwann mal dieses Land bekommen
und dann war für alle, die danach kamen, das Feld schon bestellt.
Für Milley folgt, der ja ein libertärer Präsident ist mit irrem Haarschnitt,
für Milley folgt daraus, dass man das Unternehmerische freisetzen muss,
den Kapitalismus darf man nicht bändigen, das heißt keine Steuern am besten.
Also, weil er so direkt fragt, würde irgendwer sagen, dass jemand freiwillig Steuern bezahlt?
Wenn man sich für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland entscheidet,
man könnte ja auch einen anderen nehmen, dann entscheidet man sich dafür freiwillig,
diese Steuern zu zahlen.
Dafür Marktzugang zu erhalten, im Publikum, als Käufer oder wie auch immer.
Arbeitsbedingungen, bei denen man weiß, wenn ich den Laden hier zuschließe,
werde ich nicht auf der Straße erschossen, weil irgendwer was gegen mich hat
und so weiter und so fort.
Es ist jetzt ein Wunder oder eine große Frage, wie weit man eine Diskussion darum,
was er da sagt, treiben kann, denn eigentlich würde man ja sagen,
durchaus legitime Argumente im Sinne von, kann man ja mal diskutieren,
ich würde sagen als abschreckendes Beispiel oder was auch immer.
Man könnte dann historische Beispiele, also wo einfach die Dichotomie zwischen
autokratischer Kommunismus, der bis unter die Bettdecke regiert,
also so ein Stalin-Russland oder sowas, so eine Sowjetunion,
oder eben so ein ganz freies, ja in Mexiko macht einfach jeder,
was er will und Touristen sagt man halt, fahr mal nicht in diese Stadt,
da ist gefährlich, da macht nämlich jeder, was er will.
So, und dann kann man sich ja dazwischen entscheiden. Und er zieht das ja jetzt
auf und blendet alles dazwischen aus.
Für ihn ist ja Sozialismus die Europäische Union, die einfach als große kollektive
Entität da so mitregiert, mit reinregiert, obwohl sie gar kein Wirtschaftsunternehmen
ist, nimmt die sich einfach sozusagen,
so einen Sonderspot, um in den Markt einzugreifen.
Und dass er Präsident ist, eines Landes, ist so skurril.
Er ist ja sein eigener Feind, wenn man so möchte.
Ja, wenn man sich so eine Universität, die jedes Jahr 20.000 Studenten da irgendwie
durchbringt, dann bräuchte man ja 100 Jahre, um mal einen Seminaristen zu finden,
der es so übertreibt wie er.
Und der ist jetzt ausgerechnet Präsident eines Landes geworden.
Und das ist schon beachtlich.
Wir hören jetzt mal seine Definition von Libertarismus.
Right to Life, Liberty and Property. Its fundamental institutions being private
property, markets free from state intervention, free competition,
the division of labor and social cooperation.
Also keine Gewerkschaften, keine sozialen Gesetze, keine Einmischung Seiten
des Staates und dann bleibt nur noch der Unternehmer und der wird auch charakterisiert.
Kapitalisten, erfolgreiche Geschäftsleute sind soziale Benefizierter,
die weit von der Verpflichtung der Mehrheit der anderen zu der generellen Well-Being-Genehmigung
contribuieren. Endlich ist ein erfolgreicher Unternehmer ein Hero.
Ja, aber es ist ja eben kein general well-being, sondern das ist ja wirklich
die Definition von partikularistischem well-being.
Ja, er glaubt natürlich, dass ein Wirtschaftswachstum für ein gesamtes Land
grundsätzlich immer schon allen irgendwie zugutekommen wird,
was denn nicht der Fall ist.
Ja, dann sitzt man wie Rainer Hank in einer Landsendung und sagt,
es geht doch dann allen gut.
Ja. Es geht doch dann allen besser. Es geht nicht nur um Aufsummierungsfragen
und wie viel und so, sondern auch Verteilungsfragen.
Die werden hier ausgeblendet.
Für ihn kann immer nur der Staat der Schuldige sein.
Und er stellt jetzt ein paar Reflexionen an zum Thema Marktversagen.
Failure is an oxymoron. There are no market failures.
If transactions are voluntary, the only context in which there can be a market
failure is if there is coercion.
And the only one that is able to coerce generally is the state,
which holds a monopoly on violence.
So, Monopoly on Violence, Violence auf Seiten des Staates.
Wenn man jetzt die Marktkräfte einfach
gewähren lässt, kommt man um Monopolisierungstendenzen nicht drumrum.
Ja, da sei aber auch gar nichts Schlimmes dran. Genau.
Und da wird einfach eine Unfehlbarkeit doktriniert.
Es waren die Marktkräfte, also ist es richtig. Hauptsache es wurde sich nicht eingemischt.
Und dann ist ja wirklich die Frage, wenn 99% der Bevölkerung tot auf der Straße
liegt und der eine Kapitaleigner, weil er nur noch drei Ingenieure braucht,
mit denen alleine für sein partikularistisches Heil sorgt, das ist dann für
ihn kein Markt-Failure. Ja.
Dann hat das der Markt so entschieden. Das ist wie Gottes ewiger Rat. Ja.
Die Enttäuschung über Politik, die in Argentinien nun begründet ist,
ist hier so groß, dass man lieber die Politik aus der Geschichte tilgen möchte.
Einfach no. Wir haben eine ökonomische Asymmetrie, soziologisch würde man ja
dann auch historisch nachzeichnen können, wie zuerst die ökonomische Asymmetrie kam,
Dann hat man die versucht einzuhegen mit politischer Asymmetrie,
also man hat den Profiten ein Machtgefüge gegenübergestellt,
das von den Profiten entkoppelt, ansonsten wäre das ja Korruption.
Und um die politischen, also um die Machtasymmetrien wieder einzuhegen,
hat man juristische Asymmetrien daneben gestellt,
also Regeln, nach denen in der Politik Macht verteilt wird, damit die Macht
nach allgemeinen Regeln und nicht partikularistischen auf ökonomische Differenzen
einwirkt, um die einzuhegen.
Aus dem Gefühl her kann man die Politik nicht rausnehmen. Und er macht es trotzdem.
Und zwar in fundamentaler Weise. Wir haben gehört, überall wo der Staat sich
einmischt, da herrscht Zwang.
Und er tut das ja nicht nur in Form von Steuern, sondern auch in Form von neuen
Strömungen, die es in der Gesellschaft gibt, die auch einwirken.
Denn ganz gefährlich sind zum Beispiel auch Feministen.
Giving a job to bureaucrats who have not contributed anything to society.
Another conflict presented by socialists is that of humans against nature,
claiming that we human beings damage the planet, which should be protected at
all costs, even going as far as advocating for population control mechanisms
or the bloody abortion agenda.
Unfortunately, these harmful ideas have taken a strong hold in our society.
Neomarxist have managed to co-opt the common sense of the western world.
Also er kombiniert hier auch die Leute, die für eine Liberalisierung des Abtreibungsrechts
sind, mit denen, die Geburtenkontrolle ausüben wollen.
Also dass es für ihn alles, das geht noch minutenlang so weiter,
dass er wirklich alle auszählt, um so einen großen Kulturkampf dort aufzuführen.
Es ist schon ja häufig wie so ein Weltkommentar.
Hört sich dann diese Rede an.
Und jetzt haben wir mehrmals schon Sozialismus gehört und man denkt die ganze
Zeit, ja, aber was ist denn jetzt Sozialismus?
Da hatten wir doch mal eine andere Definition. Das war doch mal die Frage des
Privateigentums und muss man seine Arbeitskraft verkaufen?
Oder haben wir da Vergesellschaftungen?
Na, wir müssen nur den Sozialismus mal neu definieren, um zu erkennen,
dass wir im Sozialismus leben.
Das heißt, es ist ein ökonomisches System, in dem der Staat die Mittel für die
Produktion besitzt. Diese Definition,
in my view, should be updated in the light of current circumstances.
Today, states don't need to directly control the means of production to control
every aspect of the lives of individuals.
With tools such as printing money, debt, subsidies, controlling the interest
rate, price controls and regulations to correct the so-called market failures,
Ja.
Das ist das, was die Kryptobros über YouTube erzählen.
Der EZB-Sozialismus. Und jetzt hat er ja ein Problem. Er kann ja nicht sagen,
Bitcoin ist eine Staatswährung, weil er hat ja Venezuela gesehen und so.
Oder war das Venezuela? Das hat ja alles nicht geklappt.
Weshalb er jetzt sagt, okay, dann nehmen wir den US-Dollar und die Entscheidung,
wir nehmen den US-Dollar, heißt ja nur, damit wir uns als Staat raushalten können.
Nur dafür braucht er einen amerikanischen Staat.
Ja.
Der ist ja darauf angewiesen, dass der amerikanische Staat funktioniert.
So, kann er wirklich dafür garantieren, dass Trump mit dem Dollar,
entsprechend umgeht, dass das für ihn in Argentinien entsprechend seiner und
so weiter nicht, also es könnte ja genauso gut sein, dass, ah ja,
die sind jetzt von uns abhängig, von unseren Wechselkursen und so weiter.
Das heißt, wir nehmen die erstmal ökonomisch aus.
Weil damit kannst du ja eine Import-Export-Politik machen, die nun individueller nichts übrig lässt.
Kennt man so ein bisschen von der deutschen Agrarpolitik, von der europäischen
Agrarpolitik, die sich dann Nordafrika nimmt und sagt, bei euch gibt es keinen Ernährungsmarkt mehr.
Ihr lebt vom Weltmarkt, wir produzieren so viel, also verkaufen wir es an euch.
Das ist der Preis und so weiter und so fort. Also er liefert im Grunde Argentinien
jetzt dem Ausland aus. Was das angeht.
Und hofft aber, dass doch noch irgendwie die Kryptowährung auch wichtig ist.
Er hofft auf den Bitcoin 2.0 und so, dass er dann wieder sagen kann,
nee, das ist nicht wie bei dem ersten Bitcoin, diesmal klappt es.
Ja, das war nicht in Venezuela, da hat man auch ein bisschen rumexperimentiert,
aber das war in, ich habe es gerade verstanden.
Nee, in Venezuela regiert ja immer noch Maduro oder wie heißt,
dieses eine Land, was wir besprochen haben, wo der Bitcoin so schön eingeführt
und dann gefailt ist von diesem neuen Präsidenten.
Von Bukele wurde der eingeführt, richtig. Und jetzt hören wir also,
dass der Sozialismus in der EZB steckt.
Ja, eigentlich ist der Sozialismus überall.
Nationalsozialisten, Demokratischen Christen, Neokainsischen,
Progressiven, Populisten, Nationalisten oder Globalisten.
Am Boden gibt es keine großen Unterschiede.
Sie alle sagen, dass der Staat alle Aspekte der Leben der Individuen steuern muss.
Mir ist das alles zu kompliziert. Ich habe aber auch keine Lust auf eine große
Aufarbeitung, weil das hieße ja, das Problem ist in mir und ich brauche jemanden,
der es mit mir aufarbeitet oder wie auch immer. Sondern ich sage jetzt einfach, wie es ist.
Ich.
Will alles rausradieren. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn Merz sagt,
der ganze Bundeshaushalt muss neu aufgesetzt werden.
Was heißt denn neu aufgesetzt? Da kommt am Ende dasselbe raus wie jetzt auch.
Nämlich.
Dass der deutsche Staat ungefähr eine Billion Euro pro Jahr braucht,
um 3,5 Billionen Wirtschaftswachstum zu organisieren.
Da geht nun mal jeder dritte Euro einmal durch Staatshand irgendwo,
sei es als eine Mehrwertsteuerabgabe oder Einkommenssteuer oder was auch immer
und dann fließt das in Schulen, in Straßen und so und das ist halt, so ist es halt.
Wir organisieren das Bildungssystem abseits von Profitversprechen zum Austritt aus der Schule.
Weil die Erfahrung lehrt uns, wenn die Unternehmen selber ausbilden,
ist nicht an alles gedacht.
Und diese Erfahrung einfach rausstreichen aus dieser kollektiven Erinnerung.
Einfach so ein Gedächtnis tabula rasa machen und sagen, wir machen es nochmal neu.
Wir setzen es nochmal neu auf. Wir beginnen 1850 Manchester. Warum nicht 1848?
Nee, wir nehmen eine runde Zahl. Das ist wie wenn man beim Fernseher immer auf
runde Zahlen die Lautstärke stellt, weil irgendwie sonst die kognitive Distanz,
irgendwas quält einen so innerlich.
Und so ist er auch, ihm quält das einfach alles und er möchte einfach das Tabula rasa machen.
Doch wie kann das sein, dass man ihn einlädt nach Davos und da eine Rede halten
lässt? Also dass man ihn nicht wenigstens stellt in einem Talk?
Unklar. Also diese Rede wurde ja auch auf Deutsch übertragen bei Welt TV mit
einem anschließenden Ad-Hoc-Kommentar von Ulf Poschert, der auch sagte,
das kann ich gar nicht glauben, was ich da gehört habe. Es ging ihm zu weit.
Oh, aber er hat ja dann ein paar Wochen vorher noch so einen Artikel geschrieben,
dass Millet der neue Kant ist oder so etwas.
Ja, ja, ja. Es gab einige Lobhudeleien, aber.
Also das ging jetzt selbst Ulf Poschardt zu weit.
Das ging Ulf Poschardt wirklich zu weit. Aber es war auch erstmal nur so ein
Ad-Hoc-Kommentar. Vielleicht hat
er nochmal drüber nachgedacht und später irgendwas anderes dazu gesagt.
Er hat ja einen eigenen Podcast, in dem er, das empfehle ich sehr,
er hat so einen Podcast in der Welt.
Nein, wir empfehlen den nicht.
Die reden so 20 Minuten über Sachen und da kann man wirklich Impuls- und Intellektualitätskontroll
gestörte Menschen beim Reden zuhören, die einfach wirklich frei von der Leber
weg oder wie das heißt, Sachen sagen.
Völlig ohne einmal konzeptionell die Sachen nochmal durch so ein Gedankenapparat
schieben, ob das irgendwie Sinn macht oder so.
Ja, ja, ich meine, Poschardt kommt ja eigentlich so aus der Kunstbetrachtung,
hat ja da so auch angefangen und eigentlich ist er so ein Kind der Postmoderne,
der nichts mehr zusammen gedacht werden kann, also nur noch einzelne Bruchstücke,
das bastelt man mal notdürftig zusammen, zertrümmert es morgen wieder,
also man findet heute, dass Millet der neue Kant ist, morgen sagt man,
nee, das geht aber jetzt zu weit, übermorgen sagt man, ich hab nochmal drüber
nachgedacht, Millet ist vielleicht doch unser Messias, vielleicht brauchen wir
mehr Glauben, an weiß ich nicht wen.
Also das funktioniert so und man kann da aber eigentlich sagen,
das ist so die exakte Publizistik, die man braucht, wenn man in den sozialen
Medien erfolgreich sein will, dass man immer wieder Impulse auslöst,
immer wieder Reaktionen auslöst.
Das funktioniert selbstredend nicht, wenn man mal über Dinge nachgedacht hat
groß, sondern das funktioniert nur so, indem man irgendwas raus hat und irgendwas
wird ja schon passieren.
Es gibt ganz viele kleine Millets irgendwo und sei es nur so als Vögelchen im
Hinterkopf, dass die ganze Zeit die Leute quält, also Ulf Pascha zum Beispiel,
Friedrich Merz ja auch, das steckt überall so ein bisschen drin.
In Indien, das will ich nur ganz kurz erwähnen, hat ja eine riesige Investorenkonferenz
stattgefunden, von der niemand gehört hat.
Es gibt einen Artikel dazu im Handelsblatt von Matthias Peer,
der in Bangkok Korrespondent ist.
Und der hat über diese Investorenkonferenz Viprant Gujarat geschrieben und dort
war der indische Premierminister und man muss sich das wirklich vorstellen,
das ist dann wie so eine Arena,
wo die Leute da alle sitzen, also Investoren ohne Ende dort,
Unternehmer, man verspricht Großes.
Modi sagt, Indien ist ein Kraftzentrum für talentierte junge Menschen,
ein Technologiezentrum für die Suche nach Lösungen und eine Demokratie,
die Ergebnisse liefert.
Und man sagt dann auch hier, dass man sehr stark auf AI setzt,
dass das nochmal sehr viel ermöglichen wird, beschleunigen wird in der Wirtschaft.
Und dann war dort bei dieser Investorenkonferenz auch Mukesh Ambani zu Gast.
Das ist der, glaube ich, reichste Mann Indiens derzeit.
Er steht auf der Forbes-Liste weltweit auf Platz 10.
Ist also auch reicher als Jack Ma zum Beispiel. Ich glaube, der ist der reichste
Mann im ganzen indopazifischen, asiatischen Raum.
Er ist, hat er einen Sohn oder eine Tochter, die vor ein paar Jahren geheiratet
haben und auch aus einer Milliardärsfamilie.
Da war ja bei der Hochzeit zu Gast Hillary Clinton und Beyoncé hat gesungen.
Also über diese Maßstäbe sprechen wir jetzt hier. Und man kann also mit anderen
Worten sagen, dieser Mukesh Ambani ist ein sehr, sehr erfolgreicher und sehr reicher Mann.
Und jetzt muss man sich mal anhören, wie dort ein so mächtiger Mann spricht,
wenn in der Reihe 1 der Minister Modi sitzt.
Transformation happen.
Because of one leader. Our beloved leader who has emerged as the greatest global leader of our times.
And he is, Shri Narendra Bhai Modi, the most successful Prime Minister in India's history.
So spricht Manda mit Manda. Es geht noch weiter.
When you speak, the whole world not only listens, but applauds you.
My friends abroad ask me, what is the meaning of the slogan,
millions of Indians are chanting, Modi hai, to mumkin hai.
I tell them, it means, India's Prime Minister makes the impossible possible
with his vision, determination and execution. They agree.
Ja.
Es ist ja eine Huldigung von moderner Ausprägung wie, keine Ahnung, zur Kaiserwahl.
Und da sind jetzt internationale Investoren dort und man möchte jetzt Gelder
bekommen und der reichste Mann Indiens spricht so den Ministerpräsidenten an.
Und wir haben ja schon mal über Indien ausführlich gesprochen,
über diesen Hindu-Nationalismus, der dort von Modi immer weiter verschärft wird,
für die Pressefreiheit eingeschränkt wird.
Und zugleich haben wir so internationale Konferenzen, hier haben wir auch einen Modi, der ja sehr,
sagen wir, quecksilbrig unterwegs ist, also der kann ja mit dem Westen, aber auch mit China,
aber auch vielleicht mal mit Russland, von Russland bekommt man ja gerade jetzt
viele Energielieferungen, die kann man auch vielleicht nochmal in den Westen dann weiterverkaufen.
Also das ist ja so jemand, der das mit allen so macht und dann noch seinen Yoga-Tag oder was. Genau.
Das läuft bei Ihnen auch über den Bart und das Gesicht und so.
Sehr viel dieser ganze Kram kommt da so zusammen und man merkt also einmal eine
internationale Ausrichtung und dann dieser Hindu-Nationalismus.
Und ich glaube, dass wir schon auch in Modi so einen Führer par excellence erleben,
der eigentlich nochmal so bündelt, was wir generell erleben können.
Also wir haben ja rechte Regierungen.
Anders sind als rechte Regierungen des 20. Jahrhunderts.
Also wir haben ja eben nochmal deutlich gemacht, worin sich jetzt Remigrationspläne
unterscheiden von Wannsee-Konferenz.
Und du hast dann auf die Demografie und hast auf die Migrationsanteile verwiesen
und ich glaube, auch das können wir jetzt
generell sagen, also die nationalistischen bis faschistischen Strömungen,
die es gibt, ob man nach Italien blickt oder auch sehr, sehr,
rechts ist ja, Millet, das hat man jetzt eben nur kurz so in seinen Ausführungen
zum Feminismus gehört, aber es gibt ja noch viele weitere Aussagen, die sagen, ist, dass man,
sich aber sehr auf dem internationalen Parkett auch bewegt.
Also man macht nicht jetzt irgendein völkisches Ding, ja, also das ist vielleicht
was, was so aus der Höcke.
Aus dem Höcke-Bereich noch da Leuten vorstellt, aber dieser neue Rechtsruck
oder das neue Faschistoide, das tritt sehr international auf und das fand ich
jetzt sehr erstaunlich,
dass dieser Mukesh Ambani das auf den Punkt bringt, indem er beschreiben will,
was Modi eigentlich für einer ist.
Die kommenden Generationen werden dem Premierminister Modi für sein,
dass er sowohl Nationalist als auch Internationalist ist.
Sie haben eine starke Foundation für Vixit-Bharat gelegt, Indien als eine vollständig
entwickeltes Land in Amritka.
No power on earth can stop India from becoming a 35 trillion dollar economy by 2047.
Nationalismus und Internationalismus vereint in einer Person.
Der Internationalismus im Sinne von, wir machen mit AI Kryptowährungen,
wir locken ausländische Investoren an.
Nationalismus im Hinblick auf, wir tyrannisieren die muslimische Bevölkerung,
führen unseren Hindu-Nationalismus ein, unterdrücken die Frauen wieder und das glaube ich ist etwas,
was wir sehr häufig jetzt schon erleben und auch in Zukunft erleben werden.
Dass wir rechte, sehr rechte Regierungen bis faschistische Regierungen haben,
die nicht mehr auftreten in so einem völkischen Sinne, aber die eine rechte
Programmatik dann über Kulturkämpfe führen,
über religiöse Kämpfe und das ist ja auch glaube ich etwas, was man bei einem
anderen großen Teil, weil er so gerade auch bei diesem Weidel-Teil der AfD sehr gut erleben kann.
Man hat diese Internationalität, pflegt auch selbst einen Lebensstil, der keineswegs im 20.
Jahrhundert zu verorten ist und zugleich aber gibt es dann eine rassistische
Politik oder man macht halt mehrere Klassengesellschaften über Ethnie aus.
Auch das ist ja nichts Neues, also dass man Länder hat, die zwar einen ganz
hohen Migrationsanteil haben, wo aber einfach ein ganz großer Teil der Migranten,
wenn sie dann eine dunklere Hautfarbe beispielsweise haben,
einfach in gewisse Positionen niemals kommt und immer da unterdrückt bleibt.
Und ich glaube diese Bundscheckigkeit des Rechtsrucks, die sollte einem eigentlich
sehr klar werden und die ist ganz gut in dieses Bild gefasst,
internationalistisch und nationalistisch zugleich.
Also er verweist auf 2047, ein sehr krummes Datum, aber 100 Jahre Unabhängigkeit Indien. Ja.
Indien hat sich von Großbritannien als Kolonialmacht unabhängig gemacht,
was ja auch wieder bedeutet, da sieht man mal, wenn die dort indische Geschichtsschreibung
machen, hängt die immer noch sehr von europäischen Verursachungen ab und so.
Also es ist eingebettet in eine Welt und man hört hier diesen Supermilliardären
auf der Bühne, der also mit Modi so im Schulterschluss die Botschaft in die Welt trägt,
hier gehen große Kapitalentitäten und der Staat so Hand in Hand. Ja.
Und das ist ein Megatrend. Man könnte jetzt über diesen Januar 2024 ja unglaublich
viel, was medizinische Fortschritte, wir haben große Ernährungssachen hier in
Deutschland, wie auch immer.
Aber es gibt ein Megatrend und ich will nicht zu sehr drauf umreiten,
aber demografisch scheint es jetzt doch grundsätzlich allen zu blühen,
dass die Hälfte der Welt schrumpft, insbesondere die Fortentwickelte,
also das Gerangel um Talente.
Und das war in Davos einfach ein Megathema.
Wir haben die letzten Jahre dort immer chinesische Premierminister gehabt,
die so ziemlich arrogant auftreten und dann nochmal sagen, und Taiwan gehört
übrigens uns, und das sage ich auf der Bühne auch ganz offen und so,
und wenn sie Nachfragen haben, sage ich nochmal, also, ob es ein Überfall wird,
wissen wir noch nicht, aber Taiwan gehört uns, so.
So, jetzt haben wir einen neuen chinesischen Premier.
Xi hat ja seine Regierung so ein bisschen umgebaut. Keiner weiß so richtig,
was ist denn eigentlich und so.
Wir hatten lange keinen Außenminister, sondern nur diesen Vorsitzenden dieser
außenpolitischen Komitees da und so weiter und so fort.
Jetzt haben wir jedenfalls jemanden, neuen Li Kuyang, der auch nach Davos fuhr,
um dort als Premierminister so einen ersten Aufschlag, ein paar Wochen nur,
glaube ich, nach seiner Insamtbringung zu machen.
Und wir hören uns das mal in sechs Clips an, wie der Ton Chinas jetzt ist.
Und ich erinnere, wir haben Texte dazu gelesen, wie sich die Chinesen verrechnet
haben in ihrer demografischen Grundlage und so weiter, wie die ganze Politik
sich neu organisieren muss, wie dieses Ertrockenerwachen von heute auf morgen,
ach Corona ist jetzt doch kein Problem, geht mal zurück zur Arbeit.
Man stellt fest, so richtig klappt das irgendwie nicht und so.
Also wie einfach China wirklich struggelt.
Um die majestätige Schönheit der Alpen zu vollständig zu appreizieren,
muss man sich aus der Sicht aussehen und von weit weg schauen.
As I see it, it is the same with the Chinese economy.
One has to broaden the vision and take a panoramic view to see the whole picture
in an objective and comprehensive manner and truly grasp where it is now and where it is going.
Also, ganz sensibel und freundlich, freundschaftlich. Die Alpen,
die Alpen sind so toll. Er macht irgendwelche Anleihen zu den Alpen.
Wenn man da reinfliegt nach Davos, das sieht bestimmt auch super toll aus,
so ein Landeinflug in den Alpen.
Aber achtet man nicht so sehr aufs Panorama, nicht auf die Details.
China ist im Panorama ganz toll. Die paar Details, dass wir jetzt so ein 300
Milliarden Bauwirtschaftsbankding, was auch immer das ist, jetzt abwickeln müssen
und so, dass hier nichts mehr funktioniert. Bitte nicht so auf die Details schauen.
Nicht verrückt machen lassen.
Genau, nicht verrückt machen lassen. China ist ein tolles Land,
vor allem im Panorama, man sollte es betrachten wie die Alpen.
Und es ist ganz erstaunlich, wie sie wissen, wo ihre Schwächen sind und die
explizit zu ihren Stärken erklären, wo wir uns denken als Zuhörer,
nee, also das ist einfach zu blöd.
Man kann sich ja, also man kann sich ungefähr vorstellen, wie Markus Lanz immer
so für Dramatik sorgt in seinen Gesprächen, indem er irgendwem erzählt,
Also während seiner Sendung, wissen Sie, wie viele Ingenieure in Deutschland
jedes Jahr aus der Uni kommen? 20. Wissen Sie, wie viele das in China sind? 20 Millionen.
So.
Wir werden überrannt von chinesischen Ingenieuren, die werden alles dominieren,
die Schlüsseltechnologien und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt steht er so da und
sagt, die Demographic Dividend, also die demografische Dividende.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was er meint, dass wir viele sind und groß und deswegen
viel rauskommen oder was auch immer.
Also, ja, China hat sehr viele Ingenieure, aber die suchen auch händeringend nach Arbeit.
Also wir haben da eine Jugendarbeitslosigkeit von immer noch 20% oder mehr oder so.
Man weiß nicht genau, wohin mit sich lohnt sich für eine, wir haben das ja häufig
mit diesen Ein-Kind-Familien, lohnt es sich denn, in die so richtig zu investieren
oder sollten die lieber schnell irgendwo,
so wie man ja hier auch diskutiert, Studium, ey, ich will jetzt nicht nur Handwerker
werden, es läuft gerade so gut, man braucht so viele Handwerker, wie auch immer.
Beziehungsweise, wir hatten das im Live-Salon angesprochen, es gibt viele,
die sind gut ausgebildet, die sind in der Stadt, finden dort keine Arbeit.
Dann sagt die Regierung, ja, es gibt auf dem Land Arbeit. Und dann sagen die,
wie, wir sind jetzt in die Stadt gezogen, haben hier nicht eine Ausbildung gemacht,
wir würden jetzt gerne in der Stadt leben.
Also sind wir lieber arbeitslos in der Stadt, als mit Arbeit irgendwo in einem Caf. Ja.
Man hängt dann da so rum und wir haben es ja schon besprochen.
Shenzhen, ja, schön und gut, so eine Wirtschaftszone, da ist ganz viel mit neuer Technologie.
Aber daneben sind halt doppelt so große Gebiete, wo 50 Millionen Menschen leben
und da werden einfach nur Waschmaschinen und Old-Style-Technik,
die aber wichtig ist für die grundlegende Lebensführung in einem sich entwickelnden Land und so weiter.
Also es ist alles sehr viel weniger cool, als man so glaubt und es ist auch
nicht alles glitzern und glenden und durchelektrifiziert und wie auch immer.
Naja, aber irgendwo gibt es wohl eine demografische Dividende und da wissen
wir ja, wir haben es ja auch an einem Salontext besprochen, Untertitelung des ZDF für funk, 2017,
Die Chinesen haben 400 Millionen Rentner. Allein die chinesischen Rentner wären
die drittgrößte Nation der Welt.
Das ist auch demografische Dividende. Und dass man für die kein Rentensystem hat.
Sondern dass man die irgendwie aus einem laufenden System versorgen muss,
ohne dass sie noch einen produktiven Benefit erwirtschaften.
Aber jetzt haben wir ja, wie er sagt, die Talentdividende und das soll jetzt offenbar meinen,
dass also die sind zwar weniger geworden oder die werden nicht jetzt nochmal mehr,
also da erhöht sich die Dividende nicht, aber durch die großartige Bildungs-
und Ausbildungsarbeit, die geleistet wird, hat man jetzt eine hohe Dividende
in Bezug auf talentierte Leute. Genau.
Irgendwie so. Also die ganze Rede ist ein wackeliges Kartenhausgebäude,
es gibt auch nur eine Nachfrage oder so, das ist alles kurz vorm Zusammenbruch.
Zu dem Thema junge Menschen ziehen in die Stadt, kommen dann aber da auch nicht
weiter, weil ihnen die Partei nichts bieten kann und die Partei aber was bieten
muss, weil ihnen das Leben lang gesagt wurde, die Partei ist für alles verantwortlich und so.
Er sucht sich so die Kirschen raus, an denen man zeigen kann,
dass es China ganz gut geht.
Rate is now more than 10 percentage points lower than the average level of the developed countries.
There is much room for infrastructural upgrading, urban renewal,
transportation and telecommunications among others.
There are also some 300 million rural migrants who are acquiring permanent urban
residency at a faster pace.
Die Urbanisierung bleibt. Bei der Urbanisierung haben wir noch,
Raum nach oben. Wir sind noch nicht, haben unser Potenzial noch nicht ausgeschöpft.
Die urbanen Zentren, um die es hier geht, sind noch nicht ordentlich ausgerüstet.
Hier kann man noch in alles rein investieren und so weiter.
Megatrend-Urbanisierung soll also ausländische Investoren anlocken und dann
sagen, okay, gut, ist es halt die Urbanisierung.
Ich würde sagen, Urbanisierung ist sowieso ein Megatrend, auch in Deutschland.
Deutschland, diese Botschaft von, in Erfurt haben auch 3000 Leute demonstriert,
aber in München 300.000, heißt ja für alle, die in Erfurt demonstrieren,
warum lebe ich eigentlich nicht in München?
Da scheint es ja irgendwie angenehmer für mich zu sein.
Da habe ich mehr auf meiner Seite, solche Botschaften. Also die Urbanisierung,
egal aus welcher Richtung, ist immer wichtig, immer ein Megatrend.
An über 20 Euro Kaltmiete im Neubau.
Nächster Megatrend, den er hier auch nochmal betont.
Die.
Grüne Transformation, also Urbanisierung, grüne Transformation,
Transformation und das Ganze mit einer demografischen Dividende.
Sie müssen nur das Geld bringen.
Stimmt ja wahrscheinlich dann auch. Dann kriegen wir die Leute in ihre Unternehmen
verpflanzt und dann machen die dort für sie Profite.
Das ist also alles zusammen eine ganz große, wir betteln hier um Geld.
Ja, dafür ist Davos da.
Aber in diesem Jahr aus chinesischem Mund das so zu hören, das ist mehr als die letzten Jahre.
Ja, man hatte ja gedacht während Corona und vielleicht auch schon so ein bisschen
davor, dass man zwar immer sagte, ja wir sind weltoffen und wir sind gegen den
Protektionismus, den Trump will.
Also das war ja schon etwas, wie man sich immer in Davos verkauft hat.
Aber zugleich hat man sehr stark signalisiert, wir haben so einen starken Binnenmarkt
und wir können das alles so für uns, unter uns regeln.
Und das scheint sich jetzt doch zu ändern, weil ohne ausländisches Geld,
das hineinfließt, wird ja die eigene Misere, die man da produziert hat,
gerade im Immobiliensektor immer größer.
Also kann man eigentlich diese selbst produzierte Misere nur dadurch abfedern,
dass also andere wieder an das Land glauben und das sind ja dann Investoren.
Investoren, die sozusagen Geld und Know-how mitbringen und endlich was mit den
Leuten da anfangen können, mit den jungen Leuten.
Und zwar an den Orten, da möchte China dann hin, urbanisiert und so,
wo man sie braucht oder sie gerne haben möchte.
Es ist also eine ganz große Battle-Runde gewesen. Man hat China selten so gehört.
We embrace investments from businesses of all countries with open arms and will
continue work tirelessly to
foster a market-oriented, law-based and world-class business environment.
Und selbstverständlich ist das auch ein Signal an die Börsen,
denn das ist ja auch so, dass die chinesischen Aktien in den 10er Jahren mal
sehr beliebt waren und jetzt sind sie alle unglaublich abgeschmiert.
Und das bedeutet ja auch, dass die großen Schattenbanken dann sich überhaupt
nicht mehr dafür interessieren, dann da rausgehen.
Da werden auch nicht mehr neue Fonds, Marketfonds werden nicht mehr aufgelegt
mit chinesischen Aktien.
Also auch das meint ja Investitionen. Es geht ja nicht nur darum,
dass da Fabriken gebaut werden,
sondern auch diese Art der Gelder fließen dann nicht mehr, beziehungsweise diese
niedrigen Börsewerte sagen einem jeden Investor, da willst du jetzt noch eine
Fabrik aufbauen, guck doch mal die Aktien. Genau.
Und das eine ist, dass man jetzt schon so langsam so eine 10-jährige Durststrecke
hat, bei denen auch Unternehmen wie Apple überlegen, sollten wir nicht auch
mal woanders und dann hat man so irgendwie das nicht ganz aktuelle iPhone,
das dann schon in Indien hergestellt wird.
Also es fehlt an Investitionen, Wirtschaftswachstum. um allem China bettelt
und sie machen hier noch ein großes Zugeständnis.
Wir haben das ja auch ein bisschen nur so begleitet. Es gab dieses Investitionsabkommen,
das dann noch gescheitert ist, wo es immer hieß, naja, die Investitionsregeln
waren immer, ihr dürft euer Geld nach China bringen, weil die haben ja einen großen Markt.
Dann haben die ganzen Autobauer das gemacht und mittlerweile wird irgendwie
jeder dritte VW in China verkauft und so.
Aber ihr müsst auch euer Research und Development in China machen und ihr könnt
dann nicht alleine als VW investieren sondern ihr müsst immer ein Joint Venture
mit einem chinesischen Counterpart, also sehr strenge Regeln werden die Chinesen
hier einfach achso ihr wollt euch.
Die Häfen von Griechenland kaufen ja bitte, ohne weitere und so weiter,
dass man jetzt in Hamburg da mal diese paar Hafenmeter und so mit einem Veto
ausgestattet hat, was die Übernahmen durch chinesische Eigner angeht,
war ja dann mal so ein Novum.
Er macht jetzt hier auf diesem Felde, auf dieser Soft-Skill-Politik sozusagen, große Zugeständnisse.
Es gibt jetzt Partizipationsmöglichkeiten. Wenn man sein Geld mitbringt,
kriegt man auch ein paar...
Wie soll man sagen, politische Befugnisse mal was mitzubestimmen oder so.
Und ich mir denke, naja, aber so funktioniert es ja eigentlich nicht.
Also man kann ja nicht jetzt von Deutschland aus sagen, okay,
wenn ihr das Geld bringt, dann habt ihr auch Stimmrechte in der Handelskammer
oder wie auch immer, dann dürft ihr hier irgendwie,
oder dürft ihr das Lobbyregister eintragen. Also was genau meint er hier?
Also so ein bisschen schwammig, aber ein sehr bettelndes China. Ja, mal hier.
Jetzt Ursula von der Leyen, sie kriegt natürlich auch so ein Talk.
Steht dann auf der Bühne, verkauft irgendwie die Sonnen- und Windenergie-Fortschritte
der EU als wir machen jetzt mehr an Sonne- und Windenergie als russische Energie vorher da war.
Das ist eine echte Transformation.
Kann das sein?
Ich bin mir unsicher. Ich bin mir auch unsicher. Wir hören uns das mal an,
wie sie das als Kategorie formuliert. Sehr, nicht sehr bühntauglich, sagen wir mal so.
In Renewable Energy Capacity hit another record in the European Union in 2023.
And the European Union improved the efficiency of its energy.
The best energy is the one that is not used.
By almost 5%.
And in this way we turned Putin's challenge into a major new opportunity.
Last year, for the first time, the European Union produced more electricity
from sun and wind than from gas.
And this year, for the first time, the European Union is set to get more overall
energy from wind and solar photovoltaic than it does from Russia.
That is good news.
Ja, ein Investitionsstandort, der ja nicht an Energiearmut leidet,
also an hohen Energiepreisen und selbst ein Angriffskrieg in Nachbarschaft bringt
das nicht in Turbulenzen, selbst wenn die Hälfte des Stroms irgendwie von da
importiert wurde oder wie auch immer, das ist die Botschaft.
Aber es ist sehr kompliziert für eine Bühnenrede.
Ihr Top-Thema ist aber auch dieses.
So.
Talent, das ist also die demografische Dividende, die vorhin Li auch für sich reklamierte.
Das ist eine größere Konzentration als in den USA und China.
Das Argument finde ich so schräg. Das ist eine höhere Konzentration als,
naja, aber der europäische Standort hat ja immer darunter gelitten,
dass man hier so eine tolle Grundlagenforschung macht.
Auf allen Bereichen, Kernfusion, Künstliche Intelligenz, der ganze Kram.
Aber die Unternehmensbildung findet dann in Amerika statt.
Und dann gehen die rüber.
Genau. Und klar leben in Amerika 350 Millionen Menschen und davon sind dann
relativ wenige AI-Forscher. Ja, aber das sind halt die, auf die es ankommt.
Ja. Ja.
Das sind halt die Handverlesenen aus den europäischen Unis und überall aus Indien
und das ist ja nicht ohne Grund, dass Nadella und Pichai und so,
alle so aus der Welt halt da hinströmen und dann das machen,
dass die Amerikaner nicht aus sich heraus, also Sam Ortman ist ja echt ein Wundergewächs,
aber selbst Ilya Sutskever oder so, das sind ja auch alles wieder.
Jaja, und da sind ja auch Deutsche dabei.
Also auch der.
Der dieses komische Coinbase Ding machen will, ist ja auch ein Deutscher,
also das heißt, das ist ja Gang und Gäbe dort und das, was da nie verstanden
wird, ist, dass es da ja nicht um um Fabrikarbeiter geht, in der Form.
Dass man sagt.
Wir brauchen mal Leute, die mit anpacken, sondern das sind einfach ziemlich
solitäre Figuren, die man da braucht.
Dichte an AI-Forschern ist kein Kriterium. Das ist ganz schräg,
dass Sie das so gesagt haben.
Das finde ich auch geil.
Wir haben einen Vorsprung in den Industriedaten.
Von unvergleichbarer Qualität. Und wir wollen in das investieren.
Und das ist, weshalb wir europäischen Start-ups und SMEs mit Zugang zu unseren
Weltklasse-Supercomputern bieten werden, damit sie trainieren,
entwickeln und ihre großen AI-Modelle testen können.
Chats überwachen und dann daraus ableiten, welche Werbung wäre für dich die entsprechende.
Und was ja immer wieder betont wurde und was denke ich auch richtig ist,
dass Deutschland ja sehr viele Hidden Champions hat und einige andere europäische
Länder auch und dass diese Industrie mit einer neuen,
Fabriktechnik, die wie eine Plattform funktioniert, wo Daten einfließen,
wo man heute das, morgen das produzieren kann, dass also das auch sehr eigentlich
nicht datengetrieben ist.
Wir haben kein Social Media hervorgebracht und da ist auch nicht mehr mit zu
rechnen. Aber das ist etwas, was da ist.
Und da sagt man, ja da haben wir ja schon jetzt 10, 15 Jahre Daten gesammelt.
Da kann ja Meta jetzt nicht mithalten.
Die können Daten darüber haben, welche sexuellen Interesse jemand hat,
aber die haben keine Daten darüber, wie eine Autoeffizienz zusammenzubauen ist.
Und dass sie jetzt sagt, und da kombinieren wir das mit AI und sagen,
da haben wir einen unglaublichen Datenpool, auf den könnt ihr zugreifen,
während die anderen haben, die so Konsumentendaten, scheint mir Sinn zu ergeben.
Also die größten Opponenten der Datenschutzgrundverordnung waren ja die vor
allem deutschen Versicherer und Banken.
Also das kann ja schon unter Industriedaten fallen, wie wird da irgendwie mit Geld umgegangen.
Ansonsten denke ich bei sowas ad hoc, ich habe ja keine Ahnung davon,
einfach daran, dass es immer Proteste daran gab und Auszeichnungen, wie,
Datenschutz,
äh, wie soll man sagen, extravertiert die Autoindustrie umging im Sinne von,
wir bauen dir mal drei SIM-Karten mit ins Auto und messen alles.
Wie schnell du wann wo fährst, in welchem Winkel, wie lange die Tür offen steht oder wie auch immer.
Und dann war die Frage, warum speichert ihr das denn? Ja, keine Ahnung,
man weiß ja nicht, wofür man es noch braucht.
Irgendwie so. Also mal gucken, ob da ein Programm dahinter steht. Ja.
Da überläuft das ja natürlich. Also, dass man, also das ist ja immer diese Verlogenheit auch.
Man kritisiert ja wahnsinnig gern US-Konzerne oder chinesische Konzerne für ihre Daten sammeln Wut.
Selbst aber sammelt man natürlich, sammelt man wo es nur geht und möchte das
auch nicht eingeschränkt haben.
Was nur jetzt der Punkt ist, wenn sie sagt, wir haben da hier die ganzen Daten,
das ist ja speziell bei einzelnen Unternehmen.
Also das ist ja nicht gebündelt. Das heißt, sie hat ja nicht einen Pool,
wo sie sagt, ich docke euch mal mit hier an, dann könnt ihr auch auf die Daten zugreifen.
Die sind ja bei Siemens Oder die sind ja bei VW, aber die sind ja nicht überall.
Also programmatisch scheint mir das auch sehr schwammig zu sein.
Aber warum sollte man auch eine bessere Rede halten als die Chinesen?
Sie hat dann die Kontroverse nochmal aufgemacht. Es gibt ja danach immer diese
kleine Fragerunde, wo dann Schwab oder wer auch immer nochmal eine Frage stellt.
Sie will uns dann nochmal zeigen, dass sie auch in der Grundlagen Industrieversorgung
mit irgendwelchen Materialien ganz tief im Thema drinsteckt. Sie kennt alle Namen.
Exportkontrollen auf Germanium, Gallium und Graphit jetzt, keine Vertrauen bilden.
Wir sind also in intensiven Gesprächen über diesen Thema.
Aber für uns bedeutet das, die Risiken zu diversifizieren, die Suppladechengen,
mehr Handelsverträge zu haben mit mehreren Partnern.
Zum Beispiel haben wir gerade den Handelsvertrag beendet und Lithium spielt
dort eine große Rolle mit Chile.
Also alle Stoffe, die fehlen, kennt sie.
Gut.
Macron. Macron war nach sechs Jahren mal wieder da, um sozusagen,
ich habe euch damals gesagt, was ich vorhabe und jetzt cache ich ein.
Er hat so eine ganz komische Corona-Erinnerung. Die habe ich irgendwie nicht
verstanden. Vielleicht sagt das dir irgendwas.
Also Corona bricht aus und dann
möchte er die Handlungsfähigkeit Europas darstellen mit diesem Beispiel.
Within two months we had a French-German agreement and three months a European response,
to borrow together and build a program to help our economies. Ja.
Das war doch dieser Punkt. Ja, und da stand er mit Merkel gemeinsam da und da
haben sie das fröhlich verkündet.
Und das hat ja tatsächlich, war das für so einen kurzen Moment,
das macht auch hoch, ach, jetzt geht das auf einmal so gemeinschaftlich und
da ist jetzt nicht mit Schulden...
Ich kann mich da gar nicht dran erinnern.
Das war so ein ganz eigenartiger Merkel-Macron-Moment, wo man das also sehr
schnell machte, auch alle damit überrumpelte, alle fanden es aber auch sofort gut und man sagte,
wir haben jetzt so zehn Jahre immer gesagt, nein, auf keinen Fall da gemeinschaftlich rein,
das sollen die einzelnen Volkswirtschaften so mal für sich machen und das war
tatsächlich so ein Ding.
Aber ich würde sagen, es ist bezeichnend, dass du dich selbst schon nicht mehr daran erinnern kannst.
Für ihn war das wichtig, aber in Deutschland war das wieder so,
wollen wir mal schnell wieder vergessen, dass da mal irgendwas war. Was.
Ich noch weiß ist natürlich das Pandemic Emergency Program, das die EU 750 Milliarden
mobilisiert hat und 250 Milliarden über die Eurokirchische Kommission verschuldet sich selbst.
Erstmalig und bis heute einmalig. Also dass man da so den Dammbruch sozusagen
wie aus Deutschland gesagt würde.
Aber das meinte er dann nicht, weil das ist ja dann nochmal später gekommen. Ja, ja.
Er meinte Merkel und Macron und da war auch noch der Michel mit dabei. Also.
Ich habe es nicht nochmal nachgegoogelt, aber wenn es da sogar einen gemeinsamen
Auftritt mit denen gab, dann muss ich das ja seine gute Freundin und so.
Ansonsten die Standardthemen.
Für vier Jahre lang sind wir Europa's am liebsten attraktivste Land,
das die meisten Startups und die größte Fundraising hat, sowohl in den Service-
und Deep-Tech-Systemen als auch in den Raum-, Gesundheits- und Energie- und anderen Sektoren.
Es mangelt eben nicht an Selbstbewusstsein.
Zur neuen Familienpolitik in Frankreich. Also Schuluniform, Bildschirmzeit soll
geregelt werden und so weiter.
Die sollen wieder die Klassiker in der Schule lesen. Er hat ja sogar diesen
Zemmurspruch übernommen.
Frankreich muss französisch bleiben oder muss weiter den Franzosen gehören. Also er ist ja da.
Im deutschen Maßstab war das autokratisch. Bisher waren die Bette geregelt.
Wir schalten den Kindern die Handys aus, damit die morgens munter an der Schule sind.
Das schlägt sich hier so ein bisschen nieder.
Das finde ich eh krass, bei Davos als Präsident auf der Bühne stehen und vom
Human Capital zu sprechen, in das man investiert. Also sehr deutliche Ansage.
So, und jetzt ist ja so.
Während deutschen Verwaltungen, deutschen Unternehmen und so weiter ewig lange
das Thema Digitalisierung ist, digitalisiert euch doch mal und dann kam wieder.
Nee.
Doch noch nicht und so. Das ist ja beim Thema Künstliche Intelligenz ganz anders.
Da laden ja die Chefs richtig ein und sagen, liebe Belegschaft,
ich habe euch wieder ein Themaabend organisiert. Ihr habt heute frei,
AI-Workshop und wie auch immer.
Das klingt bei ihm, er übertreibt natürlich gerne, Frankreich ist der beste
Ort für Künstliche Intelligenzforscher.
Dass.
Sie etwas lockerer angeht, weil sie ersitzt schon nach der Rede,
die Rede war langweilig, und beantwortet Publikumsfragen.
We want to keep them as well and to have them in our industry.
But this is the first asset we have on AI.
The second is we have a proper strategy and now a vivid ecosystem in the different
parts of the value chain, from LLM, from training models, company,
but as well on the hardware part.
And this is the third, I think, competitive advantage of France.
Wir bieten Low-Carbon, pilotierbare und kompetitive Energie.
Und das ist super wichtig für die KI, weil einer der kritischen Punkte ist,
dass wir viele Prozess- und Kalkulierungs-Kapazitäten haben.
Also viele große Super-Kalkulatoren und Quanten-Kalkulatoren, viele Datenzentren.
Also viel Energie und Low-Carbon-Energie.
Nucleare Plants sind ein großartiges Asset dafür. for that and I launch a big
strategy to deploy more.
Also die Rechenzentren können laufen mit nuklearer Energie. Ist das so gesorgt?
Also ich finde das ja wirklich interessant. Wir werden auf jeden Fall,
auch wenn wir es heute vielleicht nicht schaffen, mal gucken.
Jeff Bezos hat jetzt sein erstes großes Interview gegeben und er macht einen
ganz interessanten Punkt bei AI.
Er wird von Lex Friedman gefragt, war es überrascht jetzt und so weiter,
irgendwie OpenAI, dieser Durchbruch.
Und er sagt, ja, aber was mich am meisten interessiert ist, wir sollten das
nicht als Erfindung kategorisieren, sondern als Entdeckung.
Man.
Kann ein Fernrohr bauen, das ist eine Erfindung. Was man dadurch sieht,
ist eine Entdeckung. Man sieht plötzlich die Planeten, er nennt dann Galiläe und so.
Und er sagt, dass die LLMs so gut funktionieren, ist eine Entdeckung.
Was für mich jetzt irgendwie bedeutet, kurz Schluss, wenn er jetzt sagt,
wir machen hier auch große Trainingdaten und so weiter,
OpenAI hat jetzt allen gezeigt, dass der Ansatz funktioniert,
Und dass die Milliarden, die man da rein investiert, nicht falsch investiert sind.
Also investieren jetzt alle Milliarden und werden die gleichen Erfindungen aufgrund
dieser Entdeckung machen.
Weshalb OpenAI nicht lange so alleine sein wird.
Google, klar, als erstes ziehen danach. Aber es wird durchaus auch französische
Klitschen, von denen man nichts hört, geben, die dann einfach mit Ursula von
der Leyen Industriedaten versprechen.
Irgendein ganz spezifisches und das aber dann Weltspitze und so weiter.
Also es ist in der Hinsicht, ich finde es sehr amüsant, wie er das so sagt,
wie das einfach aufzählt und wir haben eine proper Strategy und so.
Und auf der anderen Seite hat er wahrscheinlich recht damit irgendwie,
dass er hier nochmal die Atomkraftwerke nennt.
Und da muss man sich ja wirklich so vorstellen im Sinne von,
da ist eine Universität, dann bauen wir da ein LLM Unternehmen daneben.
Das braucht dann viel Energie, also kriegst du das nochmal an das Atomkraftwerk.
Die Investition lohnt sich so.
Und er sitzt wirklich so auf der Bühne fast.
More Nuclear announced that we already announced six new reactors und ich werde
im Juni 8 neue Reaktoren erneut.
Erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut.
Debatte nur von Friedrich Merz oder AfD-Leuten, aber jetzt ist ja Macron jemand,
der funktionale Argumente uns hier,
bietet. Wie reagieren wir darauf?
Also ein Atomkraftwerk zu bauen muss sozusagen in, also Kühlung über Flüsse
funktioniert in Frankreich nicht mehr.
Das ist flächendeckend 45 Grad im Sommer. Man braucht die auch im Sommer.
Man kann die nicht dann drei Monate ausschalten, wie auch immer.
Man braucht neue Ansätze.
Die neuen Ansätze müssen auch getestet werden.
Das sind alles Fertigstellungen in 20 Jahren und so.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Also mit einem Atomkraftwerk ein LLM trainieren,
also so im spezifischen Kontext, man braucht jetzt diese Energie.
Einen Windpark kann man auch so schnell aufbauen.
Irgendwo, die haben ja auch Küstenstreifen, einfach so 10 Megawatt Turbinen,
1000 Stück und dann hat man auch gigawattweise Strom Stromleitung legen,
aber das mit den Atomkraftwerken, ich weiß nicht, das ist so behäbig und langsam
und auch so unsicher, was am Ende dabei rumkommt.
Naja, und gerade wenn das mit der Kühlung nicht mehr funktioniert.
Noch eine andere wichtige Frage, findest du nicht auch, dass die die Krawatte viel zu dick ist.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was da los ist.
Also er trägt ja Dreiteiler. Fast alle anderen nicht.
Er trägt Dreiteiler, finde ich nicht so schlecht. Aber die Krawatte ist ja riesig
und viel zu dick gebunden. Ein unglaublicher Knoten ist das.
Ich weiß auch nicht, vielleicht wusste er, ich bin weit weg von den Leuten und
die sollen sie sehen. Also brauche ich mehr Masse.
Aber er ist doch dort unter Leuten, die tragen ja alle Krawatten aus seinem Land.
Also da würde ich sagen, ist die Die MS-Krawattendichte besonders hoch in Davos.
Und da muss man doch dann auch eine MS-Krawatte oder so tragen.
Keine Ahnung, was da los ist.
Zurück zum Thema.
We must also invest much more in artificial intelligence, in semiconductors
and we must have a much more consistent and coherent strategy.
Wir haben AI-Talent, wir haben Chips, wir haben Semiconductors,
wir haben Atomkraftwerke, wir haben alles.
Frankreich richtig gut aufgestellt. erst am Ende, also erst in seiner Fragerunde,
und deswegen gehen wir noch mal kurz darauf ein, wird sein eigentliches Lieblingsthema thematisiert.
Es bedeutet nicht, deine Verbindungen, deine Verbindungen und deine Partnerschaften
zu töten, aber es ist nicht, überdependent zu sein auf kritischen Sektoren deiner
Wertschätzung und einigen Geografien.
Ich denke, wir haben es perfekt, als ich dieses Thema sechs Jahre ago advokierte,
nicht komplett geteilt.
Aber.
Ich denke, wir haben während der Pandemie den Kosten der Überdependenz erlebt.
Die Risking von China, militärische Unabhängigkeit von Amerika,
er hat mit den Chinesen schon gesprochen, die Risking voll okay,
haben wir ja bei den Chinesen vorhin auch gehört, ihr dürft gerne mitreden,
wenn irgendwas ist, wir entriskieren euch.
Aber er meinte damit auch die Risking von den USA.
Genau, also für ihn geht es vor allem um.
Also er saß ja, wir hatten auch glaube ich mal den Clip, das ist anderthalb
Jahre her, wo er sagte, ja, aber nein, das war genau als Biden zurückkam und
dann hat von der Leyen die ganze Zeit nur gesagt, America is back.
Und er hat gefragt, er fragt sich für wie lang und er hat das ja immer wieder
deutlich gemacht und jetzt hat man diese Sache dort,
dass Trump wieder Präsident werden könnte oder vielleicht sogar werden wird
und dann ist ja interessant wie jetzt auch so reagiert wird auf diese Idee von Souveränität.
Also das ist zum einen denke ich jetzt schon so eine späte Adaption eines Makronschen Modells,
zum anderen aber sieht man auch, dass man bei Wolfgang Ischinger lesen kann,
naja die Welt wird davon so nicht untergehen, man wird weiter die USA als wichtigen
Partner haben, aber wir müssen dann zusätzlich nochmal aufrüsten.
Also da sind dann solche Ideen schon wie, brauchen wir nicht nur ein 2% Ziel,
sondern ein 4% Ziel und da sehe ich auch eine ganz große Gefahr drin,
also dass so ein neues Souveränitätsgerede eigentlich bedeutet,
dass man extrem aufrüsten wird und noch zugleich aber nur das Ganze in so einem
Festbindungsrahmen denkt und nicht wirklich als multipolare Weltordnung,
wo man sich ein bisschen aus gewissen,
Blockkonfrontationen heraushält.
Ja, jetzt wo in Deutschland wieder diskutiert wird, ob wir alle nochmal eine Wehrpflicht brauchen.
Ich hätte ja gerne so eine Resilienzdebatte, in denen dann erstens ganz explizit
mit Frankreich der europäische atomare Verteidigungsschirm diskutiert wird.
Sodass dann mal beide aus der Deckung kommen, man hört dann immer nur,
was Macron so sagt irgendwie und wie Scholz nicht reagiert.
Ischinger sagt ja, in so einem Handelsbeitrag hat er das im Januar ausgeführt,
dass er dafür sei, dass man das mit Frankreich dann regelt für Deutschland.
Und er sagt ja, wenn immer diese Ausrede kommt, ja, aber das geht doch nicht,
dass in Paris dann darüber entschieden wird.
Momentan akzeptiert man ja auch, dass in Washington darüber entschieden wird.
Also er sagt ja kein Unterschied.
Was ich aber jetzt sehe, ist ja, dass wir zum einen das haben und ich glaube
in den Thinktanks wird es auch schon diskutiert.
Und zum anderen haben wir diese Wehrpflicht und irgendwie passt das ja,
wir haben das ja schon häufiger herausgestellt, nicht so zusammen,
dass man einmal sagt, ja wir könnten eine Atombombe werfen, schicken also keine
Soldaten los und zugleich gibt es aber den Ruf nach mehr Soldaten.
Wie passt das zusammen? Jetzt kann man sagen, ist das einfach nur irrational?
Ich glaube nein. Nein, ich glaube, worauf wir künftig hinausdauern und in gewisser
Weise kann man es in der Ukraine schon sehen, ist,
dass wir zum einen atomare Aufrüstung erleben und man damit immer diesen totalen
Krieg haben kann im Sinne von, ja, wir drücken alle mal auf den roten Knopf und dann ist Ende.
Ende, aber da das ja dann doch am Ende wohl keiner will oder dazu so mal bereit,
also was heißt mal bereit ist, sondern das dann nicht macht,
also auch Putin geht ja jetzt sehr weit in der Ukraine an, sie hätte ja jetzt
auch sagen können, ich lasse das mal lieber nicht, dass die mir eine Atombombe
auf den Kopf werfen vom Westen aus. Naja.
Rutscht ja so lange die nur unter Ukraine.
Jaja, genau, aber wir unterstützen dann mehr und noch mehr und aber trotzdem
gibt es nicht die Atoma- Eskalation, die zumindest zum Glück bis jetzt nicht,
Glaube ich, dass wir auf folgendes hinausläufen. Man hat diese Atommächte dann,
die sich gegenüberstehen, die könnten auf diese Weise eskalieren.
Das machen sie aber nicht, weil das ja auch dann das Ende für alle ist.
Also auch für die, die die Atombombe auslösen, kommt ja dann direkt eine zurück.
Und deshalb sagen sie, ja wir haben zwar diese Atommächte, aber wir haben noch
eine andere Möglichkeit doch uns laufend zu bekriegen und unsere Interessen
durchzusetzen und das geht ganz einfach, wir sind immer mal wieder bereit 100.000
Männer an den Tor zu schicken.
Und das ist ja etwas, was wir beobachten können. indem sie einer Wehrpflicht unterzogen werden.
Und ich will es auch nochmal, weil das immer gesagt wird, ja,
aber siehst du denn nicht, was in der Welt passiert?
Dann will ich die Frage hier so stellen.
Wenn China sich Taiwan nimmt, werdet ihr euer Leben dann opfern für Taiwan,
wo ihr, die ihr hier zuhört, die meisten nicht mal, und ich schließe mich damit
ein, auf einer völlig nackten Karte völlig korrekt Taiwan einzeichnen könnte.
Also würde man das machen?
Die Antwort lautet, wenn man ehrlich zu sich selbst ist, nein.
Immer nein. Ich würde auch sagen, die jungen Männer, um die es hier geht,
die sollten sich ganz kurz nur erheben in so einer Diskussion und sagen,
Ja, Herr Steinmeier, ich würde für Deutschland kämpfen, wenn an der Heimatfront alles geregelt ist.
Das heißt, für eine Verteidigungs- und Resilienzstrategie, zuallererst mal muss
das Stromnetz dezentralisiert werden.
Solange nicht auf jedem Haus eine Solaranlage ist, was bedeutet,
solange das Haus selbst nicht bombardiert wurde, wird es mit Strom versorgt.
Kann man nicht an die Front gehen. Solange man nicht sicher sein kann,
dass die Züge fahren, worauf sind die Ukrainer so stolz, dass der Zug immer fährt, auch im Krieg.
Solange nicht sichergestellt ist, dass die Züge immer fahren,
kann man die Heimatfront nicht verlassen, sondern dann wird man an der Heimatfront gebraucht.
Solange nicht beispielsweise Versorgungsinfrastrukturen wie die von Amazon entweder
staatlich abgesichert oder dupliziert werden, um einfach Versorgungssicherheit
herzustellen, kann man nicht die Heimatfront verlassen.
So, ganz am Ende kann man dann über eine Wehrpflicht diskutieren,
aber dann muss vorher erstmal die Resilienz- und Verteidigungsstrategie ordentlich
und zwar nicht nur diskutiert, sondern auch instand gebracht werden.
Und das würde 100 Jahre dauern. Und so lange ist leider kein Krieg mit deutschem
Personal irgendwo möglich.
Der Verteidigungsfall sieht dann anders aus, als wenn Deutschland direkt angegriffen würde.
Aber so lange droht, dass man, wenn man irgendwo ist im Auslandseinsatz,
dann zur Vergeltung Deutschland angegriffen wird und man ist dann nicht zu Hause.
Geht das nicht. Also das ist einfach ausgeschlossen.
Einer, der ein bisschen anders im Ton drauf war, Anthony Blinken,
Amerikas Außenminister, Biden selbst war nicht da.
Er hat auch nur so einen Gesprächszusammenhang gehabt mit jemandem,
den ich nicht kenne, es war nicht Schwabe oder sonst irgendwer.
Und wir haben ja von den Chinesen gehört.
Tech, AI und Öko, das sind die Megatrends. Er äußert sich auf seine Weise dazu.
Und statt dass dann die ganze Zeit nur über, ich habe vor sechs Jahren versprochen
und so weiter, oder wir haben die besten Industriedaten oder wir haben die meisten
Atomkraftwerke oder was auch immer. Es ging tatsächlich nochmal ein bisschen
um die eigentlichen Sachen, die die Welt zu beschäftigen.
Sehr erstaunlich.
Das sind mal deutliche Worte. Gut-Wrenching und it breaks his heart.
Die größte Herausforderung der Welt, während alle nur von Künstlicher Intelligenz
reden und wir in der Case besprochen haben,
wie Larry Page von Google Elon Musk vorwirft, ein Species zu sein,
der den Mensch über die Maschine wertet.
Hier auch ein Grundbegriff.
Mit anderen, ist Dehumanisierung.
Dehumanisierung. Kann man ja auch mal in die Richtung denken.
Ja, sehr gut.
Also AI kommt und sollen wir uns jetzt um diese Dehumanisierenden,
die können uns ersetzen, wie auch immer, Assistenzsysteme, sondern Dehumanisierung
ist hier ein großes Problem.
Wir werden ja gleich noch was zu TikTok haben und da können wir uns das jetzt
schon mal im Hinterkopf behalten. Dehumanisierung.
Wie da eigentlich auf Menschen geblickt wird. Ja.
Leider ist es so, dass Blinken, kurz bevor Trump die Macht wieder übernimmt
und wen auch immer zum Außenminister macht, hier durch die Welt tourt und derzeit
ja wirklich, wie wir es ja hier auch in einem anderen Ton von ihm hören als
vorher, also der Typ tritt ja anders auf.
Zu den großen politischen Fragen hat er leider wirklich nur Idiotenfragen aus
der Moderation bekommen,
mit denen er bewusst und explizit nichts anfangen sollte und es ist für eine
Davos-Veranstaltung so ein bisschen haarsträubend bescheuert.
Wenn du dich mit ihm auf diese Themen in Russland engagierst,
sagst du ihm immer, dass Russland ein Verlierer ist?
Warum gehst du mit diesem Verlierer zusammen?
Well, in diplomacy times, it's not like journalism, it's a different terminology.
No, and I'm not commenting specifically on what you just said.
You know, occasionally you see collections of countries coming together and
it reminds you of the famous bar scene in Star Wars.
Not necessarily something you want to be a part of.
But let me say this first.
Also ich halte ja Blinken für in der Riege, in der er spielt,
den interessantesten Gesprächspartner für die Bühne, weil er wirklich auch ein
bisschen bereit ist, mal was zu sagen und nicht nur, mein Präsident ist der
Beste und so weiter, sondern mal so.
Leider wurde die Chance einfach vertan.
Aber hier bekommt er Angst, da weiß er ganz genau, was jetzt blüht,
wenn er da falsch antwortet und dann kann er da nichts machen.
Ich will das überhaupt mal ganz kurz einwerfen, weil man hat jetzt immer so
gesagt bei den Demokraten,
die haben ja auch kein gutes Personal und Kamala Harris wäre auch sicherlich
keine ideale Kandidatin und jetzt sieht man wirklich sehr schlimme Auftritte
von beiden mit unter, dass man da Angst bekommt.
Es ist wirklich furchtbar.
Warum hat man eigentlich den Blinken nicht genommen? Der macht doch so viel
her. Aber der macht doch wirklich viel her.
In Europa hört man immer, vor allem hier in Deutschland, dass die Demokraten
da niemanden aufbieten können, der Biden mal.
Es ist wie in Deutschland auch, Merz möchte gern Kanzler werden.
Biden möchte gern Präsident bleiben. Es mangelt da nicht an sehr guter Konkurrenz
oder so, sondern das sind einfach diese Machtspiele. und sich da Trump so geschlagen zu geben.
Also wenn ich mir jetzt ein Duell vorstelle, Trump, der da völlig eskaliert
und du hast dann so einen sehr feinen Herrn,
der intelligent genug ist, sich nicht provozieren zu lassen,
sondern seine eigenen Punkte setzt,
da könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass der dann eine andere Tonalität reinbringt,
statt jetzt so einen Biden, der nochmal so aus dem großväterlichen Ohrensessel heraus Ja.
Und selbst wenn man sagt, Blinken ist keiner für die erste Reihe,
sondern so ein Arbeitstier, der dann einfach diese acht Reisen in drei Tagen
macht oder so, könnte man ja sagen, ja dann sollte die Strategie der Demokraten
sein, nicht ein Präsidentschaftskandidaten, sondern sofort ein Team.
Zu präsentieren.
Ja, das ist natürlich so stark personalisiert, ob das noch irgendwie geht.
Ich glaube, das könnte für Überraschungen sorgen, denn ein Team gegen Trump,
Trump alleine, das wäre nochmal so eine andere Dynamik irgendwie.
Gerade auch bei der Frage, wer für die Präsidenten-Debatte.
Man hat momentan bei diesen beiden Videos ja eher, wenn andere Leute mit im
Bild sind, den Eindruck, die sind da, um ihn ein bisschen abzustürzen, damit er nicht fällt.
Ja, Biden sollte tatsächlich nichts mehr live machen, sondern nur noch so,
keine Ahnung, Stimmungsbilder, die aus der Retorte von gestern Archivmaterial
oder so damit versuchen, irgendwen zu überzeugen.
Also Blinken hier auf der Bühne, er spricht mal noch...
Irgendwie nicht dann die Florian Silbereisen-Show. Wir sind zum Vollblayback
nochmal unsere Einwohner.
Da ist kaum Strategie irgendwie für beiden. Blinken sitzt hier auf der Bühne.
Es geht um Investitionen, AI und so weiter, Atomkraftwerke, haben wir genug Rechenzentren.
Er spricht mal über die Themen, die nun wirklich alle Amerikaner besorgen. Und.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass es die Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat,
dass es es sein sollte. Der einzige Nummer 1 Täter von Amerikanern, der 18-49 Jahre alt ist.
So, 18-49, das ist das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial.
Oder die werberelevante Kundengruppe oder wie auch immer. Also das ist wirklich
die Einflugschneise, um den Investoren von Davos, die sie ganz großen Geschäfte
machen, hier einen Punkt zu machen.
Und ich hatte das ja im Salon mitgebracht, im Live-Salon, diesen Clip,
als der chinesische Außenminister in den USA war und die Pressekonferenz gibt
und normalerweise verkündet man ja nur die großen Sachen.
Und das ist aber die große Sache, weil ich dann dachte, wovon reden die denn jetzt da?
Direkt als zweites erwähnte er, dass sie da jetzt ein Abkommen geschlossen haben,
dass sie versuchen, dass diese synthetischen Drogen nicht mehr weiter exportiert
werden können, dass sie da versuchen jeweils ihre Menschen,
ihre jungen Menschen zu schützen. Also das ist ein Riesenthema.
Ja und dann hatten wir mal über das Buch kurz gesprochen, hatten da Podcast-Ausschnitte
gehört, Tod aus Verzweiflung.
Also wie sehr das eigentlich epidemisch geworden ist, dass sich mit Drogen dort
der Tod ausbreitet in jungen Jahren.
Bezos wird in diesem Gespräch, das wir nachher oder später hören,
über den Long-Term-Missen ungefähr so reden.
Ich hätte gern 1000 Einsteins und 1000 Mozarts. Also sagt er ganz explizit. Wie kommt man dazu?
Naja, man muss die Menschheit auf eine Billion gleichzeitig lebende Menschen
expandieren. Wie geht das? Naja, Weltraum.
Also wir haben irgendwo Weltraumstationen, in denen man in so Röhren lebt,
wie das in so dystopischen Science-Fiction-Filmen.
Hauptsache, es ist eine ganz große Grundgesamtheit da, damit sich Jeff Bezos,
die tausend Mozarts und die tausend Einsteins zu seiner Belustigung und seiner,
partikularistischen, ökonomischen Strategie und so weiter herausfischen kann.
Dabei übersieht er, dass es die tausende Einstellungen schon gibt,
wo stehen die irgendwo gerade auf einem Reißfeld und können leider sich nicht
der Mathematik oder sonst was...
Oder dass deren Eltern sich gerade mit synthetischen Drogen die Kugel gegeben haben.
Also in deren Sicht, hier haben wir es, das ist wirklich ein ganz wichtiges
Thema für alle Fragen, die wir gerade derzeit haben und Blinken führt es ein
mit, ich weiß nicht, ob das gerade richtig rüberkam, deswegen sage ich es nochmal.
Ihr Erwerbspersonenpotenzial stirbt gerade weg. Und zwar nicht,
wie Sie glauben, weil Fehler im Straßenverkehr oder Waffen, was man uns nachsagt,
sondern wegen diesen Drohungen.
Nun gut. Taiwan.
Wenn das zerstört würde, würde es den ganzen Planeten beeinflussen.
Und es ist die letzte Sache, die wir brauchen, besonders wenn wir von Covid zurückkommen.
Zweitens, um das Obvielste zu sagen, die Semiconductor und die Verbraucherkapazität,
die Taiwan hat, das beeinflusst jede Person in diesem Raum und fast jede Person rund um die Raum.
Von dem Smartphone, den Sie in Ihrem Koffer tragen, zu Ihrem Dischwasher,
zu Ihrem Auto, zu allem anderen. So klein ist es.
Das finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Taiwan ist die Schicksalsfrage unserer Menschheit. Also wenn wir es nicht hinkriegen,
auf Taiwan aufzupassen, dann ist jeder Mensch auf der Welt betroffen,
dann gehen nicht nur Lieferketten kaputt, sondern dann geht einfach gar nichts mehr.
So, und jetzt wenn man so ein Science-Fiction-Szenario, ein Komet kommt auf
die Erde und wir wissen, er trifft auf Taiwan.
Wir haben fünf Jahre Zeit, was würden wir tun?
So, und dass wir diesen Kometen gerade selbst, also dass es unser Komet ist,
dadurch, dass die Chinesen da irgendwie außer Rand und Band und so weiter und
so fort, das geht in keinen Kopf rein.
Also das ist einfach, das muss man auch weltweit so thematisieren,
wenn irgendwas mit Taiwan passiert, ist nukleärer Winter.
Naja.
Das ist halt die Frage.
Also Adam Tooze sagt ja, nee, eigentlich müsste Europa jetzt klar signalisieren,
der Status Quo ist das, was wir, also so wie er ist, das eigentlich, was wir präferieren.
Aber wir werden nicht militärisch eingreifen, wenn was ist. Weil wir sonst auch
den dritten Weltkrieg zusteuern.
Also das sagte ja gerade Adam Thyssen in seinen Vorträgen immer,
dass es das Eskalationspotenzial bei den Chinesen gibt, aber es gibt auch das
Eskalationspotenzial bei den anderen.
Und da ist aber diese Taiwan-Frage natürlich noch zusätzlich auch verknüpft
mit anderen wirtschaftlichen Interessen, die noch so dran liegen.
Also die Frage, ob wir eingreifen.
Ist gar nicht so, also die finde ich total irrelevant. Wir werden nicht eingreifen.
Sagen alle, niemand wird eingreifen. Naja.
Aber die Demokraten würden ja, sind ja so.
Ja, aber in was eingreifen? Die Frage ist ja ganz konkret.
Naja, einmarschieren in China.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja ganz konkret. Wenn erkennbar ist, dass China in Taiwan
einmarschiert, wird irgendwer diese Anlagen sprengen? Die gibt es dann einfach nicht mehr.
Da weiß ich nicht.
Ob das passiert. Ja, also es wird, es ist undenkbar, es gibt kein Szenario,
in dem man mit militärischer Gewalt die Hoheit über diese Fabriken erringt.
So, dafür sind die Selbstzerstörungskräfte und die, wir gönnen es euch nicht
und wir können auf gar keinen Fall das in chinesische Hände fallen lassen, Kräfte zu groß.
Dazu muss aber keiner aus dem Ausland eingreifen oder Taiwan verteidigen.
Deswegen dieses Szenario, also darüber braucht man gar nicht diskutieren,
es wird wahrscheinlich eine ganz kurze Aktion, zwei, drei Tage oder so und danach
gibt es da nur noch eine Insel, um die man kämpft, alles andere muss von Grund
auf neu und so weiter. Also das wird man nicht in die chinesischen Hände fallen lassen.
Nur die Frage ist, wie lässt man dieses Szenario dann trotzdem zu?
Und wir stehen ja irgendwie so kurz davor. Also die Chinesen,
es ist ja nur die Frage, wie die Chinesen kalkulieren.
Gönnen sie, nachdem jetzt die Amerikaner auch die Chinesen davon abgeschnitten
haben, dass da Exporte nach China stattfinden und so weiter,
also die müssen es auf eigene Faust machen, sagen sie sich dann einfach,
ja dann müssen die Deutschen auch.
Also dann sollen die Deutschen mal in Magdeburg mit ihrer Intel-Fabrik gucken,
wie weit sie kommen. Taiwan ist jetzt erstmal Geschichte. Geschichte.
So.
Und das ist, also, dass man das bewusst, also wie er ja bedauernd aufgreift,
dass man es überhaupt zu dieser Gefahr kommen lässt, statt jetzt einfach zu
sagen, liebe Chinesen, liebe Amerikaner, jetzt redet doch einfach mal darüber, worum geht es euch?
Die Kosten sind so hoch, ihr könnt jetzt einfach mal freie Schnauze reden, worum es euch geht.
Ihr spielt ja nicht vor einem unbekannten, großen Dritten ein Theaterspiel,
bei dem dann spieltheoretisch jemandem Vorteil gegen, sondern einfach mal ganz
offen sagen, worum es was euch geht, weil die Alternative ist,
ich meine, uns hat jemand über Texte geschickt, dass angeblich bewusst unter
diesen Fabriken also Bomben installiert wurden, um das einfach,
Also so richtig, wie man sich Selbstzerstörungsmechanismen auf der Brücke der
Enterprise vorstellt. So, weißt du, bevor die auf die Brücke kommen,
das Schiff unternehmen, zerstören wir es lieber und töten uns auch.
Gut, ich halte alles für möglich, nur ich würde nochmal deutlich machen wollen,
dass wir ja den zusätzlichen Konflikt, den es gibt, neben dem Taiwan-Konflikt, ist ja der,
dass man eine Block-Konfrontation zwischen den USA und China hat.
Und das hat ja Adam Tooze in diesem Vortrag mit der IG Metall,
den wir hier ausführlich behandelt haben, deutlich gemacht, dass wir da an so
einem Punkt sind, wo eigentlich die USA sagt, ja also China darf schon wachsen,
aber bitte nicht in irgendwelchen relevanten Bereichen, also Chipindustrie etc.
Und dass das ja nichts ist, was man irgendwie einer anderen Wirtschaftsmacht
aufzwingen kann, dass man jetzt sagt, ihr könnt jetzt mal in gewissen Konsumentenbereichen
wachsen, aber nicht generell und wir wollen schon die Vorherrschaft haben.
Also da gibt es ja kein angestammtes Recht beziehungsweise keine Legitimität
und dass daraus so eine Blockkonfrontation immer wahrscheinlicher wird,
die dann auch kriegerisch umgesetzt wird.
Also Adam Tooze hat ja wirklich von einer schießenden Auseinandersetzung gesprochen.
Das sehe ich als eine ganz große Gefahr an und möglicherweise ist dann für die
eine oder die andere Seite oder für beide Seiten Taiwan so ein Feigenblatt,
warum man jetzt gerade da agiert.
Aber es geht natürlich dann nicht um die Menschen in Taiwan,
sondern es geht dann nochmal um sehr viele andere Interessen,
die damit eingebunden sind.
Und dieses Eskalative, das wir so stark jetzt haben,
auch im gesamten europäischen Diskurs, finde ich, läuft ja auf eine Zeit hinaus,
wo man sagt, gut, dann brauchen wir über den Klimawandel nicht mehr reden,
dann bomben wir uns so kaputt.
Ich will das nochmal unterstreichen mit einem Zitat, das schon ein bisschen
älter ist und du musst jetzt erraten, von wem das stammt. Und zwar...
Geht das so? Meine Einschätzung ist aber, dass insgesamt wir auf dem Wege sind,
doch auch in der Breite der Gesellschaft zu verstehen, dass ein Land unserer
Größe mit dieser Außenhandelsorientierung und damit auch Außenhandelsabhängigkeit auch wissen muss,
dass im Zweifel, im Notfall auch militärischer Einsatz notwendig ist,
um unsere Interessen zu wahren.
Zum Beispiel freie Handelswege, zum Beispiel ganze regionale Instabilitäten zu verhindern.
Horst Köhler?
Ganz richtig. Und Horst Kühler ist dafür zurückgetreten. Also da sagt man, das ist unmöglich,
dass man von deutscher Seite aus sagt, ja zur Not müssen wir auch Kriege führen,
um unsere Handelsinteressen zu vertreten.
Heute ist das das, was in jedem Kommentar steht.
Haben wir noch Hoffnung? Antony Blinken zu dieser Frage.
Es gibt mächtige, mächtige Lichtbeine, die man sehen kann, für die Art und Weise,
wie Dinge können, sollten und, glaube ich, werden, besser, anders.
Und wir haben über einen davon gesprochen. Man kann einen sehr anderen Zukunft
für den Mittleren Osten sehen, der endlich die Herausforderungen beantwortet,
die es verursacht haben und als Ergebnis vieles der Welt für Generationen verursacht haben.
You can see through the power of technology so much good that is possible in
solving fundamental problems.
Die Power der Technologie, das letzte, wie nennt man es, wo man sich dranhängt,
Silberstreif oder wie auch immer, das letzte Rockzipfelchen,
das war es, mehr kann er da nicht bieten.
Das ist echt nicht viel.
Ich will, nur um es abzuschließen, uns der Technik hinzuwenden,
wir reden ja dann gleich über TikTok, ein kleiner Clip von Nadella und ein von Altman jeweils.
Wir haben ja auf der Bühne besprochen, wie ich finde, das war ein großer politischer
Coup, OpenAI zu übernehmen, sich sozusagen von der Open-Vergangenheit loszusagen.
Wir sind jetzt for profit und wir wollen es mit Microsoft machen und den Markt
einmal komplett abschließen.
Niemand soll mehr glauben, dass man gegen Microsoft und OpenAI hier irgendwas erreichen kann.
Nadella sitzt auf der Bühne mit dieser neuen Selbstherrlichkeit,
die er da hat, die wir ja auch in den Gesprächen mit Kara Swisher und so gehört haben.
Er macht eine interessante Definition für, was das ganze AI,
diese AI-Wende jetzt bedeutet.
General Purpose Technology, also so wie der Universalcomputer.
Oder die Dampfmaschine. Ich
würde schon sagen, dass das hier keine schlechte Wortfindung ist dafür,
General Purpose Technology und dass
damit allein schon ein echt großer paradigmatischer Wandel markiert ist.
Sam Altman sitzt hier in so einem Panel, zusammen mit dem Chef von Salesforce
und so weiter, also alles ganz oben aufgehangen.
Und er ist wahrscheinlich der Einzige, der sagt, naja, mit Open Air und so weiter,
so gut ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Also da sieht man auch die Selbstherrlichkeit hier so drin spiegeln.
Ich spiele es mal nur aus Amüsement.
Für dich, was sind die Dinge, die es am meisten effektiv machen kann und was
sind die Dinge, die wir verstehen müssen, die es nicht machen können?
Ich denke, ein sehr guter Hinweis auf dieses neue Werkzeug ist,
dass es selbst mit seiner sehr bedingten aktuellen Fähigkeit und seinen sehr tiefen Fehler ist.
Die Leute finden Möglichkeiten, es zu nutzen, um gute Produktivitätsgänge oder
andere Gänge zu erzielen und die Bedingungen zu verstehen.
Also ein System, das manchmal richtig ist, manchmal kreativ, oft völlig falsch.
Welche Strategie ist das? Ist das zu sagen, das ist eigentlich gar nicht so
schlimm, was wir hier machen, das ist eigentlich ganz harmlos?
Also während alle da sitzen, von allein der Chinese, Lee, Macron, sowieso,
man hört heraus, dass sie es mega finden, dass sie es nicht in Abrede stellen,
dass es die Welt verändern wird und dass sie selbst irgendeine kleine Rolle
damit spielen und so weiter.
Die müssen sich also alle, die Bedeutung liegt nicht bei ihnen,
sondern sie müssen sie an sich heranziehen, sich andichten, sie müssen sich
selber den Nimbus verschaffen, semantisch, obwohl alle da sitzen und denken, ja Macron,
ich weiß nicht genau, ob du weißt, worüber du sprichst.
Von der Leyen ja auch. Man kann sich ziemlich sicher sagen, ohne jemanden an
ihrer Seite, irgendeinen Personal
Assistant, würde die nicht mal ein YouTube-Video hochgeladen kriegen.
Bei ihm ist völlig klar, er weiß, wovon er spricht. Wenn er jetzt die Limitierung
eingesteht, dann weiß man, bei ihm ist man an der richtigen Adresse. No Bullshit.
Also ein bisschen mehr No Bullshit. Bei den anderen kriegt man halt nur das,
was man halt so sagt, weil man viel Geld haben möchte oder was auch immer.
Und er kann einfach jetzt diesen Nimbus ausspielen, dass an ihm eh kein Weg
vorbeigeht, aber ihm geht es wenigstens ehrlich zur Sache.
Weil die Leute sitzen ja da und wissen, das hat Limitierung.
Und es ist auch sehr oft falsch.
Nur wenn der Macron das jetzt auch noch sagt, dann sagt er ja,
also unsere AI ist nur so halb gut.
Dies wird auch häufig falsch sein, aber bringt trotzdem eure Milliarden und so.
Er hat ja die Milliarden schon. Er hat ja mit seinem Nadella-Deal alles geregelt.
Von daher bringt er sich wieder in so eine Solitär-Situation.
Die No-Bullshit-Solitär-Situation-Position von Sam Altman. Der wahre Führer unserer Welt.
TikTok verändert sich schnell und wir wollen erst einmal darüber sprechen,
was macht die Plattform jetzt anderes und wie reagieren auch dann die User zum Teil darauf.
Wir hören jetzt mal in den Podcast vom Wall Street Journal rein.
For more than 20 years, if you wanted to find information on the Internet, you googled it.
There are other search engines, of course, but Google is the one that became
a verb. Now that trend seems to be shifting.
Millions of people, especially young people, are turning to TikTok for answers.
Mehr und mehr wird TikTok jetzt zu einer Suchmaschine.
Ja, aber das ist doch nun wirklich billigstes Marketing. Während bei Google
YouTube das ja nun demnächst erst recht durchtranskribiert und gezielt ansteuerbar
und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann gibt es auch Short-Videos, die im Grunde TikTok duplizieren.
Aber hast du den Eindruck, dass bei YouTube die Suchfunktion gut funktioniert?
Ich nämlich nicht. Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, dass ich gesucht habe nach dieser Konferenz,
der Investorenkonferenz in Indien und ich gebe das ein und mir werden aber zugleich
auch noch Videos von Jürgen Drews angezeigt und man denkt, das kann jetzt gar nicht sein.
Das habe ich, weil ich kein TikTok-User bin, jetzt nicht genutzt.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass ich sehr häufig was bei YouTube suche und es nicht
angezeigt bekomme oder an zehnter Stelle dann erst angezeigt bekomme, wo es wirklich geht.
Und ich sehe gerade, dass durch diese Shorts eine solche, ja,
Zugleisterung stattgefunden hat mit Content,
dass diese Shorts mir eigentlich den Weg zu längeren Sachen verwehren,
beziehungsweise muss ich dann immer schon rausklicken, bitte keine Videos unter
vier Minuten anzeigen, um überhaupt zu diesen eigentlichen Inhalten zu gelangen.
Also ich finde, dass das nicht sehr übersichtlich ist und ich merke auch mitunter
bei YouTube, dass es Schwächen hat, dass ich Dinge google und mir,
weil dann so ein SEO-Optimierungskram stattfindet bei den großen Medienhäusern,
dass mir dann Fokusartikel aus dem Jahr 2003 angezeigt werden,
wo ich aber eigentlich gerne was hätte zu Investitionen aus dem Jahr 2023. Genau.
Also das sind eben so ganz einzelne Probleme jeweils.
Also die Google-Suche wird geflutet mit künstlicher Intelligenz erzeugten, generierten Zeug.
Videos suchen funktioniert noch nicht besonders gut. Das heißt aber noch nicht,
dass das bei TikTok irgendwie besser ist.
Und das TikTok-User-Verhalten ist ja auch bislang weiterhin dieses Gescrolle.
Man sieht da zwar unglaublich viel, aber dieses spezifische,
ich will jetzt wissen, wie dieses und jenes Rezept irgendeinen Auflauf oder
so und dass man dann über TikTok, das müsste man nochmal wirklich sich genau anschauen.
Ob diese Idee stimmt.
Stimmt.
Also genau bei diesen Dingen. Also ich glaube, man geht jetzt nicht zu TikTok,
um was über Bismarck zu erfahren.
Also dann wird man vielleicht auch irgendein Video angezeigt bekommen,
aber dann ist man doch bei Google leichter dran.
Nur das wird wahrscheinlich zehn Dokumentationen über Bismarck bei YouTube geben.
Bei TikTok stelle ich mir das nicht so leicht vor.
Hier bekommen wir mal vom Wall Street Journal erklärt, was da gesucht wird.
People, so people between the ages of like 18 and 24, are using TikTok as a
source of information for all kinds of things.
Some examples like fitness, ideas, fashion inspiration, things to do, places to go,
travel, food recommendations, recipes, all kinds of things that you can find
on an app that gives you a lot more visual results than like a typical Google
search, as well as something that's like super quick and fast.
Was wir merken ist also, es geht Es geht sehr um Alltägliches,
das gesucht wird und etwas, was schon mit Konsum auch zu tun hat.
Und da sehen wir eine weitere Entwicklung. Wir nähern uns dem mal langsam.
Und der Take war, TikTok ist nicht eine Suchen-Engine, lass mich es beweisen.
Und er hat gesucht und geschrieben, Timber in Manchester.
And if you think of search as a buying habit, it's actually less useful.
It's searching the way that, in my view, in the way that Pinterest is searched,
when you're in a buyer's mindset.
I am going on holiday to Mykonos.
I want to find out about Mykonos trips. I want reviews on a specific product,
but I know what product I'm looking for.
Maybe you will get there. But there is still a disconnect when we use very broad statements.
Ich nutze so wenig TikTok, ich kann mir das immer noch nicht richtig vorstellen.
Wenn ich zu YouTube gehe, klar, da ist ein Algorithmus, aber ich kriege doch
trotzdem Kachel verschiedener Videos.
Aber die bekommst du ja auch bei TikTok. Also du kannst ja oben,
wenn du es jetzt zum Beispiel auf dem Browser nutzt, kannst du ja oben Dinge
eingeben und dann wird dir da etwas dazu angezeigt.
Du hast Hashtags, wozu dir dann die entsprechenden Videos angezeigt werden.
Gibt es da nie im Browser aufgerufen? Das heißt, bei der App,
gut, ich nutze das jetzt nicht als App, aber da kannst du ja auch Dinge suchen,
und kannst dort auch deine Örtlichkeit mit eingeben.
Also du kannst auch wohl jetzt, also hier geht es ja schon so um Restaurant-Tests
oder dass du ein Rezept suchst und du bekommst einfach in 30 Sekunden das gezeigt
und so sieht der Kuchen dann aus und der schmeckt auch noch lecker.
Also dass das funktioniert, das leuchtet mir erstmal ein und dann ist es ja
so, dass seit dem vergangenen Jahr TikTok versucht immer mehr als Shop sich aufzubauen.
Shopping on social media is expected to become a $100 billion market in the US by 2025.
TikTok is trying to capitalize on this by creating TikTok Shop.
Last month, the company launched the shop feature for users in the US.
Can you just tell me, what is TikTok Shop? Explain what it is and how it works.
Yeah, so TikTok Shop, if you open your TikTok app,
Ja,
genau.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Und noch ein Wort zu dem Thema Suchmaschine. Mia Sato hat für The Verge geschrieben,
die Wikipedia-Funktion erscheint bei TikTok, wenn Nutzer durch die In-App-Suchergebnisse
nach unten scrollen und ist inzwischen in relevante Videos eingebettet.
Wenn der Nutzer auf das Snippet klickt, gelangt er direkt zu Wikipedia.
Links am unteren Rand des Snippets führen zu verschiedenen Abschnitten des Wikipedia-Eintrags.
Und Google hat eingeräumt, dass TikTok und andere Plattformen seine Dominanz
bei der Suche beeinträchtigen könnten.
Letztes Jahr sagte Ruck Havan,
der für die Suche zuständig ist bei Google, dass etwa 40 Prozent der jungen Leute,
wenn sie nach einem Ort zum Mittagessen suchen, nicht zu Google Maps oder der
Suchleiste gehen, sondern dies über TikTok oder Instagram tun.
Also Instagram ist da auch sehr entscheidend.
Und dann heißt es hier noch aus einem Erfahrungsbericht der New York Times,
dass, wie heißt es, als Jacoby Moore beschloss, sich in diesem Jahr an einer
privaten Highschool in ihrer Heimatstadt New Orleans zu bewerben,
erfuhr sie, dass sie mindestens ein Empfehlungsschreiben von einem Lehrer benötigte.
Da sie noch nie um ein solches gebeten hatte, bat sie um Hilfe.
Lehrerempfehlungsschreiben tippte sie in die Suchleiste von TikTok.
Die 15-jährige Moore scrollte durch die TikTok-App, bis sie zwei Videos fand.
Eines, das erklärte, wie man Lehrer um ein Empfehlungsschreiben bittet.
Und das andere, das eine Vorlage für ein solches zeigte.
Beide wurden von Lehrern erstellt und waren leichter zu verstehen als ein Google-Suchergebnis
oder ein YouTube-Video, sagte Moore.
Also das scheint wohl immer mehr sich durchzusetzen.
Das ist ja auch bei den wissenschaftlichen Publikationen, gerade in der Naturwissenschaft,
wenn dann irgendwelche Unis lieber eine Viertelstunde YouTube-Video drehen,
als ein Paper zu schreiben oder das Paper nur noch so mit abfällt,
aber eigentlich geht es denen um die Publikation per YouTube.
Kommen wir nochmal zu diesem Shopping zurück. Hier hören wir noch vom Wall Street Journal folgendes.
Wie es der Markt jetzt ist, arbeiten sie an, Warehäuser zu erstellen,
um die Sachen zu schiffen.
Aber gerade jetzt schiffen die Verkäufer ihre eigenen Produkte und behalten ihre eigenen Produkte.
Und um mit Amazon zu kämpfen, sagen die Verkäufer, dass sie in drei Tagen einen
Beweis schiffen müssen.
Welche Unternehmen verkaufen auf TikTok? Ich denke, es gibt viele kleine Unternehmen,
die Kraftwerke oder Homemade-Geschenke machen.
Und etwas, was ich in den letzten Monaten gesehen habe, sind diese Fall-Themed-Schirmshirts.
Und es wäre ein Shirt mit Snoopy und ein paar Fall-Lebens. Oder es wäre ein,
das ist nicht Fall-Themed, aber es ist ein Shirt, das Pickledrohs auf dem Shirt hat.
Das ist ja das chinesische Erfolgsmodell eigentlich.
Jack Ma's Laden, Alibaba, hat ja auch keine eigene Infrastruktur,
sondern das ist halt nur die Vermittlungszentrale.
Und danach Shopify und der ganze Kram muss halt selber gemacht werden.
Man überlegt dann auch, ob man vielleicht bei TikTok auch mit Logistikzentren
arbeitet, aber andererseits, warum soll man sich den Klotz ans Bein binden?
Und gerade Jack Ma, wo du das jetzt ansprichst, die sagte ja,
so kleine Produkte, handgemachtes, bei Jack Ma war das ja damals zu hören,
das sehr wichtig war für Alibaba, als die,
Alte Corona-Krise, also aus den Nullerjahren da war, dann mussten die Leute
auch versuchen ihr regionales Zeug zu verkaufen und das war der Peak,
wo das erstmal so klar wurde, Online-Shopping ist das Ding.
Und dann haben die plötzlich damit angefangen und das hat dann dafür gesorgt,
dass das Vertrauen dafür entstand und dass also die regionalen oder handwerklich
hergestellten Dinge auch verkauft werden konnten.
Und das hat sich ja dann bei der vergangenen Corona-Krise wiederholt,
also dass da wieder ganz stark auch wieder das Regionale adressiert wurde oder
das Handgemachte und von daher kann man sich das gut vorstellen und auch dieses Versprechen,
du kannst dir so ein kleines Business hier aufbauen. Genau.
Und das ist ja unter allen, wir haben ja auch die Bücher dazu gelesen,
Monopolisierungsdiskussionen, die es gibt, ist ja diese Entkopplung von Suchmaschine hier,
Lager da und so, dass das unterschiedliche Leute sind, die dann auch in einem
anderen Wettbewerb miteinander stehen, als immer nur gegen Amazon en bloc sozusagen
konkurrieren zu müssen. Ist gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ja, ich meine TikTok hat jetzt auch Konkurrenz mit den Reels bei Instagram.
Also da hat Zuckerberg angegeben, dass sie mit den Reels im vergangenen Jahresumsatz,
2022 Jahresumsatz, nee 23 haben sie einen Jahresumsatz mit diesen Reels von
10 Milliarden Dollar erzielt.
Das ist schon nicht schlecht. Vielleicht, wenn wir jetzt über Amazon nachdenken,
also das ist ja da, wo die meisten Leute von uns bestellen werden.
Du bist ja wahrscheinlich auch Heavy-User.
Ich will es immer wieder sagen, weil es immer wieder zu Kontroversen führt,
ich bin ein ganz großer Amazon-Fan, weil ich diese Infrastruktur mittlerweile
wirklich für eine ganz wesentliche Einrichtung und damit meine ich einen Begriff
aus dem deutschen Kartellrecht meine,
sie kann nicht einfach durch eine zweite Infrastruktur Konkurrenz oder so erfahren,
sondern das ist selber eine Infrastruktur, die jetzt als Monopol richtig gut funktioniert. Ja.
Also ich habe glaube ich mein Amazon-Konto eröffnet, da war ich 14,
also es war etwa sieben Jahre her und da kann ich auch sagen,
dass bei allen Bestellungen, die ich gemacht habe, ich glaube es gab ein einziges
Mal eine falsche Versendung,
einmal wurde ein falsches Buch geschickt, das war aber dann innerhalb von fünf
Minuten geklärt an einem Telefon. Und ich will nur sagen.
Also da muss politisch eingegriffen werden, wenn man damit unzufrieden ist und
nicht durch, ah ja, da braucht man Konkurrenten oder so.
Sondern das kann man auch so als Monopolist politisch einhegen.
Wirst du ja auch nicht wieder aussehen. Aber, weil du ja so ein Heavy-User bist,
muss ich dich fragen, denn ich kannte es nicht. Kennst du Amazon Inspire?
No.
Und zwar macht ja TikTok jetzt hier seine eigene, macht jetzt TikTok Shop und
hat das im Oktober 23 in den USA eingeführt und Amazon beobachtet natürlich sehr genau,
was passiert da alles so auf TikTok und da gibt es Amazon Inspire und damit
lassen sich dann auch Videos ansehen, in denen Produkte beworben werden und
Amazon will auch so eine Social Media Plattform sein.
Wir hören hier mal beim Wall Street Journal was dazu.
Right now, TikTok's shop only gets about $7 million a day in the U.S.
Small beans by comparison.
But TikTok has something that Amazon doesn't. People's attention.
The average user spends about two hours a day on TikTok, compared to less than 10 minutes on Amazon.
What does Amazon think of what TikTok is doing?
It's funny, neither of the companies will comment on each other publicly,
Aber das heißt, Amazon hat letztes Jahr in ihrer App einen Tab geöffnet, der InSpire nennt.
Das ist eine Art TikTok-Feed, in der man scrollen kann und Videos und Fotos
von Inhalt sehen kann, die man kaufen möchte.
Erstaunlich, dass die jetzt auch versuchen, sich dem anzugleichen.
Eigentlich werden ja auch alle, können wir so erleben, alle wollen Shop sein,
aber alle wollen auch eine Social-Media-Plattform sein.
Spotify ist ja auch eine Social-Media-Plattform inzwischen, wenn man so möchte. Ja.
Also wir haben auf jeden Fall bei der Podcast-Abteilung gibt es jetzt auch Hörerkommentare,
Rankings, der ganze Kram.
Auch für die Musiker ist das schon sehr, sehr wichtig. Genau.
Man kann den Künstlern folgen, kriegt Hinweise über Touren.
Wir springen ein bisschen und zwar zum New York Times Magazine.
Das hatte nämlich einen sehr interessanten Artikel.
Und zwar ging es darum, dass da jemand einen Kugelschreiber verkauft hat über TikTok.
Es gab einen längeren Artikel, den kann man lesen beim New York Times Magazine.
Aber dieser Autor war dann auch eingeladen, im Podcast darüber zu sprechen.
Das habe ich gehört bei den beiden.
Von New York Magazine und ein guter Observer von Dingen, die unter der Technologie-Ökonomie
auftauchen, hat viel über E-Commerce geschrieben und spezifisch über Shopping auf TikTok.
Und er hat letztens etwas, was ich als ein brillantes Experiment war,
wo er ein TikTok-Seller wurde und versucht hat, seinen mechanischen Pencil auf TikTok zu verkaufen.
Und ich möchte mit ihm darüber sprechen, weil ich denke, es ist nicht nur ein
sehr lustiger Stunt, sondern es ist auch ein bisschen ein Blick unter den Hügel
eines der größten Plattformen und wie es versucht, sich zu verändern,
um, ich würde sagen, mehr kommerziell zu werden.
How do you sell a pencil on TikTok? Right. So you look at the TikTok store and
you see something that looks like an e-commerce storefront, a place with listings,
with sellers. It looks kind of professional, right?
On the back end, it's a little bit more like signing up to sell something on
like eBay or Poshmark. It's kind of primitive.
I logged in with my regular TikTok account.
I declared my intention to become a seller. They asked me a few questions.
I had to verify my identity.
Zunächst mal nicht viel anders als bei eBay, aber dann entscheidend ist dann,
wie TikTok da mit den Verkäufern umgeht, beziehungsweise was der Verkäufer tun muss oder kann.
Vintage, you know, I didn't want to lie about it. I mean, vintage makes it sound
much cooler than it is. Well, yeah, I'm selling something.
And TikTok offered to generate my listing for me.
Das fand ich auch interessant, dass die da nochmal das optimieren können.
Erstaunlich, oder?
Ja, ich finde es auch unter diesen, also ich habe immer noch so einen Professor
aus Bielefeld fällt im Ohr, der damals meinte, mit Ebay wurde es möglich,
aus jedem Regal, egal wo es steht, ein Verkaufsregal zu machen.
Also man sitzt zu Hause im Wohnzimmer und plötzlich ist das eine Markthalle.
Und dann hatten wir aber nur Ebay. Und Ebay hat ja sehr streng geregelt und
es war auch sehr teuer. Und ich bin jetzt nochmal die Möglichkeiten durchgegangen,
bei Shopify.
Ja.
Klickt man sich ja seinen eigenen Shop, so wie man sich bei WordPress einfach
seinen Blog klickt. Und bei Shopify ist der Blog schon richtig groß drin.
Also man hat das Regal, wo man die Sachen und dann, das sieht ja aus wie eine
Amazon-Seite, also man kann verschiedene Größen, verschiedene Farben,
man klickt alles und so weiter, wie man es so kennt.
Und daneben dieses, und jetzt erzähl die Geschichte dazu.
Das.
Blog. Und wenn man sich so YouTube-Videos anguckt, wie Shopify-Shops eingerichtet
werden, ist man ja wirklich kurz davor zu sagen, ich nutze das einfach als Blogging-Plattform,
weil dann habe ich gleich einen Shop dran, auch für digitale Güter.
Also ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel die Rechte an den Audio-Versionen meiner Bücher,
die kann ich einfach einsprechen und wenn ich dann das nächste Buch schreibe,
begleite ich das eben auf einem Shopify-Blog mit lauter Aktualisierten und daneben
steht einfach so wie bei Korre Doktorow einfach die Bildergalerie seiner Bücher,
kann man bei mir einfach draufklicken und sagen, Audio-Datei runterladen.
Aber wer spricht das bei dir ein?
Naja, ich müsste halt produziert werden. Irgendwer spricht es ein,
ich, die AI oder was auch immer, aber es ist ja ein Gut, das Käufer fände, wenn man es anböte.
Und in dieser Maximilien finde ich dieses, er sitzt am Schreibtisch,
sieht einen Stift und es ist so einfach, den Pfeil zu bieten,
dass er es einfach macht.
Finde ich, das ist keine schlechte Entwicklung. Es fehlt noch so ein bisschen
das Zahlungssystem, aber darum kümmert sich ja dann in dem Falle wieder der
Monopolist, was ich nicht so gut finde.
Aber diese Idee, alles auch zur Ware machen zu können, finde ich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, ich würde sagen, wenn Leute sich von irgendwas trennen oder so,
da sehe ich jetzt auch erstmal nicht das Problem.
Also ich kann immer nie diese Differenz sehen, dass man stationären Handel immer
als schützenswertes Gut wie Seehundbabys oder so ansieht, während man alles,
was im Internet verkauft wird, immer als das Teufelszeug markiert. Das verstehe ich nicht.
Nur, Stefan, muss ich dir jetzt sagen, ja, mit Shopify ist das so,
da könntest du das als Blog machen.
Aber wenn du jetzt erfolgreich bei TikTok sein willst, musst du was anders machen.
Da wollen wir dich als Home Shopping Europe Moderator sehen.
Dann musst du nämlich folgendes machen, das erklärt hier John Herman.
I pressed the button and within seconds I had more viewers than I had followers.
I've got basically no followers. This is an account that I use for work, for testing things out.
Never posted before, but I had hundreds of viewers.
The most I saw concurrently was 360 something.
Over the 10 or so minutes that I streamed, TikTok's analytics told me that I
had more than 1,200 viewers.
And I can't,
Ja.
Es ist ganz erstaunlich, also TikTok ist sehr daran interessiert,
dass diese Shopping-Funktion in die Welt getragen wird, deswegen werden Leute,
die live gehen und was verkaufen, besonders gepusht und hier ist jemand, der hat einen Account,
wo nie was drauf passiert, er hat so gut wie keine Follower,
aber sobald er da live geht, irgendeinen Stift verkauft, sind 360 Leute da.
Also 360 Leute bei einem Livestream sind richtig viel.
Also wir wissen, wenn jetzt Thilo einen Livestream macht mit Jung und Naiv,
dann ist das bei guten Gästen so 2000, 2500.
Also da kann man jetzt hier mal sehen, hier sind 360 Leute, weil da irgendein
Nobody einen Stift verkaufen will.
Da muss man aber auch sagen, es ist vielleicht gerade die Goldgräber-Zeit,
denn die wollen ja die Funktionen pushen.
Also jeder, der da gerade live geht mit, ich verkaufe was, ich gewöhne eure
Zuschauer, also die Nutzer der App daran, dass man hier was kaufen kann,
wird ja gerade wahrscheinlich mit Handkuss genommen.
Also probieren sie einfach mal das Buch in die Kamera halten und sagen, hier, Altenrepublik.
Wahnsinnsbuch.
Müsst ihr lesen. Ja, und der Versand ist dann auch ganz interessant.
Ich habe 69 Cent davon bekommen, der noch nicht in meine Bankkarte gepostet wurde.
TikTok hat für die Schaffung, die etwas mehr als 4 Dollar war,
als Teil ihrer Promotion-Schemme, um TikTok-Shops zu promotieren.
Warte, also auf einem Item, das einen Dollar kostet, von dem du 69 Cent gemacht
hast, hat TikTok die ganze Kosten für die Schaffung des Pencils subsidiert?
That's right. It was listed as having free shipping.
I had no say over that, but all potential customers saw that this was $1 free shipping.
And TikTok then lost at least four times the value of the product on the sale.
Yeah, and to be honest, the product was probably worth about 15 cents.
Wir haben das Buch gelesen über Amazon,
wo klar war, innerhalb eines Monats hat Amazon 400 Millionen Dollar Miese gemacht,
nur um den Windelmarkt zu übernehmen, den Diaper-Market.
Und wenn das hier wieder so, dann ist es wirklich gerade, also jetzt kriegt
man gerade sein Zeug los, ohne Transportkosten und so weiter.
TikTok kümmert sich drum, die Hauptsache.
Aber die konsolidieren jetzt den Markt.
Das sollte man jetzt nutzen, glaube ich, wenn man irgendein cooles Produkt hat.
Echt erstaunlich.
Man bräuchte natürlich dann mehr als einen Stift.
Ja, du kannst wirklich ganz kleine, billige Produkte verkaufen,
weil die Sache ist ja dann, solange die das so machen, also irgendwann werden
die das ja, das ist ja total ruinös.
Aber ich sag mal, es gibt ja viele Produkte, die zwei, drei Euro kosten,
die man im Internet nicht bestellt, weil man sagt, ja, Versandkosten und so
weiter. Und damit geht es da.
Wir hören nochmal, wie das so in China schon läuft.
Great to be in commerce, if you could become a dominant commerce platform,
if you could take some market share from Amazon or Shein or compete with Teemu,
whatever. This is all great.
You sort of diversify your product away from the fleeting whims of social media audiences.
You also sort of solve a problem that TikTok's had for a long time,
which is that it's creators don't have a ton of ways to monetize by giving people
the chance to sell stuff,
not their own stuff, but to like Wenn man den Affiliate-Link in der Mitte eines
Broadcasts verbindet, ist es potenziell eine Art, viel Geld zu verdienen.
Das bedeutet natürlich für die Influencer einen unglaublich großen Markt,
die jetzt alle live gehen. Also das passiert ja bei TikTok, die gehen live.
Zum einen bitten sie um Spenden oder diese ganzen Donations,
die kommen, wenn da irgendein Smiley dann auftaucht oder die führen dann irgendwas vor der Kamera vor.
Aber es ist auch, dass sie jetzt also über diesen Home Shopping Europe Weg oder
QVC Weg, dass sie da jetzt unglaublich gut verkaufen können und das wahnsinnig
gepusht wird. Hier nochmal so ein kurzes Fazit.
Could be a person with great skin care or, you know, it's like,
you want cheap crap, we know it and we're gonna just feed it to you endlessly.
Also, Instagram hat ja lange darunter gelitten, dass die Influencer so Side-Business-mäßig,
also die nicht wirklich daran beteiligt werden.
Und dieser Markt für eine Influencer hat gesagt, also glaube ich ihm,
scheint ja immer noch nicht ausgeschöpft zu sein.
Und in der Hinsicht ist diese Verknüpfung hier, entweder es ist ein großer ökonomischer
Flop, weil das wirklich unglaublich viel Geld kostet für TikTok erstmal,
oder es ist wirklich der Start einer ganz neuen Facette von TikTok,
die irgendwann ganz TikTok übernimmt, weil sie dominant wird.
Dass man zu TikTok geht, um dort die elementaren Influencer angepriesenen Sachen
zu kaufen. Wir kennen das ja von...
Infowars, wie heißt der? Der jetzt wieder zurück ist auf Twitter.
Ihr wisst, wovon ich rede. Alex Jones.
Alex Jones verkauft ja quasi nur diese Prepper-Creme irgendwie, was auch immer.
Also hier Vitamine lassen dich länger leben und der ganze Kram.
Und Alex Jones ist nun wirklich der und ich glaube, das fühlen auch die Leute,
die ihm zuschauen, der schlechteste Leumund.
Extremes Übergewicht. Sehr irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nicht der Typ,
aber wenn der sagt, hier nimm diese Vitamine und dir geht es besser,
kaufen die Leute das in Millionen und Millionenfach.
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und das Prinzip weiter auszubeuten,
hoffähig zu machen für alle, ist natürlich, mal sehen, wohin das führt,
was dann da so verkauft wird.
Ja, das ist schon die perfekte Überleitung, denn wir haben noch Trump im Ohr,
der TikTok verbannen will, aber es gibt auch,
Republikaner, die das anders sehen und auch Auch damit hat sich das Wall Street
Journal mal beschäftigt.
Es gibt da so einen Sponsor der Republikaner und diese Leute da,
die finden TikTok gar nicht so schlecht.
Slowly there was this trickle of Republicans who started making noise about
how we shouldn't ban TikTok.
And those Republicans had something in common. They're sort of libertarian leaning.
Our colleague Stu Wu started looking into what was going on.
Und ich dachte, oh, das ist eine tolle Geschichte, wie Libertarier diese kleine
Power-Base in Washington entwickelt haben.
Und je mehr ich mich in das Ganze befasst, desto mehr erinnern wir uns,
oh, es gibt etwas anderes, das sie verbindet, das ist die Finanzierung von diesem Mann, Jeff Yaz.
Jeff Yaz. Und.
Back in 2012, before TikTok was even created, ByteDance got money from a US
investment firm, founded by a man named Jeff Yaz.
Who is Jeff Yaz?
Have you ever met him? I have not. He's super secretive. He's given very few interviews.
What is his interest in TikTok?
Und so langsam ergibt dann alles Sinn.
Jeff Yes ist ein Amerikaner, der 15% von TikTok gehört.
Stu dug in and found out that one of Rand Paul's largest donors is Jeff Yaz, the investor in TikTok.
He and his wife have given Senator Rand Paul 24 million dollars over the past
decade, either directly to him as a candidate or to committees that support Rand Paul.
Yaz's donations go beyond just Paul.
He and his wife were the fourth biggest political donors in the last election cycle,
giving almost 50 million dollars to
republicans and republican affiliated groups and many
of those lawmakers who yes has supported have recently
come to tick tocks defense when you look at the republicans who have come out
publicly and said we don't want to ban tick tock via this bill something that
binds them together is that they all receive political backing from jeff yaz
either Entweder direkt von politischen Donationen von Yaz und seiner Frau oder
durch dieses politische Komitee,
das Club for Growth, das er ein großer Unterstützer ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das muss schon die Mother sein. Also keine Ahnung, aber es ist wirklich crazy.
Also jedenfalls viel Geld unterwegs. Und vielleicht ergibt ja alles auch deshalb
Sinn, weil jetzt so ein Republikaner oder den Republikaner nahestehender wie Jeff Yaz kennt,
dass man ja TikTok wahnsinnig gut politisch nutzen kann.
Und das war ja so erstaunlich, dass Trump so gegen TikTok wetterte.
Er ist ja derjenige, der noch Fernsehen guckt und dann was er im Fernsehen sieht
für die Wirklichkeit hält und dann auch was twittert, so kennen wir ihn.
Und man kann aber doch eigentlich feststellen, dass TikTok für rechte Inhalte doch ideal ist.
Und mir schickte es dann jemand und ich erinnerte mich dann selbst an,
dass ich den Vortrag ja mal schon vor ein paar Monaten gehört hatte.
Mir schickt es ein Hörer nochmal.
Die AfD beschäftigt sich ja auch mit TikTok. Wir hatten schon mal Clips von
Maximilian Krah gespielt.
Und deswegen springen wir jetzt mal zu Erik Ahrens,
der aus der Identitären Bewegung stammt, den TikTok-Account unter anderem von
Maximilian Krah betreut,
der bei dieser Sommerakademie zu Gast war von Schnellroder und der vor einigen
Monaten auch deshalb für Furore sorgte, weil er sagte, ja, ich bin für eine Wehrpflicht.
Aber ich finde es auch gut, wenn man Frauen dazu zwingt, dass sie dann ihre
Eizellen abgeben müssen.
Also ja, das sind wirklich ganz krude Ideen, die da lauern.
Und er war bei der Sommerakademie, also in Schnellrohr dabei,
Götz Kubitschek, um über TikTok zu sprechen.
Und das hören wir uns jetzt mal an, was er da ausführt. TikTok.
Und die Kurzvideos allgemein, aber besonders eben diese Plattform TikTok,
funktionieren genau gegenteilig. Man kann mit niedrigem Aufwand und extrem geringen
technischen Mitteln sofort einsteigen.
Also er macht hier erstmal deutlich, wenn man jetzt bei YouTube eine Karriere
sich aufbauen will, braucht das lange Zeit, denn man muss einen Abonnentenstamm
haben, um dann auch sichtbar zu sein. Das geht nicht mit einem Video.
Es braucht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Produktionsaufwand. Im Gegenteil,
wenn man sich anguckt, was gut funktioniert und was nicht so gut funktioniert,
sind die Videos, die mit viel Aufwand produziert wurden, häufig eher nicht so erfolgreich,
weil eben da vielmehr das Prinzip ist, man muss viele, viele Inhalte veröffentlichen
und rein die Wahrscheinlichkeit gebietet es schon, dass einige dieser Inhalte dann viral gehen.
Das heißt, wer am meisten regelmäßig auf TikTok veröffentlichen kann und ein
paar Grundprinzipien richtig befolgt und am besten auch meistert,
Es sind also wenige Prinzipien, aber man muss sie auch meistern.
Der kann eben dort sehr schnell sehr große Reichweite erreichen.
Um das nochmal ganz klar zu sagen, das ist jetzt hier ein freizugänglicher Podcast
und auch ein YouTube-Video gibt es dazu.
Man muss also jetzt nicht in fünf Monaten einen Investigativ-Artikel veröffentlichen.
Die AfD hat auch einen TikTok-Plan. Ja, ja, genau, aber der ist ganz transparent einsehbar. Ja.
Und wir hören mal weiter, also die Follower, wie ist es denn damit bei TikTok?
Und dabei sind nicht entscheidend die Follower, die man nun auf dem Account hat.
Ich werde drei Accounts zeigen, die ich betreibe, die alle Reichweiten haben
von Videos, die in die hunderttausende, teilweise in die Millionen Views gehen,
aber die alle nur wenige tausend, zehntausend Follower haben,
weil bei TikTok eben gar nicht entscheidend ist, wem ich folge oder wem ich
nicht folge, sondern wessen Videos ich tatsächlich angucke.
Und da kommt er mit dem ersten Beispiel. spielen.
Hier rechts sehen wir jetzt, das kann ich schon mal vorwegnehmen,
den TikTok-Account von der Bürgerbewegung Die Österreicher, DO5,
wo ich eine Zeit lang während ihrer Migrationsstour die Videos gemacht habe.
Da haben wir leider nur wenige Videos aufgenommen in dieser Zeit.
Das waren jetzt diese acht.
Und man sieht eben, dass ich unten rechts mit dem ersten Video,
was wir da veröffentlicht haben, eben über 500.000 Views hatten und wir danach
auch recht stabile Aufrufzahlen hatten.
Die machen da ein, zwei Videos und haben 500.000 Views.
Also, bei YouTube ist es ja so, dass die Videos lang sind. Ich weiß,
TikTok macht jetzt auch lange Videos.
Ja, sie testen jetzt sogar bis zu 30 Minuten.
Ja, so. Das Ding ist, 500.000 Views, ich finde, da muss man nochmal so einen
Faktor reinrechnen. bei YouTube.
Man setzt sich dahin, man konsumiert das man spielt irgendwas an man entscheidet
sich, ach ich gehe doch mal zum nächsten Video und so weiter und so fort,
nur grob über den Daumen, wenn ich YouTube benutze, komme ich in der Stunde
vielleicht auf 30 40 Videos wenn ich mir jetzt überlege, die,
Standardbenutzung eines TikTok Users, eine Stunde lang das sind hunderte Videos Videos.
Wenn die drei Stunden nach der Schule oder zu Feierabend oder wie auch immer
TikTok benutzen, bei TikTok beginnt der View-Counter nach 0,3 Sekunden.
Also die Zählung geht so schnell nach oben und ich finde es immer wieder amüsant,
wenn irgendwelche Menschen, die Marketing machen wollen für ganz legitime Produkte
wie Bücher oder was auch immer,
dann heißt es ja, wir buchen eine Agentur und die macht acht Kacheln und dann
werden acht Kacheln produziert und ausgespielt.
Ich denke mir dann, ja, aber wisst ihr, wie die benutzt werden,
die acht Kacheln? Die werden sich eine halbe Sekunde lang angeguckt,
wenn sie überhaupt gesehen werden.
Also wenn die Augen gerade auf dem Bildschirm sind, während man da so durchscrollt
oder wie auch immer. Diese TikTok-Videos rauschen so durch.
Klar, die Masse macht es am Ende. Und wenn wir jetzt so ein TikTok-Netzwerk,
Influencer, irgendwas, so eine Milieu-Gemengelager haben mit rechten Videos,
wo dann dieses TikTok baut ja immer so acht Videos am Block zusammen und spielt
die dann aus und dann wird immer umgesteuert und so.
Und dann kriegt man nur noch solche Videos. Okay. Okay.
Aber das geht ja ganz schnell. Ich hatte gerade mit einem Bekannten drüber gesprochen,
der ist bei TikTok eigentlich nur um Mode und Autos zu sehen und er hat dann
aber aus irgendeinem Grund irgendein Bauernprotest-Video angeklickt. Ja.
Und dann war alles zu Ende. Also danach nur noch Alice Weidel spricht,
Krah spricht, irgendwelche russischen Trolls, die sagen, kommt nach Russland,
hier ist noch das echte Leben, hier findet man noch eine Bäuerin, die zu einem steht.
Also wirklich die krudesten Sachen und bekommt man nur noch das angezeigt.
Also ich habe da von dem Freund wirklich nochmal so ganz klar Berichte bekommen,
ja ich nutze das nie für irgendwelche politischen Inhalte, sondern mache da
nur Lifestyle-Kram in Autos und Mode.
Und dann einmal hat es dann TikTok mal versucht,
ach ja, wahrscheinlich weil es irgendwie so einen Konnex gab,
jemand der sich irgendwie einen Sportwagen von BMW ansieht und noch teure Lederschuhe,
vielleicht ist er auch noch rechts, gucken wir mal, gehen wir mal so mit rein.
Also Scott Galloway ist der Meinung, dass sich die Chinesen da einmischen und
die amerikanische TikTok-Bevölkerung bewusst ideologisch zersetzen wollen.
In der Hinsicht würde ich solche Erfolge wie, ja ja, wenn es im chinesischen
Interesse ist, uns AfD-Material reinzuspielen, dann haben diese Videos 500.000 Views.
Und man kann natürlich auch sagen, also wenn, sollte, dann wäre ja so ein Bias im Algorithmus.
Wenn man mal nicht davon ausgeht, sondern nur sagt, ja der Algorithmus testet
halt was Funktioniertes funktionieren, dann finde ich es aber erstaunlich,
also weil es nicht mehr auf diese Follower ankommt, dass man es schafft mit
einer Werbung oder einer Berichterstattung von einer Veranstaltung,
mag sein, dass diese Videos dann ein bisschen catchy sind, aber dass man es schafft 500.000 Leute,
auch wenn es dann nicht Leute sind, die komplett durchgesehen hat,
Aber dass überhaupt solche Zahlen generiert werden, ist ganz erstaunlich.
Er macht dann ein weiteres Beispiel für irgendeine andere rechte Veranstaltung. Das.
Ist ein anderes Beispiel jetzt hier. Das Beispiel des Kanals von der Gegenuni.
Da hatten wir einfach mal testweise probiert. Ja, es funktioniert bei einer
aktivistischen Bewegung, die Österreicher.
Kann man denn auch jetzt so ein Projekt über TikTok bewerben?
Und dann habe ich einfach mal in Auftrag gegeben.
Und wir haben einfach mal geguckt, können wir hier einfach mit ganz einfachen
Mitteln Gegenunikurse bewerben?
Hier in dem Fall Geschichte der Kreuzzüge oder das Nibelungenlied.
Also hier oben links, wo Kultur steht, das habe ich gemacht zum Nibelungenlied.
Und es hat super funktioniert.
Also mit den richtigen Zusammenschnitten einfach aus ein paar Bildern,
ein bisschen Text und der Musik, kann man eben auch jetzt ein rechtes Projekt,
was die Reichweite angeht, extrem stark boosten. Und zwar von heute auf morgen.
Ja, 50.000, 100.000, 200.000 Aufrufe haben die da. Und er erklärt ganz gut dieses
Prinzip und er erwähnt dabei jemanden.
Wenn es aber eine Person ist mit einem Gesicht und einem Namen,
die noch niemand kennt und die es schafft, sich eben über TikTok eine gewisse
Reichweite, eine gewisse Bekanntheit aufzubauen und dann dieser Kanal gesperrt
wird aus irgendeinem Grund.
Dann kann diese Person sich einfach einen neuen Account machen und kann,
weil sie ja schon bekannt ist in der Zielgruppe, innerhalb von kürzester Zeit
dieselbe Reichweite erneut erzeugen.
Und das ist eben der Grund, warum jeder den Namen Andrew Tate kennt.
Das hat er nämlich die letzten zweieinhalb Jahre so gemacht.
Während er von jeder Plattform gesperrt war, haben er und seine Helfer einfach
die ganze Zeit mit neuen TikTok-Kanälen immer wieder neue Videos hochgeladen.
Und jedes dieser Videos auf jedem dieser neuen Kanäle ist immer wieder viral
gegangen, gegangen, weil der Name und das Gesicht und die Botschaft hier entscheidend
waren und nicht eben dieser einzelne Account.
Das heißt, dass die Plattforming kann in dem Sinne nicht stattfinden,
wenn man weiterhin zur Öffentlichkeit sprechen will.
Das TikTok aber eigen. Also wir haben bei KuchenTV gelernt, wenn du gesperrt
bist bei Twitch und du tauchst in einem anderen Stream auf bei irgendwem,
wird der auch gleich gesperrt, weil du bist ja gesperrt. Das ist bei Twitter auch.
Trump konnte sich nicht einfach einen anderen Account machen und da weiter twittern,
sondern da ist man als Person neun Grader dann und das ist krass, dass man dabei tickt.
Ja, beziehungsweise wenn Entrotate, macht das ja nicht selbst,
also irgendwelche Leute laden da jetzt irgendwas hoch.
Also es sind ja weiterhin, ich will es mal so vergleichen, bei Twitter,
es sind ja weiterhin Trump-Videos erschienen bei Twitter.
Das heißt und die wurden auch ganz, die wurden geguckt, weil man den ja schon
kannte und sagte, ach hier Trump, kenne ich ja schon, klicke ich auch nochmal
an, auch wenn er das jetzt selbst nicht nicht gepostet hat.
Und dieses Prinzip, das wir bei Twitter schon finden, ist eigentlich bei TikTok noch besser.
Und dieser Maximilian Krah war ja jemand, den man überhaupt nicht kannte,
wenn man sich nicht mit den Rechten beschäftigt.
Und er ist dann da bei TikTok und wird von dem Ahrens hier betreut.
Der geht dann auch kurz darauf ein.
Auf Maximilian Krah, also der
ja nun Listenkandidat Nummer 1 ist für die Europawahl 2024 bei der AfD.
Und wir haben jetzt in den letzten drei Monaten einige TikToks veröffentlicht
und machen das auch weiter.
Und wir haben eben genau diese Prinzipien angewandt. Wir haben eine Botschaft,
die den Zuschauer direkt anspricht innerhalb der ersten Sekunden,
so dass das Video eben angeschaut wird, dass es auch mehrfach angeschaut wird, mit Musik unterlegt.
Also wir haben so gesehen alles richtig gemacht.
Und man sieht, was für Reichweiten man dann erzeugen kann, wenn man alles richtig macht.
Also wir haben in den letzten zwei Monaten zweieinhalb Millionen unique viewers erreicht.
Das heißt zweieinhalb Millionen Menschen haben unsere Videos gesehen.
Das sind ganz erstaunliche Zahlen. Und jetzt muss man auch mal irgendwie jetzt
die Rechten darüber reden.
Also wir haben das ja auch schon immer mal so thematisiert, was das eigentlich mit Menschen macht.
Und hier wird überhaupt kein Hehl daraus gemacht, dass man Menschen manipulieren will.
Vielleicht wundert man sich, warum das jetzt so plötzlich abgeschnitten ist. Das hat einen Grund.
Also er hat jetzt ein Video gezeigt und das hört dann einfach da in dem Vortrag direkt auf. Denn.
Auf der Plattform ist es in diesem Moment so, dass das Video sofort wieder vom Neuen anfängt.
Das heißt, es entsteht faktisch ein hypnotischer Effekt, wo der Zuschauer dasselbe
Video mit derselben Musik und derselben Botschaft mehrfach hört und ihm sozusagen
suggeriert wird, auch wenn er vielleicht beim ersten Mal gar nicht auf alle
Einzelheiten geachtet hat,
dass ihm jetzt eben suggeriert wird und diese Botschaft immer und immer tiefer
in sein Bewusstsein eindringt.
Hypnose. Ich musste direkt daran denken an die Filme der 20er Jahre,
von Caligari zu Hitler, von Siegfried Krakauer, also wo man quasi sagt,
man muss die Massen, also Dr.
Mabuse ist ja auch der Hypnotiseur, also man muss die Menschen hypnotisieren
und dann sind sie zum Faschismus zu allem bereit.
Und das wird hier ganz transparent gemacht.
Hier wird gesagt, ja klar, das hat eine hypnotische Wirkung, so machen wir das.
Wobei die Nutzer wissen, die Videos beginnen immer wieder von vorne,
also scrollen sie ja schnell weiter.
Ich glaube, dass, also man sieht an den Zahlen auch, dass viele Videos mehrmals
geguckt werden und dass die Leute das immer und immer wieder haben.
Und das ist doch, wenn du auch mal bei den YouTube Shorts guckst,
es ist doch erstaunlich, also diese Videos werden ja alle, in denen irgendwie
nochmal gezeigt wird, so schlimm,
so dumm sind die Grünen und diese ganzen Videos, die es da gibt.
Die fördern ja keine neue Erkenntnis in dem Sinne zutage oder sie recyceln auch
so diese Auftritte irgendwie Versprecher von Baerbock oder Abeck sagt irgendwas,
das recyceln sie immer und immer wieder.
Also ich glaube, es geht schon den Leuten, den Anhängern darum,
wie auch den Produzenten dieser Videos, so ein hypnotisches,
ja, da sieht man es wieder.
Also man muss sich immer wieder mal so neu aufstacheln, wie man sich irgendwie
mit guter Laune Musik, gute Laune schafft, um dann am Abend auszugehen.
So kann man sich auch wieder so den Hass neu drauf schaffen.
Und wirklich auch das Vokabular, das hier verwendet wird, ist so erstaunlich.
Wir hören nochmal Ahrens.
Also wenn man sich jetzt hier von Statista einfach mal die Nutzerzahlen im Jahr
2022 anguckt, dann konsumiert über die Hälfte der 14- bis 19-Jährigen in Deutschland TikTok.
Durchschnittlich übrigens 90 Minuten am Tag. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich 90
Minuten am Tag ein Fenster in deren Gehirn, wo man da reinsenden kann, ja?
Ins Gehirn reinsenden.
Also, was würden wir sagen, wie lange wird ein TikTok-Video geguckt im Schnitt?
Alle TikTok-Videos insgesamt im Schnitt.
Man scrollt schon ziemlich schnell. Also fünf Sekunden?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Fünf Sekunden. Jetzt müssen wir ausrechnen. Fünf Sekunden, das hieße ja zwölf
Videos pro Minute, das mal 90.
90 mal 12, also wir sind bei irgendwie tausend Videos.
Also ich kann heute diese Beispiele, ich habe noch unterhaltsame Beispiele,
aber das machen wir vielleicht mal im Live-Salon.
Da gibt es, also es gibt immer mehr Formate, wo man sicher sein kann,
dass diese Videos ganz geguckt werden, weil die darauf hinauslaufen.
Also sie laufen auch auf Vorhanden hinaus. aus.
Ich glaube, was du stark meinst, ist so das, was Younes Zahro da so produziert.
Irgendjemand macht was mit Farben oder irgendeine lässt eine Drohne rumfliegen
und so diese ganzen Spektakel-Videos.
Man müsste sich nochmal genau die Rabbit Holes angucken.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was so gewischt wird. Aber hier, also die Tatsache, dass TikTok,
wie mir jemand sagte, der bei TikTok aktiv ist, nicht bei den Rechten,
dass TikTok TikTok jetzt gerade zwei bis drei,
minütige Videos gut findet und auch präferieren, dass man zehnminütige Videos
jetzt schon hochladen kann und die gerade Tests machen, ob man auch mit 30 Minuten arbeiten sollte.
Zeigt ja, dass sie offenbar eine Audience haben, die bereit ist,
länger dabei zu bleiben.
Und wenn jetzt hier gesagt wird, ja, da senden wir da ins Gehirn rein, das ist ja so Inception,
wie wir das immer mal hier thematisiert haben, also was man denen ja lassen
muss, beziehungsweise was man auch als klare Gefahr erkennen muss,
die sind nicht blöde, sondern die arbeiten sehr strategisch da.
Insofern sollte man sich das sehr genau vor Augen führen.
Auch wie man wiederum darauf reagiert. Er bringt dann das Beispiel,
dass ja da Krah dann sowas sagt, du kannst stolz auch auf deine Großeltern sein
und du kannst stolz auf deine Geschichte sein, diese ganzen Videos.
Und das wird ja dann von den Medien wieder aufgegriffen. Er zeigt dann hier
so wie ZDF oder NZZ so Artikel dann haben.
Hier wird bei TikTok von Maximilian Krah auf deutsche Vergangenheit so und so
eingegangen und die greifen das hier ganz selbstbewusst auf.
Er bringt dann so Beispiele mit und sagt folgendes.
Wir zwingen letztlich, also das ist jetzt hier ein ZDF-Ausschnitt,
der kam vor ein paar Tagen über die Umfragewerte der AfD, da zwingen wir sie
sozusagen unsere eigene Botschaft dann auch darzustellen, weil sie können es
eh nicht totschweigen und,
sie berichten dann auch darüber, also in der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung,
jetzt natürlich auch wieder negativ in diesem Frame, die AfD will den Schuldkult
abschaffen, so sieht die,
erinnerungspolitische 180-Grad-Wende aus und wir denken uns natürlich, ja, so sieht sie aus.
Also.
Das ist nicht, also Katharina Barley hat so eine Rede jetzt gehalten auf dem
Parteitag, du verziehst schon hin und her.
Also ich habe gar keine Clips mitgebracht, das hat ja keinen Zweck mehr,
aber sie steht dann da und sagt, die AfD hat sich entlarvt und dann denke ich
mir, nee, die hat sich nicht entlarvt, die macht, was sie immer macht.
Vor allem diese Parteitagsreden, die am Ende irgendwie 3000 Views auf YouTube haben oder so.
Also.
Hier muss man echt sagen, die AfD bespielt wahrscheinlich...
85% aller politischen Kommunikation, die abseits des Fernsehens stattfindet, deutschlandweit.
Weshalb ja auch dieses, was wir vorhin von Quent gelesen haben,
diese Vermutung, wir sind die schweigende Mehrheit und so weiter,
so krass unterstrichen wird.
Weshalb es so relevant ist, so viele Menschen auf der Straße zu sehen,
das sieht man ja dann auch bei TikTok, dass da einfach viele sind und so.
In der Hinsicht ist das schon ein krasser Vorsprung, den die Partei da hat. Ja.
Wir hören noch einen letzten Clip. Martin Sellner hat auch in Schnellroder bei
der Sommerakademie einen Vortrag gehalten, ging auf die neuen Medien ein.
Der Vortrag ist aber nicht so interessant.
Sellner geriert sich ja immer als so ein Wiedergänger von Heidegger und Ernst
Jünger. Das bleibt aber dann doch sehr substanzlos.
Aber eine Sache fand ich doch ganz erstaunlich, die er da von sich gab in Bezug auf Twitter. Die.
Technische Disruption und Kommunikationsrevolution ist der Dreh- und Angelpunkt
einer metapolitischen Wende und das würde ich wirklich behaupten,
der Kauf von Twitter durch Elon Musk und die Öffnung von Twitter,
teilweise für rechts, ist wahrscheinlich insgesamt in der Wirkung ein wichtigeres
Ereignis weltweit als der Wahlsieg von Donald Trump und wird noch längere und
größere Folgen und Konsequenzen haben.
Ja, das ist Quatsch.
Das ist Quatsch, weil Twitter so wichtig für die Leute nicht ist.
Also Twitter ist nicht so.
Twitter niemand. Das haben wir doch bei Triggerpunkte wegen Irrelevanz ausgeschlossen.
Ich würde aber sagen, man sollte die Wirkung dieser rechten Metapolitik und
Politik auf TikTok und Twitter nicht geringschätzen in dem Form.
Aber ja, es gibt schon noch andere Rechte.
Scott Galloway betont ja immer wieder in Amerika, die jungen Leute unter 25
benutzen TikTok mehr als alle anderen Medien zusammen.
Und damit sind alle Medien gemeint. Von Social Networks auf ihren Displays,
Fernsehinhalte, über welche Streaming Plattformen auch immer.
Alles zusammen ist weniger als TikTok.
Haben wir noch einen Moment oder machen wir schon Schluss? Haben wir noch einen Moment?
Wir haben noch einen Moment.
Du willst nichts mehr zeigen, dann hätte ich noch was.
Jeff Bezos verschieben wir. Wir machen ja immer vor dem Salon auch eine Folge.
Mittlerweile die wechseln wir ein bisschen mehr. Die hat nicht so hoher Abruf
wie der Monatsend-Podcast.
Also das, was da als Teaser so erscheint, ist eigentlich doch nochmal eine kleine Folge. Da.
Werden wir Jeff Bezos nochmal würdigen. Ich fand das echt interessant, was er da gesagt hat.
Dann machen wir das Im Teaser bringe ich das nicht noch einmal mit,
sondern wir machen es jetzt hier.
Wir sprechen noch kurz über YouTube. Heute machen wir mal richtig digital.
Und zwar ist dir da auch vielleicht was aufgefallen bei YouTube mit den Mikrofonen.
So geht es zumindest Tom Nikolas und der hat darüber ein sehr langes Video gedreht
auf seinem YouTube-Kanal.
YouTuber haben Mikrofone in der Hand. Ja, und welche Mikros?
Das ist das Lavelier-Mikrofon, das Lav-Mic zu seinen Freunden.
Und das ist besonders wichtig.
Because this microphone, this tiny little microphone, this is specifically designed
to be as invisible as possible.
Das stimmt. Wir sehen das überall.
Also die Leute haben dieses winzige Ansteckmikrofon. Ich habe ja auch so eins
in der Filmanalyse, aber ich habe es am Revers natürlich.
Aber die Leute tragen es jetzt in der Hand und dann stellt man sich die Frage,
warum machen die das jetzt eigentlich? eigentlich.
Und er leitet das ziemlich gut her.
Und zwar gibt es da so eine US-Plattform, die auch so, ja, wahrscheinlich wie
News bei uns in Deutschland ist. Die heißt PragerU.
Und dort werden ja solche komischen rechten Inhalte fabriziert.
Und die produzieren, die machen Fernsehen auf YouTube.
Und machen das so hyperprofessionell. Und er sagt jetzt folgendes dazu.
So.
Und wie sehen diese PragerU-Videos aus?
Die Videos sind schlecht. Es ist kind of hard to substantiate.
From a technical point of view, they're nothing if not perfectly proficient.
They're well lit, in focus and regardless of your thoughts on their clip art
library, the editing is pretty positive.
Es ist alles auf Hochglanz getrimmt. Es ist also ganz weit von dem,
was früher mal die ugly Internet genannt wurde.
Und die These ist jetzt hier, man nimmt wieder so ein Mikro an die Hand,
man möchte sich ganz deutlich davon unterscheiden.
Also man sagt damit, wir haben hier ein Lavellier-Mikrofon in der Hand,
wir machen hier kein Fernsehen.
Denn im Fernsehen würde man sich das anstecken und würde man auch darauf achten,
dass das Kabel nicht sichtbar ist etc.
Aber als wirklicher YouTuber macht man das nicht. Er sagt weiter.
Und.
Wir fragen uns, wo ist eigentlich dieser klassische YouTube-Look hin?
Nicht völlig marginalisiert, aber ihre Position als integral zu dem,
was es bedeutet, ein YouTube-Video zu sein, ein YouTube-Video zu sein,
scheint unter Threat zu sein.
Und das ist der Hintergrund, gegen den YouTubers angefangen haben.
Das hätte ich eben zu TikTok noch erwähnen können. Immer mehr Fernsehsender
gehen zu TikTok, wir öffentlichen dort, überlegen jetzt auch oder tun es bisweilen
schon, eigene Formate für TikTok zu entwickeln.
Die großen Häuser, die großen Medienhäuser sind also da präsent und so ist es auch bei YouTube.
Far more likely to be elevated to the trending page than those of native YouTubers.
When it came time for YouTube Rewind
2019, an obvious effort was made to foreground creator-made content.
Ja, und das bestätigt sich bei mir auch auf der Empfehlungsseite.
Ich würde sagen, das meiste, was ich angezeigt bekomme, ist von großen Medienhäusern
und ich sehe nicht mehr die kleinen YouTuber oder die größer gewordenen kleinen einen YouTuber.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen, die Judy Woodrow, die ja ganz lange PBS News Hour
moderiert hat, war jetzt bei Carys Fischer im Podcast und meinte auch nochmal,
ja, wir spielen jetzt alles auf YouTube aus und,
sehr gute Annahme des Publikums, obwohl ich ja finde, dass die PBS News Hour,
ich gucke sie ja häufiger im Fernsehpodcast, immer noch so sehr altbacken,
also so wie so ein 90er Produkt daherkommt, aber irgendwie dann doch sehr beliebt.
Zu diesen Mikros will ich mal noch, das ist ja wirklich ein Wespennest,
wenn man so drüber nachdenkt.
Als das alles aufkam mit diesem wir machen jetzt auch von zu Hause aus Video.
Und das hat ja kann man sich ja in Deutschland immer noch nicht also es hat
ja extrem lange gedauert,
Bis Interviewgäste im Fernsehen von zu Hause aus einfach das selber machen.
Das ging ja wirklich nur mit der Corona-Pandemie los.
Und jetzt ist das dauerhaft. Also dass wir irgendwelche Politiker so zugeschaltet von zu Hause.
Die haben natürlich immer schlechte Technik zu Hause, weil man sich so fragt,
wie bei Slavoj Zizek oder so.
Wenn du Millionen und Millionen verdienst, musst du echt immer in so ein blecherndes
Laptop-Mikro reinsprechen.
Kannst du 200 Euro ausgeben? Ist das möglich?
Geht irgendwie nicht bei ihm und so. Und wir kennen ja noch von Bibi damals.
Damals, Bild, naja gut, sie saß halt mit einer relativ guten,
aber damals dann doch nicht ausreichenden Kamera in ihrem Schlafzimmer und hat
den Kameraton genommen.
Und zwar um der Anmutung, du redest hier mit einer Freundin,
die kauft sich auch nicht extra ein Mikrofon.
Also wir sind ja mehr auf der Sprachnachrichten, Videotelefonie-Ebene als auf
Massenmedium, obwohl sie ein Millionenpublikum hatte und so.
Und dann kamen diese ersten YouTuber, die ersten Podcaster ins Fernsehen durch was auch immer.
Also ich denke so ein Leo Lapport, der ja auch ganz lange alte Medien gespielt
hat, dann mit Twit sein neues.
Und dann war die erste Anfrage, die Frage immer, ja können sie das Mikro noch aus dem Bild stellen?
Wir machen das so im Fernsehen, wir verstecken die irgendwie.
Also ne, sie reden hier mit einem Podcast, bei uns ist der Ton das Allerwichtigste.
Ich habe jetzt so ein riesiges Mikrofon und das war ja so Mode irgendwie,
dass nicht nur das Mikrofon, sondern auch der Kameraarm im Bild der Let's Player
hing, bis dann irgendwann der Techniksprung soweit war, dass man sich so Videos
angeguckt hat mit diesem neuen Mikrofon, das ist ein Richtmikrofon,
das ist dann nicht mehr im Bild.
Hängt man auch, solche Mikro-CVs jetzt haben irgendwo in den Raum und vertraut
darauf, dass die Technik das schon entsprechend macht. Also das Mikro rutscht
eigentlich wieder raus.
Bis es dann, und dann musste ich beim Lavalier an diese Straßen umfragen.
Also irgendwelche Typen machen irgendwelche Straßenumfragen und da ist ja die
ganze Zeit, dass dieses Kabel da immer noch so hängt.
Da würde ich sagen, das hat so einen praktischen Nutzen, aber so klein es ist,
so auffällig ist es dann doch, dass man da so komisch rumhantiert.
John Philipp nutzt wieder so ein Startmikrofon um seine Instagram-Ansagen zu
machen, finde ich auch interessant, Ola hat klassischerweise das Larry King
Mikro auf dem Tisch stehen, um dann seine Monologe da zu machen,
also wohin mit dem Mikro ist noch nicht entschieden Ja.
Was ich gerade am häufigsten tatsächlich aber sehe, ist das Lavalier-Mikrofon,
also das kleine Ansteck-Mikro zwischen Zeigefinger und Daumen hat und dann da
rein spricht und das hat ja ja sowas von absolutem Improvisiertem.
Ja, wir haben es da, weil es ist so, ja, das ist irgendwie nicht so ideal,
aber ich mache es jetzt mal so, aber was man ja damit ausdrückt ist,
die Botschaft ist so wichtig, ich kann mich jetzt um diesen anderen Kram nicht kümmern.
Und diese Dringlichkeit, die da drin steckt und dann auch diese sehr nahe Aufnahme,
die dann oft gewählt wird bei TikTok oder bei den Insta-Reels,
Das ist glaube ich etwas,
was so einen unprofessionellen Charakter gibt, aber worauf dann Tom auch eingeht, Tom Nikolas,
dass sehr viele Medienhäuser jetzt solche Formate produzieren.
Also dass da auch jetzt jemand eigentlich 100.000 Euro im Jahr vom Sender bekommt,
aber hier kriegst du so ein Lavaliermikrofon, geh mal raus auf die Straße, mach da eine Umfrage.
Das wird aber nur kurz so sein. Also das ist ja die, wir verzichten auf das
blaue Tagesschau-Studio für 25 Millionen, weil wir wissen, das gilt zwar als
seriös, aber wir wollen es ja authentisch.
Und authentisch ist wie der Sehgewohnheit jedermann. Also dann rennt man wieder
mit dem billigsten Kram rum.
Aber der neueste Dreh ist ja, und das gefällt mir auch wirklich sehr gut,
weil das auch fürs Ohr sehr gut ist.
DJI hat zum Beispiel zuletzt das Mic 2 vorgestellt. Du hast so eine kleine Kiste,
da sind zwei Mikrofone drin und ein Empfänger.
Typischerweise brauchte man immer noch den Empfänger, ich habe auch so ein paar
Sachen da, der einfach das Funksignal entgegenhält und so.
Jetzt hast du aber schon in der GoPro die Möglichkeit, das Mikro einfach per
Bluetooth zu verbinden.
Du kannst also die AirPods Pro, die Apple eigentlich wirklich nur entwickelt
hat, um nur mit dem iPhone zu funktionieren,
an die GoPro anschließen, so dass du die GoPro draußen ans Auto dran machst,
du lässt dich durch die Scheibe bei 100 kmh filmen und der Ton kommt aber aus
dem Mikro, das bei dir im Ohr steckt.
Also da verschwindet das Kabel schon und mit diesem ganzen DJI-Kram oder GoMic
und wie auch immer, hast du das ganze Mikro in dieser kleinen Ansteckgröße,
aber dann kein Kabel mehr.
Was bedeutet, die Leute machen sich das einmal fest, vertrauen darauf,
dass das Video den Ton schon entsprechend aufnimmt, stellen die Kamera irgendwo
hin und der Ton ist trotzdem gut.
Und ich hoffe, dass sich dieses, also das quasi Lavalier, aber ohne Kabel durchsetzt,
immer ein bisschen kleiner natürlich nochmal wird,
so mit ein bisschen mehr aus dem Bild verschwindet und dann haben wir endlich
wieder einen Status Quo in dieser wichtigen, was mache ich mit dem Ton? Ja.
Nur glaube ich, dass es ja hier um eine rein ästhetische Frage geht.
Also wahrscheinlich, wenn das funktioniert, ist das ja sehr viel sinnvoller.
Aber sinnvoll kann es ja eigentlich nicht sein, dass man mit einem Lavalier-Mikrofon am Finger rumläuft.
Ja.
Das ist eine Brückentechnologie.
Nee.
Ich glaube nicht, das wird ja hier schon auch deutlicher, es ist keine Brückentechnologie,
sondern es ist eine bewusste ästhetische Entscheidung, die sagt,
wir sind nicht wie das offizielle YouTube,
wie das, was die Sender jetzt machen, wir sind nicht hyperprofessionell,
sondern wir entscheiden uns, das direkt so zu machen, es hat keine Funktionalität.
Also bei der ZDF-Hitparade in den 70er Jahren sang man ja mit Mikrofon und Kabel
und es hatte sich irgendwie eingebürgert,
dass die Schlagersänger dieses Mikrofon-Kabel einmal so herumtreten,
dass so diese Schleife entstand und also traten alle immer mit dieser Kabelschleife auf.
Weil sie Angst hatten, dass es rausgezogen wird und so.
Was in dem Sinne unsinnig war, aber man hat es gemacht und es war dann so ein
ästhetischer Look, der sich durchgesetzt hat und ich glaube auch hier haben
wir was ähnliches und wir können jetzt mal so ein Beispiel von Politics Joe,
den ihr da erwähnt, der von einem großen Medienhaus ist, aber auch so ganz,
ja fast stümperhaft auftritt.
Es gab doch dieses Buch, die Stunde der Stümpfer, so eine Kritik an Internet
und den Amateuren vor etwa zehn Jahren.
Und jetzt will man natürlich von allen Seiten versuchen, wenigstens die Ästhetik
der Stümpfer zu bedienen.
In den USA gibt es ähnliche Tränen des Internets, die in der Outdoor sind.
Joe. Das exzellente Vertikal der neuen Medienfirma Joe.
Elemente von intentioneller Unvergleichbarkeit sind am meisten in der Channel-Serie
von satirischen Musikremixen eindeutig, die,
von der Arbeit von Kassettboy aus, die Worte britischer Politiker aufschneiden
und Autotune-Tracks auswählen, die Regierungs- und Kontroversien,
Aber es läuft durch die Channel-Branding und sogar zu ihrem Podcast, dem Pubcast,
Ja.
Man hat, wenn man sich diese Videos ansieht, den Eindruck, da sitzen Podcast-Bros
zusammen, die reden da in ihrem Mikro und wie man das so kennt.
Toll, dass es sowas auch gibt, aber nein, da steckt das ganz große Geld dahinter.
Hier noch ein kleines Fazit.
Thought it could add an additional layer of fun to their own videos.
But the artistic choices of both creatives and audiences are often guided by
underlying cultural anxieties.
Ja, das sind am Ende Modetrends, die niemand durchschaut, aber alle befolgen.
Entweder durch ich mach mit oder bewusst nicht.
Aber solange es gut klingt, finde ich schon mal gut und die Richtung geht in es klingt gut.
Also der gute Ton ist, wir sind aus dem Bibi-Zeit Alter, endlich raus,
es ist nicht mehr zu anstrengend.
Videos zu hören Wir sind am Ende aber lass mich noch zum Schluss einen Hoffnungsschimmer
abspielen, den mir eine Hörerin,
sendete und zwar sind so viele schlechte Nachrichten jetzt von uns verbreitet
worden hier wieder, was heißt, wir haben sie aufgegriffen und versucht zu analysieren
und man schaut dann mitunter in eine düstere Zukunft,
aber wir haben vielleicht die Rechnung ohne den Wassermann gemacht.
Das ist jetzt das aktuelle Sternzeichen. Und es gibt die Leute von Human Design
Tribe eine, wie soll ich sagen, dubiose Astrologie und weiß ich nicht was,
Company mit Homepage und erfolgreichem Insta-Kanal und so weiter.
Und da erscheinen Videos.
Und eines dieser Videos hat mir eine Hörerin geschickt. Und dann dachte ich,
das will ich doch mit allen teilen, dass wir gar nicht so pessimistisch sein müssen. Okay.
Bin gespannt.
Hör zu.
Wie ihr bestimmt schon alle gemerkt habt, ändert sich gerade kollektiv wahnsinnig viel.
Das liegt daran, dass wir uns gerade auf den Zeichenwechsel im Pluto vorbereiten.
Und das Ganze findet aktuell aus junger Seinsicht im Tor 60 statt.
Steinbock im Pluto hat mir jetzt 20 Jahre lang die Energie von Transformation
aller Machtstrukturen, der Autoritätsstrukturen und so weiter.
Gerade in letzter Zeit mit dem Tor 60 durften wir die ganzen Grenzen,
die dadurch entstanden sind oder sich verändert haben, akzeptieren lernen.
Ja, mit dem Wassermann bekommen wir jetzt Schnelligkeit, Fortschritt,
Innovation, soziale Gerechtigkeit, Individualität.
Der Start mit Tor 60 wird sein, dass der Wassermann gegen all die alten Grenzen
des Steinbocks protestieren möchte und sie auflesen möchte.
Naja, also da kann doch eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe das auch angeklickt, das ist ja ein riesiges Konglomerat
an verschiedenen Leuten, die immer die gleiche Botschaft und so weiter.
Ja, das ist manifestieren mit Sternen.
Es ist skurril, aber es ist, wie es ist. Glauben wir ihr einfach.
Wir glauben ihr einfach. Ja, wir weisen nochmal darauf hin, im Salon werden
wir über das Buch Im Grunde gut von Rutger Pregmann sprechen,
sicherlich auch diskutieren.
Wir werden im Salon Teaser dann noch über Jeff Bezos und sein Interview reden.
Ich werde ein kleines Büchlein noch mitbringen von Eric Ollenwright.
Warum Klasse zählt, also warum wir von der Klasse auch als Kategorie widersprechen müssen,
um Gesellschaft zu verstehen und es gab in der Financial Times einen Artikel
darüber, dass die Frauen toleranter, progressiver werden,
die Männer immer konservativer, regressiver, die Jungen und zwar weltweit.
Und ich will erstmal diese Zahlen wiedergeben, will es aber auch mal ein bisschen
einordnen und vielleicht können wir das eine oder andere davon mal ableiten.
Wir sind ja da in unserem Safe Space.
Weißt du, was Scott Galloway zu den Zahlen gesagt hat? Das ist eine große Mating
Opportunity für Männer, die einfach mal nicht die konservative Wende mitmachen,
sondern für sehr viel mehr Frauen interessant sind, wenn sie auch einfach mal modern im Kopf sind.
Das zum Beispiel, ja. Hast du schon was im Auge, was du uns mitbringen wirst?
Nur den angekündigten Alexander Thiele, der greift sich ja die gängigen,
also konkreten europäischen Visionen für eine Veränderung und Reform der Europäischen
Union auf, wo auch immer sie publiziert werden.
Geht sie dann durch und nennt das ja defekte Visionen oder so.
Wer weiß, wir kriegen nochmal ein Update zum Thema, was sollten wir jetzt von
der Europäischen Union halten, kurz bevor wir relevante Teile ihres Personals neu bestimmen.
Sehr gut. Und den Salon, wir sagen es nochmal ganz kurz, kann man buchen über
Steady, das präferieren wir, es ist ganz einfach.
Neu20er.de, dort findet ihr den Button, um zu Steady zu kommen.
Mit wenigen Klicks ist das getan oder man kann über Spotify zu Steady gelangen.
Man kann auch über Apple den Podcast buchen oder wenn man schon dort ist, bei Patreon.
Und dann sehen wir uns im Februar und gucken mal, ob der Mensch tatsächlich im Grunde gut ist.
Ja, so ist es. Sind wir gespannt. Bis denn.